THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER. AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL ACOSTA
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ALLEN ARAMBULA BAKER BERMAN.
BIGELOW BLOOM.
BONTA BROUGH. BURKE CABALLERO
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES
CHAU.
CHAVEZ CHEN DAVID CHIU CHOI.
KANSEN CHU COOLEY.
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY. DALY
EGGMAN.
LARA.
FONG FRAZIER. FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GRAY. GRAYSON HARPER HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER-DOVE. KILEY LACKEY
LEVINE LIMON OWN. LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA. MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL. PATTERSON QUIRK QUIRK
SILVA. REYES RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO STEINORTH STONE.
THURMOND.
TING VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WOOD.
MISTER SPEAKER
REPORT TO THE FLOOR.
WITH LOTS OF BUSINESS BEFORE THE
ASSEMBLY TODAY PLEASE REPORT TO
THE FLOOR
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR.
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND BOB OSHITA REVEREND
OSHITA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
WHILE MY WIFE PATTY NINE A
WEARING KYOTO JAPAN ELEVEN DAYS
AGO.
WE HEARD ABOUT THE SHOOTINGS AT
FORT WORTH HIGH SCHOOL IN FORT
WORTH TEXAS.
TEN KILLED. THIRTEEN INJURED.
ONCE AGAIN THE INNOCENT VICTIMS
FOR STUDENTS AND TEACHERS.
THIRTEEN WEEKS AND THREE DAYS
EARLIER ON VALENTINE'S DAY
AFTERNOON.
WE WERE ALL HORRIFIED TO WATCH
THE UNFOLDING NEWS FROM PARKLAND
FLORIDA'S STONEMAN HIGH SCHOOL.
SEVENTEEN DEAD FIFTEEN INJURED.
AT THAT TIME WE HEARD OFFICIALS
SPEAKING OUT SAYING. THE
VIOLENCE HAS TO STOP.
WE MUST MAKE SURE THIS NEVER
HAPPENS AGAIN.
CNN REPORTED THAT THERE HAD BEEN
TWENTY TWO SCHOOL SHOOTINGS THIS
YEAR.
SIXTEEN RESULTING IN INJURY OR
DEATH.
THEN JUST LAST FRIDAY.
NOBLESVILLE MIDDLE SCHOOL IN
INDIANA WAS ADDED TO THE GROWING
LIST OF SCHOOLS VICTIMIZED BY
GUN VIOLENCE.
ONCE AGAIN LET US OPEN OUR
SESSION TODAY WITH LOVING
KINDNESS.
FOR ALL FAMILIES WHO CONTINUED
TO RECOVER FROM SENSELESS
VIOLENCE.
AND WOULD LOVING GRATITUDE FOR
ALL WHOSE EFFORTS AND SACRIFICES
ARE DEDICATED TO MAKING OUR
WORLD A BETTER PLACE.
NOW MORE ON. WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING. AND JOIN US
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STEINORTH. AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
STEINORTH THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER PLEASE JOIN ME AS WE
SALUTE OUR NATION'S BLACK.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
TAKE.
IT IS.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
WEDNESDAY MAY SIXTEENTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN RECENTLY MET AT SEVEN
A. M. ON BOTH THIS YEAR AND
AGUIAR-CURRY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOURTH DISTRICT PRESIDING CHIEF
QUICKLY EVOLVING WILSON AT THE
TOASTER CALDERON. MOVES MISTER
LACKEY SECONDS.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE OF BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY THERE ARE
NO ABSENCES TODAY
MEMBERS WE ARE AT PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN NAY TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TEAMED UP GUESTS
AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON. THE FLOOR
TODAY'S GUEST WILL BE SEATED AT
HIS DESK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER S. B. SIX
NINETY FIVE LADA. FROM THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION AGAINST SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
ADOPT FLOOR AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
PENDING AT THE DESK.
THE FOLLOWING BILLS ITEM TO A
ONE AB TWENTY NINE SEVEN FIVE
FRIEDMAN ITEM TO A FOR AB TWENTY
ONE SIXTY FOUR COOLEY. ITEM TO
SIXTY A. B. NINETEEN FORTY
MCCARTY.
ITEM THREE TWENTY SIX AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY ONE CARILLO ITEM
THREE FIFTY AB TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED KALRA ITEM THREE FIFTY
THREE LOW. ITEM THREE SIXTY
SEVEN AB TWENTY SIX THIRTEEN RAY
AS ITEM THREE EIGHTY AB TWENTY
SEVEN OH FOR O'DONNELL. AN ITEM
FOR FORTY ONE A. B. THIRTY TWO A
SEVEN LIMON.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED THANK YOU MISTER
CITIES ARE PRINTED BACK ON.
I'M.
I MOVE TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX B. TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORY TO TAKE UP
LATE AMENDMENTS TO ITEM TWO
TWENTY NINE A. B. THIRTY ONE
THIRTY ONE.
THIS WATER FOR WHAT PURPOSE. WE
OBJECT TO THE AIR.
MOTION ANNOUNCEMENT WORLD MS
WALDRON WITHHOLDS MISTER
CALDERON MOVES.
AND MR GIPSON SECONDS.
THAT THE RULES BE SUSPENDED
MEMBERS AS A ROLL CALL VOTE THIS
A PROCEDURAL VOTE THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE OF MY PARENTS ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THE RULES
SUSPENSION.
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR IT I MISS
WALDRON AND NO.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
I..
AND MISS WALDRON IS ASKING FOR
NO.
PROCEDURAL VOTE MEMBERS.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE I FORTY THREE
KNOWS NINETEEN THE RULES.
ARE SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS IF I COULD HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION WE HAVE SOME VERY
SPECIAL GAS WITH US.
IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FILLED SAYING.
I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME HIS WIFE
SUSAN SON AND THEIR DAUGHTERS
ELEVEN YEAR OLD ISABELLA. AND
EIGHT YEAR OLD MADDY MS SON IS
IN THE GALLERY AND THE GIRLS ARE
AT HIS DESK LET'S WELCOME THEM
TO THE ASSEMBLY
AND MEMBERS OF I HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION.
MR TANG ALSO HAS A SCHOOL GROUP
VISITING THE CHAMBER TODAY THEY
ARE IN THE GALLERY WELCOME
PRINCIPLE KLAUS AND THE ENTIRE
FOURTH GRADE CLASSROOM JOSE
ORTEGA ELEMENTARY SCHOOL. IN THE
SAN FRANCISCO LET'S WELCOME THEM
TO THE CHAMBER.
AND FINALLY ALSO IN THE GALLERY
FOR MR TANG WE HAVE GIRL SCOUT
TROOP NUMBER SIX TWO SIX ONE
FOUR FROM SAN FRANCISCO. THEIR
GROUP LEADER IS MISS SUSAN SIGN.
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT SECOND
READING.
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE TWENTY
FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS SEVENTEEN
THIRTY FOUR SEVENTEEN FORTY
THREE SEVENTEEN SIXTY TO
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
SEVENTEEN NINETY THREE. EIGHTEEN
OH ONE EIGHTEEN FIFTY EIGHT
EIGHTEEN SIXTY EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
ONE EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY THREE NINETEEN
SIXTEEN NINETEEN NINETEEN.
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE NINETEEN
TWENTY SEVEN NINETEEN THIRTY
THREE NINETEEN FORTY FIVE
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE NINETEEN
SIXTY ONE NINETEEN SEVENTY.
NINETEEN NINETY TO NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT TWO THOUSAND AND
FIVE TWO THOUSAND AND SIX TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
THIRTY. TWENTY THIRTY FOUR
TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN TWENTY FORTY
ONE. TWENTY FORTY THREE TWENTY
FIFTY TWENTY FIFTY EIGHT TWENTY
SIXTY TWENTY SIXTY ONE TWENTY
SIXTY FOUR TWENTY EIGHTY THREE.
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT OH FIVE TWENTY EIGHT
NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY. TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY SIX TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
ONE TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY ONE
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY FOUR. TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY TWENTY EIGHT NINETY TWO
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY THREE TWENTY
NINE SIXTY TWENTY NINE SIXTY ONE
TWENTY NINE SIXTY FIVE TWENTY
NINE EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY NINE. TWENTY NINE NINETY
EIGHT THIRTY OR SIX THIRTY OH
NINE THIRTY TWENTY ONE THIRTY
EIGHTY THIRTY EIGHTY ONE THIRTY
EIGHTY TWO THIRTY EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTY EIGHTY NINE.
THIRTY NINETY SIX THIRTY NINETY
SEVEN THIRTY ONE TEN THIRTY ONE
EIGHTEEN THIRTY ONE NINETEEN
THIRTY ONE THIRTY NINE THIRTY
ONE FORTY SIX THIRTY ONE FIFTY
THREE. THIRTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE SEVENTY SIX THIRTY
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY TWO EIGHTEEN
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
FOUR FORTY SEVEN. TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY FIVE TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
NINE TWENTY FOUR SIXTY ONE
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY FOUR. TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN TWENTY FIVE A FOUR
TWENTY FIVE A FIVE TWENTY FIVE
OH SEVEN. TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT TWENTY
FIVE FORTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY ONE TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
FIVE.
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY EIGHT TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY FIVE
NINETY THREE TWENTY FIVE NINETY
SIX TWENTY FIVE NINETY SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE NINETY NINE TWENTY
SIX OH SIX. TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY SIX THIRTY NINE
TWENTY SIX FORTY ONE TWENTY SIX
FORTY NINE TWENTY SIX FIFTY TWO.
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY FOUR TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY ONE TWENTY SIX NINETY
THREE TWENTY SIX NINETY SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN NO SIX TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
EIGHT. POINT SEVEN FORTY NINE
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY ONE TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY ONE TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY NINETY ONE.
TWENTY ONE OH SIX TWENTY ONE
TWELVE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY ONE THIRTY SIX TWENTY ONE
THIRTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE FIFTY
THREE. TWENTY ONE SIXTY ONE
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY ONE TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY TWO TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
SIX TWENTY ONE EIGHTY NINE
TWENTY TWO OH SEVEN TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN TWENTY TWO TWENTY.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO
TWENTY SIX TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY TO THIRTY THREE. POINT
TWO THIRTY FOUR TWENTY TWO FORTY
SEVEN TWENTY TWO SEVENTY FIVE
TWENTY TO SEVENTY SIX POINT TWO
NINETY THREE. 23-14 TWENTY THREE
SEVENTEEN TWENTY THREE THIRTY
FOUR AT TWENTY THREE THIRTY FIVE
TWENTY THREE THIRTY SIX TWENTY
THREE THIRTY EIGHT TWENTY THREE
FORTY TWO. TWENTY THREE FORTY
THREE TWENTY THREE SIXTY THREE
TWENTY THREE SIXTY SEVEN TWENTY
THREE SIXTY EIGHT POINT THREE
SEVENTY TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
SEVENTY THREE EIGHTY ONE TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY TWO. TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY FOUR AND THIRTY TO FIFTY
SEVEN.
THANK YOU KATHLEEN.
ALL BILLS ARE BEING READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED
.
MEMBERS BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
CONCURRENCE ITEMS
.
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY THREE PASS
MEMBERS WE ARE ON CONCURRENCE
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY FOUR IS AB
TWENTY TWO FORTY THREE.
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO FORTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
AND ACTUALLY THE EVIDENCE.
MS FRIEDMAN MEMBERS.
MS FRIEDMAN YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AMENDMENT MADE TO AB TWENTY TWO
FORTY THREE IN THE SENATE DID
THE FOLLOWING IT CLARIFIED THAT
EVIDENCE AS OF AN. OF AN ACTOR
PROSTITUTION IS IT ADMISSIBLE IN
A SEPARATE PROSECUTION OF THE
SEX WORKER WHO WAS THE VICTIM OR
WITNESS TO A VIOLENT FELONY.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS FREEMAN.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF OF.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE OF ON I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY FIVE ACR TWO HUNDRED
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWO HUNDRED BY SOMETHING NUMBER
BAKER AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION MONTH.
MS BAKER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND CONCURRING IN THE
AMENDMENTS FROM THE SENATE AND
ACR TWO HUNDRED THEY ARE
TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING THIS
BILL DECLARES THE MONTH OF APRIL
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AS CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION MONTH I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE IN CONCURRENCE
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT CLERK WILL OVER THE
ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE OF AND I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS.
OUR CONCURRED IN.
ON RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEMS
ONE SIXTY EIGHT THROUGH ONE
SEVENTY THREE.
WILL BE CONTINUED.
MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO THE THIRD
READING FILE.
FILE ITEM ONCE EVERY FOREST'S AB
TWENTY NINETY NINE BY MISTER
GLORIA OPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINETY NINE
BY SOME A MEMBER GLORIA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE MENTAL
HEALTH.
MISTER GLORIA.
THEY CAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
RESENT AB TWENTY NINETY NINE
THIS BILL.
IS MEANT TO RESPOND TO THE
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS THAT WE'RE
FACING NOT JUST IN THE STATE BUT
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY SPECIFICALLY
THE BILL ESTABLISHES THAT A COPY
OF THE FIFTY ONE FIFTY PAPERWORK
SUBMITTED. TO A MILLION AS
PSYCHIATRIC FACILITY SHALL BE
TREATED AS THE ORIGINAL DOCUMENT
IS ARTIST ANY THAT FOR SOME.
INSTANCES. FOLKS ARE ABLE TO
FIND PSYCHIATRIC BEDS ARE BEING.
NOT ALLOWED TO ENTER THOSE BEDS
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF OFFICIAL
PAPERWORK LIMAY DESPAIR SHOULD
HELP MORE PEOPLE TO GET THE CARE
THEY NEED I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THINK IT WAS GLORIA SENIOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK LIBERAL. ON MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THOUGH ON MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TELL THEM WHAT I
SIXTY SEVEN. KNOWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES WERE PASSING
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY FIVE.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEMS ONE SEVENTY SIX.
THROUGH ONE EIGHTY FOUR.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY FIVE AB TWENTY THREE
NINETY TWO MISTER SANTIAGO
CORPORATE.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY THREE NINETY
TWO BY SOME MEMBER SANTIAGO
ACTUALLY TELLING IN STORAGE OF
VEHICLES MISTER SANTIAGO.
FIGURES SPEAKER.
AB TWENTY THREE NINETY TWO MAKES
A NUMBER OF CLARIFICATIONS AND
CHANGES TO CLOSE THE LOOP ON
CALIFORNIA'S TOWING VEHICLE
STORAGE LAW. TO REDUCE ABUSIVE
PRACTICES AIMED AT INCLUDING
STORAGE FEES.
IT WOULD ENSURE THAT CONSUMERS
ARE NOT HELD HOSTAGE EXCESSIVE
STORAGE AND TOWING FEES WHICH
CAN LEAD A VICIOUS CYCLE NOT
BEING ABLE TO HAVE ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT NECESSARY ASSETS.
THIS THAT TRANSPORTED OBVIOUSLY
SUPPORT THEMSELVES IN THEIR
FAMILY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE IN. THANK YOU.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS
WHEN EIGHTY SIX AND ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN PASS AND RETAIN WE'RE
GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY A FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT.
AS WELL AS FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
NINE WERE PASSING TEMPORARILY
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEMS ONE
NINETY ONE NINETY ONE.
THAT BRINGS US FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY TWO.
AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY SEVEN BY
MISTER BLOOM.
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM ACTUALLY TO HOUSING
RICHARD BLOOM YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER RECENT
COURT CASE CAL NELL GARDENS
VERSUS CITY OF LOS ANGELES HAS
UNDERMINED THE APPLICATION OF
MELLOW AND DENSITY BONUS LAW. IN
THE COASTAL ZONE IN THAT CASE
THE DEVELOPER PROPOSED A SMALL
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT THAT
INCLUDED AFFORDABLE UNITS.
AT WERE IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
MELLOW ACT AND THE DENSITY BONUS
UNDER OUR STATE LAWS.
AND ALTHOUGH THE PROJECT WAS
CONSISTENT WITH BOTH LOCAL
PLANNING AND ZONING AND DENSITY
BONUS LAW THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
DENIED THE PROJECT ON THE BASIS
THAT THE INCREASED DENSITY. MADE
THE PROJECT VISUALLY
INCOMPATIBLE WITH THE
SURROUNDING NEIGHBORHOOD IN
VIOLATION OF THE COSTA LACK. THE
APPELLATE COURT UPHELD THIS
DENIAL FINDING THAT THE COASTAL
ACT SUPERSEDES DENSITY BONUS LAW
AND IF. NOT CORRECTED THIS
DECISION WILL LIKELY PREVENT
DENSITY BONUS LAW FROM BEING
USED AT ALL ANYWHERE IN THE
COASTAL ZONE AND UNDERMINE THE
PRESERVATION OF PRODUCTION OF
HOUSING. UNDER THE MELLOW ACT
THE RESULT WILL BE FEWER
AFFORDABLE UNITS WITHIN THE
COASTAL ZONE THAT'S A RESULT
THAT WE CAN. NOT AFFORD AND SO
AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY SEVEN
WILL CLARIFY OPPOSED PROVISION
IN DENSITY BONUS LAW TO ENSURE
THAT A PROJECT. CANNOT BE FOUND
IN CONSISTENT WITH THE COASTAL
ACT MERELY BECAUSE IT RECEIVES A
DENSITY BONUS.
INCREASE UNDER STATE LAW.
I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT WE'VE
WORKED OUT ALL OF THE CONCERNS
THAT THE COASTAL COMMISSION.
AND OTHER OPPOSITION HAD ON
THIS BILL AND THEREFORE ASK YOU
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THING IS BLOOM SEEING THEIR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
QUIRK LIBERAL ON MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARAB VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLLER TIME ABOUT I.
SIXTY NINE NEWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
PASS RETAIL FILE ITEM ONE NINETY
THREE. WHERE FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY FOUR? AB THIRTY ONE
THIRTY EIGHT CORPORATE AS SOME
PEOPLE THIRTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT
BY SOME A MEMBER MURATSUCHI AND
ACTUALLY TO HAZARDOUS MATERIALS
MISTER MURATSUCHI. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT. WELL
MAKE REFINERIES AT OTHER
FACILITIES AND HANDLE HIGHLY
TOXIC AND FLAMMABLE CHEMICALS
SAFER BY HOLDING THEM
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE SAFETY OF
WORKERS AND COMMUNITIES. BEFORE
RELEASES FIRES AND OTHER
ACCIDENTS ARISE.
THIS BILL.
HAS THROUGH OUR AMENDMENTS ALL
OPPOSITION HAS BEEN REMOVED.
FROM.
THIS BILL AND IN THIS PREVIOUS
HEARING. OWE IT WILL INCREASE
THE MINIMUM DAILY CIVIL PENALTY
FOR VIOLATIONS OF ACCIDENTAL
RELEASES. WHETHER WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE RICHMAN. O. OR
REFINERY OR THE TORRANCE
REFINERY IN MY DISTRICT THIS
WILL HELP ENSURE THAT WE HAVE.
WELL ACTUAL DETERRENCE TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR REFINERIES AND
OTHER FACILITIES ARE HANDLING
THESE HIGHLY TOXIC CHEMICALS IN
A SAFER MANNER I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A AYE VOTE.
THEY RISK MURATSUCHI SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
LOCAL OF NARAL. ON MEMBERS VOTER
SARAH VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE
ALL THE VOTERS ARE VOTE
MR WORSE
MEMBERSHIP AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
NINE.
I MISTER GRAY THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
NINE BY SELLING MEMBER GRAY AND
ACTUALLY THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR.
MISS GRAY YOU MAY OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY NINE WILL
PROHIBIT. A POLITICAL APPOINTEE
FOR MAKING A CONTRIBUTION OR
PROVIDING A GIFT TO A LEGISLATOR
OR ANY COMMITTEE CONTROLLED BY
THAT LEGISLATOR DURING THE
PERIOD IN WHICH THE APPOINTEES
SEEKING CONFIRMATION.
UNDER EXISTING LAW AS WE KNOW
ALL TOO WELL ON THE HEELS OF THE
RECENT FORM SEVEN HUNDRED
DEADLINE. GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
LEGISLATORS LOBBYIST LOCAL
PUBLIC OFFICIALS AND OTHER
GROUPS TO INTERACT WITH THE
POLICY MAKING PROCESS ARE
SUBJECT TO THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT.
THE LAW REQUIRES US TO REPORT
GIPSON CONTRIBUTIONS GIVEN AND
RECEIVED SHAREHOLDER INTERESTS
REAL PROPERTY INTERESTS AND
OUTSIDE EMPLOYMENT AMONG OTHER
THINGS.
AS NOTED BY THE F. PPC ITSELF
THE GOAL OF THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT.
PREVENT BIASES ACTUAL IN
APPARENT THAT RESULT FROM
FINANCIAL INTEREST OF DECISION
MAKERS.
HOWEVER POLITICAL APPOINTEES WHO
HAVE NOT YET BEEN CONFIRMED BY
THE LEGISLATURE FACE NO
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AND NO
ADDITIONAL SCRUTINY BY THE F.
PPC.
AS A RESULT IN INDIVIDUAL
SEEKING THE CONFIRMATION VOTE OF
A SENATOR OR THE SELLING MEMBERS
FREE TO PROVIDE GIFTS AND OR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THOSE
LEGISLATORS FOR PERSONAL GAIN.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE
VOTE.
THE MYSTERY MISTER HARPER YOU'RE
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I WOULD COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING TO END THE APPEARANCE
OF CORRUPTION WITHIN THE
CAPITAL.
I BELIEVE IT IS A NOBLE EFFORT.
BUT THIS BILL DOES LITTLE TO
ADDRESS THE ROOT OF THE PROBLEM.
RARE THAN LIMIT THE CORE OF
CONTRIBUTIONS TO SENATORS AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO CONFIRM A
POLITICAL APPOINTMENT. WE SHOULD
ALSO LIMIT CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
ONE PERSON RESPONSIBLE FOR
MAKING THE NOMINATION.
IN A RECENT ARTICLE BY THE LOS
ANGELES TIMES THE HIGHLIGHTED
MULTIPLE APPOINTMENTS BY THE
CURRENT AND FORMER GOVERNOR THAT
HAVE MADE. UP THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE INFLUENTIAL FINANCIAL
CONTRIBUTIONS INCLUDE ONE
INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS APPOINTED TO
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
AFTER DONATING TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED DOLLARS TO
GOVERNOR BROWN'S CAMPAIGN.
THE SECOND INDIVIDUAL WAS
APPOINTED TO THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL AFTER MAKING THE SAME
DONATION.
A THIRD INDIVIDUAL. WAS
CONTINUALLY APPOINTED TO THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION AFTER DONATING
THOUSANDS TO GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER'S AND GOVERNOR
BROWN'S CAMPAIGNS.
AND A FOURTH INDIVIDUAL
CONTRIBUTED FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO GOVERNOR BROWN'S
CAMPAIGN BEFORE BEING
REAPPOINTED AS CHAIR OF THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD.
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
THIS BILL IS WOEFULLY INCOMPLETE
BECAUSE THE REAL ISSUE HERE OUR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE GOVERNOR
NOT NEARLY CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
SENATORS AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
WITHIN THIS BODY.
MY OFFICE TRIED TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE TO AMEND THIS
BILL TO INCLUDE THE GOVERNOR AND
I EVEN. I SPOKE ABOUT THESE
OBJECTIONS WELL IN THE ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE BUT THEY WERE
UNRESPONSIVE AND WAITED UNTIL
AFTER THE DEADLINE TO EXPLAIN
WHY THEY WOULD NOT ACCEPT MY
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
THIS BILL AS I SAID IS WOEFULLY
INCOMPLETE AND NOT READY FOR A
VOTE AND AS A REASON WHY WILL
NOT BE VOTING FOR THIS BILL
TODAY EVEN THOUGH I RECOGNIZE
THE EFFORT. IT IS WOEFULLY
INCOMPLETE AND I URGE NO NO VOTE
ON THIS BILL.
THERE'S HARPER SENIOR ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
MR GRAY YOU MAY CLOSE.
MEMBERS IS IMPORTANT BILL THAT.
BRINGS THE APPOINTEE PROCESS A
PROCESS UNDER THE PUT REFORM ACT
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
ABOUT.
WITH THAT CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO IS OUT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF
AND I SEVENTY. KNOWS ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS BACK IN THE REGULAR FILE
ORDER.
I BELIEVE WE'RE FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY FIVE.
THAT IS AB NINETEEN OH SIX
COOPERATE ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN
A SIX BY SOME A MEMBER IRWIN AND
ACTUALLY THE BUSINESS
REGULATIONS. MISSOURI WHEN YOU
MAY OPEN.
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT AB IN NINETEEN
OH SIX THE INTERNET OF THINGS
BOTNET PREVENTION ACT.
THIS BILL IS THE PRODUCT OF
EXTENSIVE COLLABORATION BY MY
OFFICE IN THE TECH INDUSTRY TO
ADDRESS A CRITICAL CYBERSECURITY
PROBLEM. ONE THAT IS ONLY
FORECAST TO GET WORSE
THIS BILL REQUIRES MANUFACTURERS
TO EQUIP CONNECTED DEVICES WITH
REASONABLE SECURITY FEATURES
APPROPRIATE TO THE DEVICE. TO
PREVENT UNAUTHORIZED REMOTE
ACCESS OR USE
I'M STILL WORKING WITH INDUSTRY
AND OTHER PARTNERS ON THIS BILL
TO IRON OUT SOME FINAL DETAILS
BUT THIS MEASURE WHEN ENACTED
WILL SECURE ARE SMART HOMES AND
SMART CITIES. FROM BEING
LEVERAGED AGAINST US
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AS OUR OWN.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DOES ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DECIDED THOUGH?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE ANTI ABOUT ICE
FOUR NINE THOSE TWELVE THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS RETAIN ON
FILE ITEMS ONE NINETY SIX AND
ONE NINETY SEVEN.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM
ONE NINETY EIGHT.
THAT'S AB TWENTY TWENTY BY DR
QUIRK THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWENTY BY
FAMILY MEMBER QUIRK AND ACTUALLY
CANNABIS DOCTOR QUIRK.
AB TWENTY TWENTY.
THE GRANT CITIES THE AUTHORITY
TO APPROVE VENUES FOR TEMPORARY
CANNABIS RELATED EVENTS.
RIGHT NOW IF THE CITY OF LA
WHERE TO WANT TO SPONSORED
EVENT.
BOB THAT A CANNABIS FESTIVAL OF
SOME KIND ITWOULD HAVE TO DO IT
IN THE COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS OUTPUT
MONA.
IF UNDER CURRENT LAW.
OF THERE IS NO.
DISCRETION.
THIS IS LIMITED MANY CITIES AND
LOCAL COMMUNITIES LIKE OAKLAND
AND REVEALS SACRAMENTO. THAT
EXPRESSED INTEREST IN PER
PERMITTING CANNABIS USE IT
SPECIAL TEMPORARY EVENTS.
BUT HER BARD UNDER CURRENT LAW.
AB TWENTY TWENTY GIVE CITIES
FULL CONTROL REGARDING TEMPORARY
EVENT VENUES AND TEMPORARY
PERMIT APPROVALS.
AGAIN
IT CAN ONLY HAPPEN. IF THE CITY
ITSELF WANTS TO HAVE THAT
FESTIVAL.
CITY COUNTY OR STATE REGULATIONS
REGARDING CANNABIS CONSUMPTION
OR SECONDHAND SMOKE. ARE NOT
SUPERSEDED MY OFFICE CONTINUES
TO WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING THE BUREAU OF CANNABIS
REGULATION.
TO GIVE THE BUREAU STRONGER
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY AN AD
EXPLICIT PROTECTIONS.
AGAINST VENDORS YOU ARE NOT
PERMITTED.
A PLAN TO TAKE THESE AMENDMENTS
IN THE SENATE.
AGAIN AB TWENTY TWENTY HAS BEEN
CRAFTED THROUGH DIALOGUE WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT THE INDUSTRY AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
IT HAS NO OPPOSITION. AND ITS
STRENGTHENS THE ABILITY TO
REGULATE THESE EVENTS.
AND ALLOWS THEM TO OCCUR IN THE
CITY THAT ACTUALLY WANTS THEM AS
OPPOSED TO A CITY THAT DOESN'T.
I ASK YOU ARRIVE VOTE AND I HOPE
I CAN GET FIFTY FOUR.
THANK YOU.
WE HOPE SO TO DUCK WORK
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLICK LOVE THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
WHO STARTED ON MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR
DOCTOR QUIRK.
DOCTOR QUIRK MOVES TO CALL
.
MEMBERS FOR PASSING AND
RETAINING ON FILE ITEMS ONE
NINETY NINE AND TWO HUNDRED.
WE'RE AB APART ME WEIRD FILE
ITEM TO A ONE.
CORRECTION MEMBERS ARE PASSING
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY NINE.
THAT'S AB TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN
PASSING TEMPORARILY.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM TO A
ONE THIS IS A BE.
WE TOOK THAT AMENDMENT UP IN THE
BATCH ITEMS FILE ITEM TO A TWO.
PASS AND RETAIN WE ARE FILE ITEM
TO A THREE.
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY TWO BY
MISTER FRAZIER CARBERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN NINETY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
AND ACTUALLY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
MISTER FRAZIER HE MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY I PRESENT IT
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN NINETY
TWO. TO HELP IMPROVE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO READ VALUE
VALUABLE TOOL CREATED LAST YEAR
WITH AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AUTHORITIES.
AS YOU KNOW THE HOUSING CRISIS
IN CALIFORNIA DOES NOT ONLY
AFFECT LOW INCOME BUT
INCREASINGLY HARD WORKING MIDDLE
INCOME FAMILIES.
THESE AUTHORITIES WERE SET UP TO
PROVIDE FOR WORKFORCE HOUSING UP
TO ONE HUNDRED TWENTY PERCENT OF
THE AREA. MEDIAN INCOME.
WITH INFANTS STRUCTURE COST.
MAKING UP ABOUT NINE PERCENT OF
THE AVERAGE PROJECT BECAUSE WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPORTING THESE
PROJECTS. WORKS CORRECTLY.
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY TO EXPAND
THE SCOPE OF OF AN AUTHORITY TO
INCLUDE PROVIDING FOR WATER
SEWER ELECTRICAL STREETS AND
OTHER IF THE SCRIPT
INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY FOR.
A WORTHWHILE PROJECT.
THIS IS THE COMMONSENSE APPROACH
AND ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK WE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
QUICK LOVE THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
USER TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL TIED UP
EYES FIFTY ONE KNOWS SEVENTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES WE'VE
DISPENSED A FILE ITEM TO A FOR
FILE ITEM TWO OH FIVE.
THE TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE
CORKERY.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
NINE BY THREE MEMBER GIPSON AND
ACTUALLY UTILITY SERVICE.
MISTER GIBSON.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE OF
TODAY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE WHICH
SEEKS TO IMPROVE THE SEWER
INFRASTRUCTURE IN CALIFORNIA.
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES A TWO
THIRDS VOTE FOR CITIES ARM AND
ITS RESIDENTS
A SALE A SEWER SYSTEM SINCE THE
COST OF THE ELECTION CAN BE
COSTLY AND IT VERY EXPENSIVE
POST MALL CITIES. HAVING THIS
VOTE THRESHOLD IS PROBLEMATIC.
THIS WOULD THEREFORE ALLOW
CITIES TO CONSOLIDATE ITS SEWER
SYSTEM WITH A MAJORITY VOTE.
AFFRONT IT'S COUNCIL AND LOCAL
RESIDENTS THIS BUILDING COURAGE
OF VOLUNTEER.
CONSOLIDATIONS AND ULTIMATELY
IMPROVE OUR STATE SEWER
INFRASTRUCTURE THIS BILL RECEIVE
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND HAS
RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GIBSON MISTER
GALLAGHER.
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS THE HOUSE WILL BE IN
ORDER.
THE HOUSE WILL BE IN ORDER
.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOT HAVE
DISRUPTION IN THE GALLERY.
I'M GOING TO REQUEST THAT THE
SERGEANTS.
REMOVE
DISRUPTIVE.
MEMBERS OF THE GALLERY
MEMBERS THE HOUSE WILL BE IN
ORDER.
MISTER GIBSON YOU MAY PROCEED
WITH YOUR ITEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH MY BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GIPSON.
HE KNOW FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK LEVEL
THERE ALL.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
GO.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL ANTI THE VOTE I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
I WOULD ASK MEMBERS OF THE
GALLERY TO REFRAIN FROM.
CLAPPING OR. MAKING ANY OTHER
DISRUPTIVE SOUNDS WE HAVE LOTS
OF BUSINESS BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY
TODAY.
MEMBERS WE GONNA MOVE BACK IN
THE FILE THE FILE ITEM ONE.
NINETY NINE.
THAT IS A V. TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN
BY MISTER KALRA.
CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN
BY SOME A MEMBER KALRA AN
EXCELLENT CANNABIS.
MISTER KALRA YOU MAY OPEN.
I DON'T THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS.
SO THE BILL TWENTY TWO FIFTY
WOULD ALLOW.
WOULD ALLOW VETERINARIANS
DISCUSS THE USE OF CANNABIS
WITHOUT FEAR.
OF LOSING THEIR.
MISTER KALRA YOU MAY PROCEED.
I'M GOING ASSN THE SERGEANTS
CLEAR THE GALLERY OF DISRUPTIVE.
MEMBERS.
MMHM.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
A BRIEF RECESS.
SO WE MAKE CLEAR THIS CHAMBER WE
HAVE LOTS OF BUSINESS BEFORE THE
HOUSE.
WE ARE IN RECESS
MEMBERS.
WE'RE BACK IN SESSION PLEASE
RETURN OF FLOOR
MEMBERS WE ARE SESSION.
RESUMING SESSION THIS IS FILE
ITEM. ONE NINETY NINE.
THAT'S AB TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN BY
MISTER KALRA THE CLERK WILL
READ.
IT'S SOMETHING I'LL TWENTY
FIFTEEN BY FAMILY MEMBER KALRA
AND ACTUALLY CANNABIS.
MISTER KALRA EMAIL ME.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
SOME OF BILL TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN.
WHAT ALLOW BETTER NEW YEAR
VETERINARIANS TO DISCUSS THE USE
OF CANNABIS WITHOUT FEAR OF
LOSING THEIR LICENSE? ENABLES
CANNABIS FOR MEDICINAL ANIMAL
USED TO BE ACCESSIBLE TO
CONSUMERS AND REGULATED
DISPENSARIES.
AND WHEN I SAY DISCUSSION I MEAN
THE CLIENT IS COMING IN WITH
QUESTIONS ABOUT POLITICS ARE
SEEING ON THE STORE SHELVES THIS
IS AT OPPOSES CBD OILS.
AND THEY WANT TO KNOW THEY'RE
GOING TO BE HELPFUL FOR THEIR
ARTHRITIC. ARTHRITIC OR CANCER
RIDDEN PET.
CONTRARY TO WIDELY HELD
KNOWLEDGE VETERINARIANS DO NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE THE SAME
PROTECTIONS THAT POSITIONS ARE
GIVEN I IN DISCUSSING CANNABIS
IN THEIR PRACTICE.
THE CALIFORNIA VETERINARY
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION SUPPORTS AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN.
AND RECENTLY SHOWED.
SHOULD BE BOTH SIR BROCHURE FOR
A PET CBD PRODUCT.
THAT WAS MAKING THE CLAIM IT IN
CURE CANCER FOR THE PAT.
THOSE WILD CLAIMS ARE NOT GOOD
FOR THE ANIMAL OWNING CONSUMER.
HOWEVER CANNABIS HAS SHOWN
PROMISING MEDICINAL AND
THERAPEUTIC BENEFITS FOR ANIMALS
BECAUSE THE POSSESS SIMILAR AND
OKANAGAN NO IT'S SYSTEMS LIKE
HUMANS.
LASTLY THE BILL INSURERS THESE
CANNABIS PRODUCTS MEDICINAL
ANIMAL USE ONLY CAN ONLY BE
ACCESSED AND ARE REGULATED
FRAMEWORK.
THIS IS WHY BUSINESS GROUPS LIKE
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION SUPPORTS AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTEEN AM.
THE BILL ALSO HAS STRONG SUPPORT
FROM SOCIAL COMPASSION IN
LEGISLATION
ONE OF THE LEADING ANIMAL
WELFARE ADVOCACY GROUPS BECAUSE
THEY SEE THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH. AN IMPROVEMENT TO WHAT
MANY LOVING PET OWNERS ARE
ALREADY DOING.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
IT I DON'T. THINK YOU MISTER
KALRA MISTER BIGELOW YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE.
TO TO GIVE A LITTLE CLARITY TO
THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
WHEN IT WAS IN A PROBE.
I ACTUALLY TOOK A POSITION OF
OPPOSITION TO THIS MY RAISE THE
ISSUE TO THE AUTHOR AND THE
AUTHOR HAS. AGREED TO WORK WITH
MY OFFICE AND TRY TO FIND A
RESOLUTION TO THIS PARTICULAR
MATTER. HE HAS GOT A ACTUALLY
LEGITIMATE POINT WHEN IT DEALS
WITH THE VETERINARIANS AND
TRYING TO CLEAR UP THAT THE
DIFFERENCE ON THIS PRODUCT. BUT
WHAT WAS REALLY LEFT ANONYMOUS
IN THE US WAS THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE TWO TYPES OF ACTIONS
THAT WOULD BE OCCURRING HERE.
ONE WOULD BE FOR SMALL ANIMALS
THE OTHER WOULD BE FOR LIVESTOCK
THAT ISSUES FOR INGESTING.
THE PRODUCTS THAT WE EAT.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS TO
US AS CONSUMERS THIS COULD
ACTUALLY BE SOMETHING THAT COULD
BE HARMFUL. IT COULD BE
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY HELPFUL WE
DON'T KNOW BUT I CAN TELL YOU
THAT THERE ARE SEVERAL WAYS THAT
YOU CAN. ADMINISTER THIS PRODUCT
THE LIVESTOCK IT'S EITHER
THROUGH ORAL.
IT'S THROUGH INJECTABLE BOTH.
AYE INTRAMUSCULAR AND
SUBCUTANEOUS OR TOPICAL.
AGAIN THE AUTHOR HAS AGREED TO
WORK ON THIS AND I WANT IT
PLEDGE MY OFFICE IS SUPPORT TO
FIND A SOLUTION TO THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE.
THANK YOU MISTER COLOR.
THANK YOU YOU SPEAKER THANK YOU
MISS BIGELOW MISTER HARPER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
IF I CAN ASK QUESTION THE
AUTHOR.
THAT'S WITHOUT OBJECTION.
I IN TERMS OF ANIMALS ARE USED
FOR TRANSPORTATION FORCES AND
OTHERS HOW WOULD THIS AFFECT.
FORCES OR OTHER ANIMALS THEY'RE
USED FOR TRANSPORTATION OF
PEOPLE ON OUR ROADS.
THANK YOU MISS HARPER MISTER
KALRA.
YOU MAY ADDRESS THAT NOW OR.
CLOSE.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. MISTER KALRA.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I
WANNA THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THEIR COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS IN
REGARDS TO THE OTHER QUESTION
REGARDING IN TRANSPORTATION
AGAIN. ABA THE IDEA BEHIND THIS
BILL ON ONE OF THE MAIN
COMPONENTS IS TO ALLOW THE
VETERAN A BOARD TO SET
GUIDELINES NOT LET ME OR OTHERS
GUESS AS TO WHAT IS NEEDED. BUT
ACTUALLY MOVE PET CANNABIS INTO
A REGULAR FRAMEWORK AND THAT
WOULD INCLUDE ANSWERING
QUESTIONS SUCH AS WHAT TO DO IN
TRANSPORT AS WELL AS THE VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION. REGARDING
LIVESTOCK AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I'M
CERTAINLY COMMITTED TO WORKING
ON BECAUSE WE KNOW WHEN IT COMES
TO OUR. LIVESTOCK THEIR ISSUES
BOTH IN TERMS OF TRANSPORTATION
AS WELL AS IT ENSURING THE FOOD
STREAM. AND SO THOSE ARE ISSUES
THAT I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK ON. I THINK
THAT THE THAT AGAIN.
PREPARING GUIDELINES I'M ALLOWS
US TO HAVE AN INFORMED
CONVERSATION AND EVENTUALLY
INFORMED REGULATIONS AS TO HOW
THESE PRODUCTS THAT ARE ALREADY
BEING GIVEN. TO ANIMALS CAN
BETTER BE.
INSTRUCTED THAT ARE
VETERINARIANS CAN KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT IT IS.
BAD THEY ARE ADVISING ON AND
THE DISPENSARIES WILL KNOW AS
WELL AGAIN THIS IS NOT REQUIRE
ANY VETERINARIAN. OF THE TO DO
ANYTHING THAT THEY DO NOT CHOOSE
TO DO WHAT IT DOES ALLOW IT'S A
PERMISSIVE BILL THAT ALLOWS
VETERINARIANS RIGHT NOW THEY
CAN'T EVEN DISCUSS CANNABIS.
WOULD ALLOW THE PEOPLE THAT WE
WANT TO BE DISCUSSING CANNABIS
WITH THE PATIENT OWNERS ARE
VETERINARIANS TO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DISCUSS IT. IN ALL
OUR BATTERY ABOARD A SET UP
GUIDELINES BOTH FOR PETS LA AND
DOES HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THEIR
PETS AS WELL AS OUR IN REGARDS
TO LIVESTOCK TO ENSURE. THAT
WE'RE NOT DOING ANYTHING OTHER
THAT ADVISING AND OFFERING UP
APPROPRIATE MEDICATION TO A TO
OUR ANIMALS.
BOB AND THIRD AGAIN IT WOULD
ONLY ALLOW. CANNABIS TO TO BE IS
DISPENSED.
IN THE DISPENSARIES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY REGISTERED AND ALLOWED
TO DISPENSED THROUGH OF THE WORK
OF OUR BUREAU AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SO IN NO WAY WITH
THIS ALLOW AN EXPANSIVE. ABILITY
FOR CANNABIS TO BE DISPENSED BY
VETERINARIANS OR ANYONE ELSE AND
SO. IT'S ACTUALLY A COMMON SENSE
BILL ONE THAT WILL ALLOW FOR PET
OWNERS TO. BRING RELIEF TO THEIR
PETS AGAIN FOCUS ON ONLY
MEDICINAL CBD NOT TEENAGE SEE I
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AIBO.
FAMOUS COLLAR. WITH THAT CLERK
LIBERAL. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS SO CZAR THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS HER DESSERT ABOUT
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL THOSE VOTERS ARE VOTE.
MISTER KALRA YOUR PLEASURE MOVE
CALL.
IT'S KALRA MS CALL.
MEMBERS BACK IN FILE ORDER WE
ARE FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO ZERO
SIX FILE ITEM TWO OH SIX.
IS AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY FIVE
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
FIVE BY SOME THE MEMBER CHILD
AND ACTUALLY TO CODE
ENFORCEMENT.
MISTER JO. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
FIVE WOULD PROHIBIT A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER OR HEALTH OFFICER FROM
BEING ACCOMPANIED BY A PERSON.
WITH A POTENTIAL FINANCIAL
INTEREST IN THE OUTCOME OF THE
INSPECTION OF A COMMERCIAL
PROPERTY OR BUSINESS FOR
COMPLIANCE WITH THE STATUE
REGULATION OR LOCAL ORDINANCE.
THIS BILL STEM FROM A SITUATION
IN MY DISTRICT WHERE THE OWNER
OF AN AUTO BODY SHOP UNDERWENT A
BUSINESS PERMIT INSPECTION
DURING WHICH.
TIME THE CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER WAS ACCOMPANIED BY THIRD
PARTY CONTRACTOR.
AFTER THE OFFICER CITED A NUMBER
OF ISSUES AND LEFT THE THIRD
PARTY CONTRACTORS STAYED BEHIND
AND OFFERED TO FIX ALL OF THE
ISSUES FOR THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
BUSINESS OWNER WAS PREVIOUSLY
QUOTED TO PAY ONLY TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS BY HIS INITIAL
ARCHITECT.
FEARING DELAYS IN THE. PERMIT
APPROVAL PROCESS THE OWNER WENT
WITH A THIRD PARTY CONTRACTOR
BUT ALSO SUSPECTED BEING THE
VICTIM ALL THE HOW IMPROPER
SCHEME. THIS BILL TWENTY FORTY%
FIVE LIMIT SITUATIONS THAT WOULD
ALLOW LAW THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CODE ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS. OF
FROM BEING ACCOMPANIED BY THIRD
PARTY INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR
TONY SITUATIONS WHERE THE
INDIVIDUAL IS THERE FOR
LEGITIMATE REASONS.
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE.
NAME IS CHELSEA NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLICK LIBERAL ON MEMBERS.
THIS OUT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW IT ABOUT
AYE SIXTY THREE KNOWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES WE ARE PASSING
RETAINING ON FILE ITEMS TO OF
SEVEN AND TO AWAIT.
WHERE FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO OH
NINE?
THAT IS A J. OUR THIRTY FIVE.
BY MISTER LEVINE THE CLERK WILL
READ
ASSEMBLY TRACK RESOLUTION THIRTY
FIVE BY SOME OF THEM MAY LEVINE
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO A POLISH
LONG SPEECH RELATED TO THE
HOLOCAUST. MICHELIN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER IS AND
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
VIRULENT ANTI SEMITISM IS ON THE
RISE BETWEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. ANTI SEMITIC
INCIDENTS ROSE FIFTY SEVEN
PERCENT THAT THAT'S THE LARGEST
ONE YEAR INCREASE SINCE THE ANTI
DEFAMATION LEAGUE HAS TRACKED IN
THE UNITED STATES. IN FRANCE AND
ANTI SEMITIC ASSAULT IS REPORTED
ON AVERAGE TWO TO THREE TIMES A
WEEK ACROSS EUROPE IS MUCH THE
SAME STORY IN RUSSIA.
HATE MONGERS TOOK TO SOCIAL
MEDIA IN MARCH TO CAST BASELESS
BLAME ON CHOOSE FOR A TRAGIC.
MALL FIRE THAT KILLED SIXTY
FOUR.
AND IN POLAND IN FEBRUARY
PRESENT ANDRE DO DA SIGNED AN
AMENDMENT TO THE LAW ON
INSTITUTE OF NATIONAL
REMEMBRANCE THAT THREATENS UP TO
THREE YEARS IN PRISON MERELY FOR
SUGGESTING. THERE WAS POLISH
COMPLICITY WITH* ATROCITIES
DURING WORLD WAR TWO.
THIS IS LITERALLY A LAW AGAINST
TALKING ABOUT THE TRUTH LET'S BE
CLEAR.
POLLS SUFFERED AT THE HANDS OF
THE* AND MANY POLL FOUGHT
BRAVELY IN RESISTANCE
BUT THERE WERE INDEED
COLLABORATORS.
THAT IS HISTORICAL FACT.
WITH THIS RESOLUTION WE ADD OUR
VOICES TO THOSE THAT CALL ON
POLAND TO ABANDON THIS LAW OUR
STATE DEPARTMENT HAS EXPRESSED
SIMILAR SENTIMENTS MANY MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS HAVE AS WELL.
WHAT WE'RE ASKING IS THAT
CONGRESS TAKE FORMAL ACTION TO
ENCOURAGE PRESIDENT DO DOT? TO
REVERSE COURSE
MEANWHILE WE WANT TO KEEP OUR
OWN HOUSE IN ORDER THIS
RESOLUTION ALSO REAFFIRMS
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO
HOLOCAUST EDUCATION.
EDUCATION IS INCREASINGLY
IMPORTANT. A STUDY THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT JUST IN APRIL
DURING THE HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE
CEREMONY FOUND THAT TWO THIRDS
OF MILLENNIALS DO NOT KNOW WHAT
AUSCHWITZ'S.
THERE WERE OVER FORTY THOUSAND
CAMPS AND GHETTOS DURING THE
HOLOCAUST IN THE SURVEY FOUND
THAT FORTY NINE PERCENT OF
MILLENNIALS COULD NOT NAME ONE.
SIMON WIESENTHAL* HUNTER
SAID FOR YOUR BENEFIT LEARN FROM
OUR TRAGEDY
IT IS NOT WRITTEN LAW BUT THE
NEXT VICTIMS MUST BE JEWS.
IT CAN ALSO BE OTHER PEOPLE
WE SOUGHT BEGIN IN GERMANY WITH
THE JEWS BUT PEOPLE FROM MORE
THAN TWENTY OTHER NATIONS WERE
ALSO MURDERED. IN ORDER TO MAKE
SURE LAWS LIKE POLAND SHOULD NOT
CONTINUE TO IGNORE HISTORY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE MS
KAMLAGER-DOVE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THINK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I RISE
TO SUPPORT AJ OUR THIRTY FIVE.
IN DAY ARE THIRTY FIVE URGES
LAWMAKERS IN POLAND TO REVERSE A
RECENT LAW THAT WOULD
CRIMINALIZE SOME SPEECH RELATED
TO POLAND'S INVOLVEMENT IN THE
HOLOCAUST DURING THE* GERMAN
OCCUPATION OF POLAND.
CENSORSHIP CANNOT UNDO THE
TRAGEDIES OF THE PAST AND JUST
LIKE AMERICANS TODAY MUST TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR PAST
ATROCITIES SO SHOULD OTHER
NATIONS.
DENYING THE TRUTH ONLY INHIBITS
US FROM MOVING FORWARD AND
BECOMING BETTER AS WE
EXPERIENCED MOMENTS AGO HERE IN
THE GALLERY.
AJ OUR THIRTY FIVE IS TIMELY
BECAUSE WHILE POLAND ATTEMPTS TO
CRIMINALIZE THOSE WHO SPEAK OUT
ABOUT UNFLATTERING TRUTHS OF
THEIR ROLE IN THE HOLOCAUST.
ANTI SEMITISM ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AND THE UNITED STATES IS ON THE
RISE.
WE MUST REMAIN STEADFAST IN OUR
OBLIGATION TO NEVER REPEAT THE
MISTAKES OF THE PAST AND PART OF
THIS COMES FROM LEARNING ALL WE
CAN ABOUT WHAT HAS OCCURRED.
THIS RESOLUTION ALSO CALLS FOR A
RENEWED COMMITMENT TO HOLOCAUST
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA.
WE CANNOT DIMINISH THE IMPACT
THE COUNTRY HAD DURING THE
HOLOCAUST NOR CAN WE CHOOSE TO
OMIT UNFLATTERING TRUTHS BY
CENSORING SPEECH AND HINDERING
THE SEARCH FOR TRUTH.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I AM
PROUD TO SUPPORT AJ ARE THIRTY
SIX AND I URGE OUR SUPPORT TODAY
AS WELL.
THANK YOU SEEN NO ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION.
MR LEVIN WOULD YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE AJ ARE.
THE SURE LEVINE IS REQUESTING
THE FIRST WILL BE OPN FOR CO
AUTHORS CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON AJ OUR THIRTY FIVE THIS IS CO
AUTHORS AT AJ OUR THIRTY FIVE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE THERE
SIXTY ONE CO AUTHORS ADDED WE
WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE ON
THE H. A R. CLERK WILL ROLL-ON
PHOTO ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO GO ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK. WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
AND TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR
NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION.
IS ADOPTED.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS.
AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEM TO TEN.
WHERE FILE ITEM TO ELEVEN? THAT
IS AB TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE OH
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES
AND ACTUALLY THE NEW MOTOR
VEHICLES. MS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN
UPDATES THE LAWS GOVERNING THE
RELATIONSHIP.
BETWEEN AUTOMOBILE MANUFACTURERS
AND CALIFORNIA FRANCHISE NEW CAR
DEALERS TO BRING EQUITY TO THIS
VITAL RELATIONSHIP.
NEW CAR DEALERS OPERATING AS
LOCAL INDEPENDENTLY OWNED
FRANCHISED DEALERSHIPS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. EMPLOY OVER ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA. AND IN
SOME COMMUNITIES ARE THE MAJOR
SOURCES OF ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
IF WE AS A STATE ARE GOING TO
MEET OUR ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS AND
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF LOW
EMISSION AND ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES ON THE ROAD WE MUST
ENSURE THAT.
CALIFORNIA NEW CAR DEALERS ARE
NOT PUT IT THE DISADVANTAGE IN
RELATION TO THE OUT OF STATE
AUTOMAKERS.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT THE BALANCE
OF POWER BETWEEN LARGE
MULTINATIONAL AUTO MAKERS AND
CALIFORNIA'S NEW CAR DEALERS IS
A FAIR AND COMPETITIVE PLAYING
FIELD.
IN SPITE OF THE OPPOSITION OF
THE AUTOMAKERS AND THE REFUSAL
TO NEGOTIATE THIS BILL CONTINUES
TO NOW IT'S IN SCOPE AND ADDRESS
ISSUES THAT ARE RAISED BY
STAKEHOLDERS.
AB TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN IS VITAL
IN MAINTAINING THE BALANCE
BETWEEN OUR CALIFORNIA BASED NEW
CAR DEALERS AND MULTINATIONAL
CORPORATIONS OPERATING FROM
OTHER STATES.
I REQUEST.
SPECULATE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE.
NAME ADDRESS SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLICK LIBERAL. MEMBERS.
ROSARIO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE.
INTEL I LOVE I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM TO TWELVE.
IS AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY TO
COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE FIFTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER AND
ACTUALLY THE CAL FRESH.
DOCTOR WEBER YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO IS A BILL
TO HELP PREVENT HUNGER AMONG OUT
OF WORK CALIFORNIANS.
THE CURRENT FEDERAL RULE
ESTABLISHES THAT OUT OF WORK
RECIPIENTS OF CAL FRESHER
LIMITED TO THREE MONTHS OF EIGHT
ANY THIRTY SIX MONTH PERIOD.
CALIFORNIA HAS A WAIVER TO THIS
RULE AND IT IS A GOOD UNTIL
AUGUST OF THIS YEAR WHEN OUR
STATE WIDE WAIVER EXPIRES.
I REQUEST FOR CONTINUED WAIVER
FOR SOME COUNTIES WITH HIGHER
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES HAS BEEN
SUBMITTED AND IS CURRENTLY BEING
CONSIDERED BY THE WHITE HOUSE.
BUT A RECENT EXECUTIVE ORDER AND
THE NEWLY RELEASED TWENTY
EIGHTEEN FOR FARM BILL SUGGESTS
THAT THE FUTURE OF THESE AREA
WAIVERS DURING THIS TIME OF HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT. UNCLEAR THE TRUTH
OF THE MATTER IS THAT THE WORK
RATES AMONG CAO FRESH RECIPIENTS
ARE HIGH WOULD NEARLY EIGHTY
PERCENT OF ADULTS ABLE TO WORK
EARNING INCOME TO EMPLOYMENT.
BUT CAO FRESH IS THERE ALSO TO
HELP PEOPLE WHEN THEY ARE OUT OF
WORK OR BETWEEN JOBS AND CUTTING
PEOPLE OFF DURING THIS TIME
MAKES IT HARDER FOR THEM TO FIND
A JOB.
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO WOULD
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO
ESTABLISH THEY HUNGER THRESHOLD
THAT WOULD IDENTIFY WHEN A
PERSON IS TWO HUNDRED TO BE ON
EMPLOYABLE.
THE BILL DIRECTS THE DEPARTMENT
TO CONVENE A WORK GROUP OF
POSITIONS WERE EXPERT IN ADULT
HUNGER AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
SPECIALIST TO ESTABLISH THAT
PRESS CHAU AND DESIGNED
SCREENING TO BE USED. BY COUNTY
SOCIAL WORKERS ONCE IN PLACE A
PERSON WAS SCREEN IS BEING UNFIT
FOR WORK DUE TO HUNGER WILL BE
TEMPORARILY EXEMPT FROM THE
THREE MONTH TIME LIMIT. SIMPLY
PUT AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO
WOULD HELP PREVENT OUT OF WORK
CALIFORNIANS WERE GOING HUNGRY
ABOUT DOING SO INCREASES THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT THEY WILL GET
BACK TO WORK. IT IS CRUEL TO CUT
OFF LOW INCOME FAN AMERICANS WHO
DON'T HAVE ANY OF THE SOURCE OF
INCOME FROM ANTI HUNGER FOOD
HEALTH AND IS ALSO DOESN'T HELP
THEM FIND A JOB. AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY TWO WILL PREVENT THE
CHRONIC HUNGER AMONG OUT OF WORK
CALIFORNIANS AND I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO WHOEVER
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO GO.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE RURAL TYPE BUT I FIFTY
KNOWS EIGHTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES WERE FILE
ITEM TO THIRTEEN MAYBE TWENTY
ONE SIXTY TO COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE SIXTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVID CHIU
AND OTHERS ACTUALLY THE LAND
USE.
MISTER DAVID CHIU YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
TWO WILL HELP CALIFORNIA ADDRESS
THE WORST HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IN
OUR STATE'S HISTORY. AT A TIME
WHEN CALIFORNIA HAS TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT OF OUR NATION'S HOMELESS
POPULATION FORTY TWO PERCENT OF
AMERICA'S CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
WITH PUBLIC HEALTH OUTBREAKS
INTENT ENCAMPMENTS THROUGHOUT
OUR ENTIRE STATE.
WE ALL KNOW THAT PERMITS SUPPORT
OF HOUSING WHICH IS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PAIRED WITH SERVICES HAS
BEEN A VERY PROVEN METHOD OF
REDUCING HOMELESSNESS THAT IS
ALSO HIGHLY COST EFFECTIVE.
UNFORTUNATELY THOSE WHO BEEN
ATTEMPTING TO BUILD THIS HOUSING
OFTEN TELL US IT CAN TAKE YEARS
TO BUILD DUE TO LOCAL APPROVAL
PROCESSES.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO STREAMLINED
APPROVAL OF ONE HUNDRED PERCENT
AFFORDABLE DEVELOPMENTS INCLUDE
A MINIMUM PERCENTAGE OF
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING UNITS AS WELL
AS ON SITE SERVICES.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WILL BE
ALLOWED TO APPLY OBJECTIVE AND
QUANTIFIABLE DESIGN STANDARDS.
AS WE FINALLY BEGIN AS A STATE
TO START INVESTING IN
HOMELESSNESS AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WE NEED MORE CERTAINTY
FOR THOSE WHO ARE BUILDING THESE
UNITS SO THAT WE CAN GET THEM
ONLINE QUICKLY. ONE TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK MY FELLOW JOINT
AUTHORED FROM ORANGE COUNTY THE
TWO OF US HAVE SEEN HOW
HOMELESSNESS IS IMPACT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. ALL THE WAY FROM
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA DOWN TO THE
SOUTHERN PART OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL WILL
EXPEDITE SPORT OF HOUSING
ADDRESS OUR PROMISES CRISIS AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IBOOK.
RIGHT IN FRONT OF A MISTER DALY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS JUST TO. A TO ADD TO.
MISTER CHOOSE COMMENTS
SPELL WILL HELP PROMOTE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING IN AREAS WHERE CITIES
ALREADY PLANNED FOR AND ALLOW
MULTI FAMILY DEVELOPMENT.
IT'S SIMPLY ALLOWS FOR THE
EXPEDITIOUS CONSTRUCTION OF
THESE VIOLENT IMPORTANT PROJECTS
AND PROUD TO BE A JOINT AUTHORED
WITH MISTER CHIU. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
THEY INITIALLY SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
WORK WELL.
CLOSER ROLAND TYLER EYES FORTY
EIGHT KNOWS TWENTY.
THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WERE
FILED ON TO FOURTEEN.
THAT IS AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
NINE CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO NINETY NINE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KANSEN CHU AND ACTUALLY
THE MEDI CAL. MISTER KANSEN CHU
YOU MAY OPEN. CHECK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SOME MEMBER AYE RICE TWO
PERCENT AB. TWENTY TWO NINETEEN
AYE WHICH CODIFIED THE SIX GRADE
READING LEVEL REQUIREMENT FOR
MEDI CAL HEALTH EDUCATION AND
INFORMATION DOCUMENTS IN
ENGLISH.
FURTHERMORE THIS WORK A IT WILL
EXPAND THE REQUIREMENT TO
THRESHOLD LANGRIDGE.
LANGUAGES TO ENSURE THAT
READABILITY AND APPROPRIATENESS
OF COMMUNICATION TO MEDICARE
OPENED THE FISHERIES.
MY WILL ALSO INCORPORATE A ONE
TIME COMMITTEE REVIEW PROCESS
FOR EXISTING AND NEW DOCUMENTS.
TO GIVE NATIVE SPEAKER A CHANCE
TO REVIEW. AND PROVIDE FEEDBACK
ON DOCUMENTS IN THE STRUCTURAL
LANGUAGES.
OF.
THIS RIO ARE.
THE INSURED THAT DOCUMENTS SENT
TO THEM RATHER CAL BENEFICIARIES
ARE EASY TO READ AND UNDERSTAND.
ANY ENGLISH AND ALL OTHER
STRUCTURAL LANGUAGES
IN END IT IS A FIRST STEP TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
THE HOUSE. SERVICES AVAILABLE TO
THEM AND WHAT THEY NEED TO DO TO
KEEP THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES HEALTHY.
RECENT FLOOR AMENDMENT YOU SAM
DOCUMENTS THAT HAVE ALREADY GONE
THROUGH A REVIEW PROCESS TO
REDUCE COSTS.
THIS BILL THE BREAKDOWN LANGUAGE
BARRIERS AND PROMOTE BETTER
HEALTH. OUTCOMES I'D
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EUROPE
BIBLE.
THING WHICH YOU SEEN NOTICE
CASHED OUR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK LIBERAL I'M.
IT IS OUT OF VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO SARAJEVO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE TELL THE.
AYE AYES FORTY SEVEN OF TWENTY
TWO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WHERE PASS RETAIN A FILE INTO
FIFTEEN WERE FOUND TO SIXTEEN?
AB THIRTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT BY
MISS BURKE CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT BY SOME
A MEMBER BURKE AND ACTUALLY TO
SCHOOL FACILITIES. MS BURKE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT WHICH
AUTHORIZES SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
RECEIVERSHIP USE REVENUE FROM
THE SALE OF SURPLUS PROPERTY FOR
PAYING DOWN THE AMOUNT OWED TO
THE STATE. AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
INCLUDE UNIFIED IN MY DISTRICT
IS IN RECEIVERSHIP.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN RECEIVERSHIP
ARE BY DEFINITION IN FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP THE CURRENT SYSTEM HAS
NOT SUPPORTED THE STRUGGLING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO REVIEW THAT
SYSTEM AND TAKE THE NECESSARY
STEPS TO SUPPORT STRUGGLING
SCHOOLS. AB THIRTY TWO TWENTY
EIGHT TAKES A STEP IN
REEVALUATING THE RECEIVERSHIP
SYSTEM BY AUTHORIZING THE FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CURRENTLY IN
RECEIVERSHIP. OAKLAND UNIFIED
VALLEJO CITY UNIFIED KING CITY
JOINT UNION HIGH SCHOOL AND
INGLEWOOD UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO USE THE REVENUES
FROM THE SALE OR LEASE OF
SURPLUS PROPERTIES TO PAY DOWN
THE EMERGENCY LOAN ISSUED BY THE
STATE.
WE MUST ENSURE THAT THESE
SCHOOLS WHICH ARE STRUGGLING
FINANCIALLY OF A PATH FORWARD
TOWARD SUCCESS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST IT MIGHT.
THINGS WERE SAYING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CARP LIBERAL.
.
IT IS SAD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS FOR
THIS AREA VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ON TIED ABOUT ICE FIFTY
NO SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM TO SEVENTEEN IS AB
TWENTY THIRTY SIX.
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
WILL TWENTY THIRTY SIX BY
SELLING MEMBER GIPSON AND
ACTUALLY THE STATE CAPITAL.
SURE GIPSON. MMHM.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I COME IN
PEACE I MEAN YOU NO HARM.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THIRTY SIX.
WHICH IS THE CLEAN UP BE OATS TO
A MEASURE THAT WAS SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR TO EXTRAPOLATE A BUS
FOR THE LATE HONORABLE DOCTOR
MERVIN EMMETT D'ITALIE. IN THE
CALIFORNIA.
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
THIS BILL IS SIMPLY A UPDATES
THE NAMES OF ORGANIZATION
THEY'LL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
BUS I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISGIVINGS AND.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL FEEDBACK
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
SARAH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
I SEVENTY FOUR. NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
WHEN TO PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEMS
TO EIGHTEEN.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS RETAIN ONTO
EIGHTEEN PASS TEMPORARILY. UNTIL
NINETEEN.
PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEM TO
TWENTY.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM TO
TWENTY ONE AB TWENTY TWO FORTY
FIVE I MISTER BERMAN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY HALL TWENTY TWO FORTY
FIVE BY FAMILY MEMBER BERMAN AND
ACTUALLY TO ELECTIONS MISTER
BERMAN.
MISTER BERLIN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES.
I RISE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY TO
FORTY FIVE WHICH WOULD PROTECT
THE PRIVACY OF MINERS WHO HAVE
PRE REGISTERED TO VOTE. OVER ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS HAVE PRE
REGISTERED TO VOTE SINCE
CALIFORNIA'S PRE REGISTRATION
PROGRAM LAUNCHED IN SEPTEMBER
TWENTY SIXTEEN. AB TWENTY TO
FORTY FIVE WOULD CLARIFY THAT
THE PRE REGISTRATION DATA OF
MINERS WHO WILL NOT BE EIGHTEEN
BY THE NEXT ELECTION. BE KEPT
CONFIDENTIAL AND PROHIBITED FROM
DISCLOSURE THIS BILL WOULD ALSO
EXPAND EXISTING REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE THAT
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
PROVIDE THE SECRETARY OF STATE
WITH DATA ON PERSONS WHO HAVE
PRE REGISTERED TO VOTE.
COLLEAGUES I'M HEARTENED BY THE
EARLY ENGAGEMENT OF SO MANY
YOUTH AND IT IS OUR OBLIGATION
TO ENSURE THE PRIVACY OF MINOR.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THERE WAS BERMAN SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE.
COR CLUB THERE ARE.
ON THEM.
OBSERVER ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE A ROLL AND TELL
YOU ABOUT.
I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES WERE FILE ITEM TO
TWENTY TWO. AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY
THREE BY MS FRIEDMAN. CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO SIXTY
THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
AND ACTUALLY THE LAND USE THIS
FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS.
TODAY I AM PROUD TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY TWO SIXTY THREE TO ENSURE
A LOCAL HISTORIC CHARACTERS
MAINTAIN ONE SET OF EYES AND
ADOPTED FOR USE OF EXISTING
HISTORICAL STRUCTURES FOR MUCH
NEEDED USE. SUCH AS HOUSING OR
OTHER COMMERCIAL USES.
I WORKED DILIGENTLY WITH
HISTORIC PRESERVATION EXPERTS IN
MY COMMUNITY AND STATEWIDE ON
THE ISSUE OF INCENTIVIZING THE
RE USE AND ADAPTATION A
DESIGNATED HISTORIC RESOURCES.
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY THREE IS
MODELED OFF OF LA IS ADAPTED FOR
USE ORDINANCE AND ONE OF
GLENDALE HISTORIC PRESERVATION
INCENTIVES. BOTH ORDINANCES
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF PARKING
REQUIRED FOR THE ADAPTATION OF
CONVERSION OF REGISTERED
HISTORIC STRUCTURES.
PARKING REQUIREMENTS HAVE A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON THE
SUPPLY OF A COMMUNITIES
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND ON THE
REDUCE THE BUILDING FOR
COMMERCIAL USES.
PLANNING DEVELOPMENT
CONSTRUCTION OF PARKING SPACES
CAN AB UPWARDS OF FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO A PROJECTS COSTS AND
ULTIMATELY KILL A LOT OF
PROJECTS I KEEP A LOT OF THESE
HISTORIC BUILDINGS EMPTY.
AND ON USED.
INCREASED DEVELOPMENT OFTEN PUTS
HISTORIC FABRIC OF COMMUNITIES
AT RISK AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY
THREE INCENTIVIZE THE
PRESERVATION OF THESE REGISTERED
HISTORIC STRUCTURES THAT ARE
ADOPTED AND CONVERTED BY.
ELIMINATING ADDITIONAL PARKING
REQUIREMENTS FOR RESIDENTIAL USE
LOCATED WITHIN A HALF MILE OF
MAJOR TRANSIT. WERE GIVEN TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT REDUCTION AND
REQUIRE PARKING FOR NON
RESIDENTIAL COMMERCIAL USES.
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY THREE HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION IT WORKED
EXTREMELY WELL ON LOS ANGELES IN
GLENDALE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THEY WAS FRIEDMAN. SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
OR CLUB-PHONE MEMBERS FOR.
IS THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ON TIE THAT ICE FORTY
SIX.
KNOWS TWENTY THREE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TO
TWENTY THREE IS AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE CLIMATE
CHANGE.
WHICH BELOW.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THE
STATE'S CURRENT CLIMATE
ADAPTATION STRATEGY COMMONLY
REFERRED TO AS THE SAFEGUARDING
PLAN IS THE TRIENNIAL REPORT
WHOSE PURPOSE. IS TO IDENTIFY
STATE AND REGIONAL CLIMATE
CHANGE VULNERABILITIES AND
STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS THESE
VULNERABILITIES.
AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY EIGHT
BUILDS OFF OF THIS REPORT AND
ENSURES THAT AREAS MOST
IMPORTANT.
A CALIFORNIA'S LONG TERM
RESILIENCE ARE ADEQUATELY
ANALYZE AND CONSIDERED FOR LONG
TERM IMPACTS.
CLIMATE CHANGE INCLUDING SPRING
FED SOURCE WATERSHED SALMON AND
STEELHEAD STRONGHOLDS MOUNTAIN
MEADOWS AND ESTUARIES THESE ARE
CRITICAL ZONES FOR EVERYTHING
FROM SPECIES PRESERVATION TO
WILDFIRE PER PENSION. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THINK MISS BLOOM SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CORPS CORPORAL.
THE DESERT VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED AS ADAM THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK CLOSE ROLL TALIBAN EYES
FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY SIX.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
PASSING RETAINING AVAILABLE TO
TWENTY FOUR. WHERE FILE ITEM TO
TWENTY FIVE AB TWENTY SIX OH
FIVE?
KERKORIAN ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SIX OH FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
TO FOSTER CARE FACILITIES.
MISTER GIPSON.
OKAY MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I RISE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX OH FIVE OF WHICH WILL
ENSURE THEIR GROUP HOMES AND
FOSTER CARE FACILITIES HAVE
POLICIES THAT RESTRICT CALLS. TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT ON FOSTER YOUTH.
AS A LAST RESORT FOSTER YOUTH
HAVE BEEN ARRESTED FOR MINOR
ISSUES LIKE HAVING A FOOD FIGHT
WITH CAKE WITH ICING AND IT HAS
BEEN YOU HAVE BEEN.
CHARGE
AND ARRESTED.
A THESE CHILDREN ARE BEING
CRIMINALIZE FOR THEIR BEHAVIOR
IS TO BE EXPECTED AS A YOUNG
PERSON GROWING UP.
THIS MEASURE IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURE THAT WE DO NOT INCREASE
THE TRAUMA EXPERIENCE.
BY THESE YOUTH ARM AND MUST
FIND ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES THIS BILL
HAVE RECEIVED.
A BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
IN THE POLICY COMMITTEE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT I VOTE ON
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX OH
FIVE.
NAMES GIPSON.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CARP LIBERAL. MEMBERS.
IS THERE A VITAL MEMBERS VOTER
ZYDECO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE AROUND TAIWAN I SEVENTY
ONE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WERE FILE AND TO TWENTY
SIX AB TWENTY SIX NINETY EIGHT
CORPOREAL. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SIX NINETY EIGHT BY FAMILY
MEMBERS RUBIO AND ACTUALLY THE
CHILD CARE. MISS RUBIO YOU MAY
OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO PRESENT MY
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX NINETY
EIGHT WHICH IS ALSO A WOMAN'S
CAUCUS PIRATED BILL THAT WILL
HELP OUR CHILDREN AND TEACHERS
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE.
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM TO BENEFIT
FROM EARLY CHILDHOOD MENTAL
HEALTH CONSULTATION.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT GETTING
RESOURCES TO CHILDREN AS WELL AS
PROVIDERS TO HELP ADDRESS
CHALLENGING BEHAVIORS AS WELL AS
PREVENTING FUTURE ACADEMIC
EXPULSION.
WE'RE SIMPLY AUTHORIZING
PROVIDERS TO UTILIZE EXISTING
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE FUNDING TO
PROVIDE VALUABLE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES WHICH RESEARCH SHOWS
WILL IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR
CHILDREN.
AS THE MOTHER OF TWO AND A
FORMER TEACHER I CAN TELL YOU.
ENOUGH HOW I CAN'T TELL YOU
ENOUGH HOW CRITICAL IT IS TO
ADDRESS CHALLENGING BEHAVIOR AT
AN EARLY AGE WE MUST PROVIDE
THESE BASIC SERVICES THAT WILL
BENEFIT NOT ONLY OUR CHILDREN.
BUT PUT PROVIDERS THAT WATCH
OVER OUR CHILDREN ON A DAILY
BASES.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS RUBIO SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
COR CLUB THERE ALL. HOME MEMBERS
VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE THE CLERK
WILL.
CLOSER ROLE MENTALITY THAT.
I SEVENTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM TO TWENTY SEVEN IS AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY NINE
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL 27-29 BY FAMILY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE STATE GOVERNMENT.
MISTER MURATSUCHI THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY NINE A BILL THAT WILL
REQUIRE THE STATE AUDITOR'S TO
APPROVE. TO OBTAIN APPROVAL FROM
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE PRIOR TO CONDUCTING AN
AND THIS SO ASSESSMENT AN AUDIT
OF A HIGH RISK LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCY.
AS THE CHAIR OF J. LACK I FULLY
SUPPORT THE HIGHER RISK LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ON A PROGRAM AND I
FULLY SUPPORT THE STATE
AUDITOR'S WORK ON THIS PROGRAM.
A PROBLEM THAT WAS PRESENTED
HOWEVER IS THAT THE LESS THAN OF
COUNCIL ISSUED A WRITTEN LEGAL
OPINION THAT STATED THAT UNDER
EXISTING LAW THE STATE AUDITOR
DOES NOT HAVE THE LEGAL
AUTHORITY TO CONDUCT AN INITIAL
ASSESSMENT. BEYOND A VERY
LIMITED SCOPE. THIS BILL SEEKS
TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM BY
REQUIRING J. ELECTED PROVE THAT
MISSILE ASSESSMENT AND AUDIT
PRIOR TO MOVING FORWARD.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
THEY MISS MURATSUCHI SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSER ROLAND TIED ABOUT AYE
AYES FORTY FOUR.
KNOWS TWENTY TWO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS HER
FATHER TO TWENTY EIGHT. AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO.
BY MISS FRIEDMAN CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND ACTUALLY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
MISS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY ARE PRESENT AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY TWO WHICH ENSURES
THAT ALL BENEFITS AND NEGATIVE
IMPACTS OF DENYING A DEVELOPMENT
PROJECT. ARE INCORPORATED INTO
HOW OUR PROJECT IS DESCRIBED IN
EVALUATED UNDER SEQUENCE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO WORKS
TO HIGHLIGHT THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF A PROJECT DELAY
OR OBSTRUCTION. EMISSION
COMMONLY FACE IN LOTS OF OUR
DISTRICTS.
AS THE NEED FOR DENSITY
INCREASES INFILL AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS ARE OFTEN
TARGETED BY LOCALS WHO USES
THEIR ONLY SOURCE OF INFORMATION
SECRET DOCUMENTS WHICH ONLY
STATE THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF
DOING A PROJECT.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW FOR SECRET
DOCUMENTS TO ALSO LOOK AT THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF NOT BUILDING
A PROJECT SOMETHING THAT'S OFTEN
NOT PRESENTED IN A TANGIBLE FORM
TO LOCALS.
THIS COULD LEAD TO INTENTIONAL
PROJECT DELAYS DESPITE OVERALL
BENEFITS ARE PROJECTS BECAUSE
DECISION MAKERS ARE ONLY GIVEN A
SMALL SNAPSHOT OF NEGATIVE
IMPACTS ABOUT LOOKING AT THE
HOLISTIC IMPACT OF A PROJECT.
AB TWENTY SEVEN ADDED TO TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY TWO ADDS A METRIC A
BENEFIT FROM THE STATEMENT OF
OVERRIDING CONSIDERATIONS AND
THE AYE ARE. TO WHAT A LEAD
AGENCY NEEDS TO CONSIDER IN THE
FILE DETERMINATION OF THE
PROJECT.
THIS ALLOWS THE HOLISTIC
HOLISTIC IMPACT OF A PROJECT TO
BE CONSIDERED IN THE FINAL
APPROVAL OR DENIAL OF THE
PROJECT.
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TO
RECEIVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGH THAN ASSEMBLY NATURAL
RESOURCES AND APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AND NOT ONE NO VOTE.
SIMPLE ADDITION TO OUR PROJECT
IS EVALUATED UNDER SEQUEL IS
WHAT THIS BILL DOES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS FRIEDMAN.
SEEING NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION WE MAY TAKE ARMY.
ROLL CALL VOTE. CORPORAL. I'M.
IS THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
THERE THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE RURAL A TIE VOTE EYES
SIXTY SEVEN.
NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM TO
TWENTY NINE.
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS.
CORD OR READ WITH AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE THIRTY
ONE WITH AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA.
MR GLORY ON THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'M OF ALLOW
ME TO PRESENT THE AMENDMENTS TO
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE. THESE
AMENDMENTS ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS
VAGUENESS CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION BY CLARIFYING THE
TYPES OF EQUIPMENT SUBJECT TO
THIS BILL. HE'S MEMBER THESE
AMENDMENTS ALSO EXCLUDE AIRCRAFT
USE IN SEARCH AND RESCUE OR
NATURAL RIGHT NOW TO DISASTERS
WHEN USE COLLABORATIVE BETWEEN
AGENCIES IN AN ATTEMPT TO
ADDRESS. MEMBERS CONCERNS ABOUT
INSTANCES WERE MOSTLY AGENCIES
MAYBE COLLUDING TO PROVIDE
MUTUAL AID I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA MISS
WALDRON WE OPPOSE THE
AMENDMENTS.
MS WALDRON WITH HOLES MEMBERS WE
WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS.
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
IT'S MAJORITY PRESENT IN VOTING
ON THE AMENDMENTS MAJORITY
PRESIDENT VOTING IS THE
THRESHOLD.
ON THE AMENDMENTS.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ZERO.
TELL ME ABOUT AYES FORTY WINDOWS
TWENTY THREE THE MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED BILLS OUT OF PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE.
PASS RETAIN A FALLEN TO THIRTY
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO THIRTY ONE THAT IS
AB%
TWENTY SEVEN. SEVENTY SEVEN BY
MISTER DAILY.
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN BY FAMILY MEMBER
DALY AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT.
MR DALY SPEAKER IN MEMBERS THIS
BILL SIMPLY EXTENDS THE SUNSET
DAY. ON AN EXISTING PROGRAM THE
GIVE STATE EMPLOYEES THE
FLEXIBILITY TO USE ALL TYPES OF
TRANSPORTATION. AND LODGING
OPTIONS INCLUDING UBER LEFT
AIRBNB AND SO FORTH WHILE
TRAVELING FOR WORK.
THESE INTERNET BASED PLATFORMS
ARE SOMETIMES THE MOST RELIABLE
CONVENIENT AND COST EFFECTIVE
OPTIONS
FOR OUR STATE EMPLOYEES.
ESPECIALLY IN COMMUNITIES THAT
LACK TRADITIONAL TRANSPORTATION
OR LODGING CHOICES.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THINGS DALY SEEN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CARP LIBERAL. MEMBERS.
MS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR OWN TIME ABOUT I
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TO
THIRTY TWO WAS AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY TO THE CLERK READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO EMPLOYMENT. MISS
GONZALEZ FLETCHER. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER A TWENTY FOURTEEN
URBAN INSTITUTE STUDY FOUND THAT
MANY VICTIMS OF LABOR
TRAFFICKING WERE SUBJECTED
SUBJECT TO A VARIETY OF PHYSICAL
AND PSYCHOLOGICAL TACTICS MEANT
TO CONTROL ENSLAVE THE VICTIMS.
INCLUDING THE USE OF DOCUMENT
SERVITUDE DOCUMENT SERVITUDE IS
A PRACTICE WHEN A PLAYER WITH
HOLDING AND IMMIGRANTS LEGAL
DOCUMENTS FOR PURPOSES OF
MANIPULATING THE EMPLOYEE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY TWO HELPS
PROTECT WORKERS AGAINST THIS
PRACTICE.
MAKING A VIOLATION PROVISION A
MISDEMEANOR AND UP TO A TEN
THOUSAND DOLLAR PENALTY IN
ESTABLISHING A WORKERS BILL OF
RIGHTS IN WHICH EMPLOYEES MUST
RECEIVE A COPY OF THAT DOCUMENT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER
SEEING.
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CORP LOCAL
ROLL-ON.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS HARIBO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FIFTY THREE.
KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
OR TO PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM TO
THIRTY THREE.
WE ARE AT FILE OUT TO THIRTY
FOUR HR. ONE ELEVEN BY MISS
WALDRON THE CLERK WILL READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE ELEVEN BY
FAMILY MEMBER WALDRON RELATIVE
TO NATIONAL POPPY DAY IN
CALIFORNIA. MISS WALDRON THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE AS A MEMBER OF THE AMERICAN
LEGION AUXILIARY. TO RECOGNIZE
NATIONAL POPPY DAY. THE RED
POPPY CAME TO SYMBOLIZE
SYMBOLIZE THE BLOOD SHED DURING
WORLD WAR ONE.
THE AMERICAN LEGION ADOPTED THE
POPPY AND ITS OFFICIAL FLOWERED
HONOR FOR ALL FALLEN SOLDIERS IN
THE FALL OF NINETEEN TWENTY. AND
IN NINETEEN TWENTY FOR THE
LEGION STARTED TO DISTRIBUTE THE
POPPIES NATIONALLY.
EACH YEAR THE DEDICATED MEN AND
WOMEN OF THE AMERICAN LEGION
SEND OUT POPPIES TO BE WORN THE
FRIDAY BEFORE MEMORIAL DAY. TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
GIVEN THE ULTIMATE SACRIFICE.
ALONG WITH THE POP THREE THE
LEGION DISTRIBUTES THE TOUCHING
POEM FLANDERS FIELDS.
OF MISTER SPEAKER PERMISSION TO
READ.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THE PALM STATES.
IN FLANDERS FIELDS THE POPPIES
BLOW BETWEEN THE CROSSES ROW ON
ROW.
THAT MARK OUR PLACE AND IN THE
SKY THE LARKS STILL BRAVELY
SINGING FLY.
SCARCE HEARD AMID THE GUNS
BELOW.
WE ARE THE DEAD SHORT DAYS AGO
WE LIVED FELT DAWN SAW SUNSET
GLOW. LOVED AND WERE LOVED AND
NOW WE LIE IN FLANDERS FIELDS.
TAKE UP OUR QUARREL WITH THE FOE
TO YOU FROM FAILING HANDS WE
THROW.
THE TORCH BE YOURS TO HOLD IT
HIGH.
IF YOU BREAK FAITH WITH US WHO
DIE WE SHALL NOT SLEEP THOUGH
POPPIES GROW IN FLANDERS FIELDS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ASK
OF THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR
CALL AUTHORS AYE URGENT AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU AS WELL THERE MITCHELL
LACKEY.
YEAH JUST REAL QUICKLY I AM
PROUD TO A RISE IN SUPPORT.
OF THIS RESOLUTION TO
COMMEMORATE THE NATIONAL. A
POPPY DAY.
AS THEY HAVE BEEN A.
A SYMBOL FOR THE RECOGNITION OF
THOSE WHO HAVE SACRIFICED THEIR
LIFE TO KEEP OUR COUNTRY SAFE.
AS REPRESENTED OF THE ANNUAL
VALLEY WHICH IS HOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA POPPY RESERVE. WOULD
ONLY GET A BEAUTIFUL DISPLAY OF
THE STATE FLOWER EACH YEAR BUT
WE ALSO SEE FOLKS TRAVELING FROM
ALL ENDS OF THE STATE TO SEE OUR
GOLDEN FIELDS.
I BITE MY COLLEAGUES TO VISIT
THE ANTELOPE VALLEY.
WHEN THE GOLDEN POPPIES ARM
BLOOM AND NEVER FORGET WHAT OUR
STATE FLOWER REPRESENTS A NINE
COURAGE OF.
SUPPORT FOR THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU MUCH LACKEY.
MR ACOSTA.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OUT AS
YESTERDAY WE JUST CELEBRATED
MEMORIAL DAY.
AS WE.
HONOR OUR FALLEN.
I WE HAD THE HONOR AND COURSE.
.
THE.
THE CHALLENGE IF YOU WELL TO GO
VISIT OUR SON'S GRAVE AND.
SOME BY SOMEBODY FROM THE
COMMUNITY SEVERAL FEET FROM THE
COMMITTEE HAD PUT UP BEAUTIFUL.
BEAUTIFUL POPPIES AT OUR SON'S
GRAVE AND ALSO UP LEFT THE POEM.
A IN FLANDERS FIELD AND THERE
WERE OF PENNIES.
THERE WERE A NICKEL CINEDIGM
SIGNIFYING PEOPLE THAT HAD
SERVED WITH OUR SON.
AND WE ONLY KNOW OF ONE LOCAL
PERSON THAT THAT HAD AND YOU GOT
HE HADN'T BEEN THERE AT THE TIME
SO. IT'S TRULY SOMETHING TO SEE
PEOPLE A LEAVE REMEMBRANCES. AND
I REALLY.
ENCOURAGE YOU ALL TO SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE BUT IT'S REALLY.
ON SPIRALING AS FAMILIES.
OF THE FALLEN TO AGO THERE ARE
GRAVE SITE OR WHEREVER WE MEMBER
I REMEMBER THEM AND SEE THE
BEAUTIFUL POPPIES LE THAT HAVE
BEEN LEFT ON ON. THAT ARE THEIR
BEHALF IN THEIR MEMORY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CASA.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
CARPOOL OPEN THE ROLE.
THERE IS A HOUSE RESOLUTION
WHICH I CO AUTHORS MISS WALDRON.
MS WALTERS ASKED. CO AUTHORS
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
HOUSE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL THEIR SIXTY EIGHT
COAUTHORS THAT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE AT MY HOUSE RESOLUTION.
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL.
ON FILE ITEM ONE NINETY FOUR.
THAT IS A. B..
THIRTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT FIVE
MISTER MURATSUCHI.
CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW THE VOTE.
EYES FIFTY KNOWS NINETEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSED.
MEMBERS BACK IN FILE ORDER.
WHERE'D FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
THIRTY FIVE THAT IS AB SEVENTEEN
THIRY FIVE BY MR CUNNINGHAM
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN THIRTY
FIVE BY SOME THE MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM AND EXPLAINED A
PROTECTIVE ORDERS. MISTER
CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY FIVE WOULD
ALLOW THE COURT TO ISSUE A TEN
YEAR PROTECT BORDER PROTECTING
VICTIMS OF LABOR TRAFFICKING.
UNDER CURRENT LAW VICTIMS OF
OTHER FORMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE COULD
OBTAIN THE SAME TENURE ORDER.
THE SIMPLY EXTENDS THAT ALSO TO
VICTIMS OF LABOR TRAFFICKING SO
THEY CAN REBUILD THEIR LIVES
AWAY FROM THEIR ATTACKERS.
OR THEIR TRAFFICKERS IT PASSED
BOTH COMMITTEES UNANIMOUSLY AND
I WOULD APPRECIATE.
AND I VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS CUNNINGHAM SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLOCK GLOBAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
ROSARIO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
HARTWELL.
CLOSE YOUR OWN TITLE VOTE.
I SEVENTY NEWS TO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TO
THIRTY SIX IS AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
SEVEN INCORPORATE.
SOME LEGAL SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN
BY SELLING MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO SCHOOL
SAFETY. MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
SPEAKER MEMBERS ARRIVED PRESENT
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN.
LAST YEAR I ASKED THE STATE
AUDITOR ON SCHOOL SAFETY.
WHICH ALARMINGLY REVEAL THAT
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS ARE FALLING
SHORT OF KEEPING OUR STUDENTS
SAFE.
THE AUDIT FOUND THAT MANY
SCHOOLS IN THEIR DISTRICT
OFFICES ARE LACKING CRITICAL
SAFETY PROCEDURES.
SUCH AS LOCK DOWNS WHICH ARE
LIFESAVING DRILLS AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER SITUATIONS.
THIS BILL REQUIRES SCHOOLS TO
DEVELOP SAFETY PLAN TO RESPOND
TO ACTIVE SHOOTER AND OTHER
VIOLENT INCIDENTS.
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT WILL BE INVOLVED
IN THE PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF SAFETY
PROCEDURES.
AND THE PART OF EDUCATION WILL
PROVIDE SCHOOLS WITH UP TO DATE
INFORMATION ON BEST PRACTICES.
AND A TIME WHERE SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS ARE BECOMING MORE
PREVALENT THAN EVER WE MUST BE
PREPARED I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE.
THINGS RODRIGUEZ MISTER
GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE I THINK THE AUTHOR OF
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD. EYES
YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN A VERY STRONG
COME THE. PROPONENT OF DOING
MORE TO SECURE OUR SCHOOLS.
AND IN THE RANCHO TAME
ELEMENTARY.
INCIDENT.
THE LOCKDOWN THAT OCCURRED
THERE WAS CREDITED WITH SAVING
LIVES OF THE STUDENTS THERE. AS
WE KNOW WE NEED TO DO MORE ON
THIS LEVEL.
I ALSO BELIEVE WE NEED TO HAVE.
MORE SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICERS
OTHERS MANY SCHOOLS THAT DON'T
HAVE ANY.
SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICERS
AND WE ALSO NEED TO HAVE THE
TRAINING IT'S A MULTI TRUE.
PRONGED APPROACH OTHER WORKING
ON AND BE GLAD TO BE OUT AS A CO
AUTHOR OF WHEN YOU GET TO THAT
POINT.
MY COLLEAGUE.
AS WELL AND SO ANYWAYS ASK YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU.
THINGS GALLAGHER AND WITHOUT.
THANK YOU MEMBERS WITH THAT
QUICK LIBERAL. ON.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CULTURAL TIES BUT I
SIXTY NINE.
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS FILE ITEM TO THIRTY
SEVEN IS AB SEVENTEEN. FIFTY
ONE.
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE BY SOME A
MEMBER LOW AND ACTUALLY TO
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES MR LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RECIPE GRIN
MEMBERS A. B. SEVENTEEN FIFTY
ONE IS THE INTERSTATE
PRESCRIPTION DATA SHARING TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA CAN SHARE
WITH THE DATA OF OTHER STATES TO
PREVENT AS MUCH DOCTOR SHOPPING
AS POSSIBLE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE QUIRK WELCOME
ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUT OF VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF TOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE VOTE
AYE SIXTY EIGHT.
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES NEXT
ITEM FILE ITEM TO THIRTY EIGHT
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY TO COOPERATE.
SOME PEOPLE SEVENTEEN FIFTY TWO
BY SOME A MEMBER LOW AND
ACTUALLY TO CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES.
MR LOW. BEEN VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS IS A SECOND
BILL IN THE PACKAGE OF BILLS
ABILITY TO THE OF YOUR CRISIS.
OF THIS AD SCHEDULE FIVE DRUGS.
TO THE CURE'S DATABASE WHICH IS
WITH RESPECT TO PRESCRIPTION
ONLY COUGH SYRUP CONTAINING
CODEINE WHICH IS NOPE YOU WAIT.
A SECOND WE THIS BILL ALSO
CHANGE THE TIME OF FARMS IS HAS
TO UPLOAD TO A HERE'S A DATABASE
FROM SEVEN DAYS TO ONE WORKING
DAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE.
AMOS LOW SEE NO DISCSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. QUICKLAW
PARA. HOMEOWNERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
CLERK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF
AND I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TO
THIRTY NINE.
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FIFTY
THREE BY SOME AMARILLO AND
ACTUALLY CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES
SHALLOW YOU MAKE AN OPEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF A SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS IS THE THIRD OF
THE.
BILLS IN THIS OPIOID PACKAGE AND
THIS IS WITH RESPECT TO
PRESCRIPTION PAD CONTROLS AND
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE SERIALIZE
PRESCRIPTION PAD SO THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENTCONTRACT WHEN HE'S
GOING TO THE WRONG HANDS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THINKING WHICH LOW SENIOR
SESSION ABATE.
CLICK LIBERAL. HOMEOWNERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TIED ABOUT AYE
SEVENTY KNOWS ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WANT
TO PASS RETAIN OF FILE ITEM TO
FORTY.
FILE ITEM TO FORTY ONE IS AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SEVEN BY MISS
CERVANTES CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN BY SOME A MEMBER CERVANTES
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY JUST DUE
TO FINANCIAL AID. MISTER ABOUT
TESS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THE INSTITUTE FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS
BALLOT THE AVERAGE PERCENTAGE OF
STUDENT DOT. FOR CALIFORNIA
GRADUATE AT A PUBLIC OR PRIVATE
NONPROFIT COLLEGE IS ABOUT FIFTY
FOUR PERCENT. WHICH IS A TOTAL
DEBT AVERAGE OF TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND PER GRADUATE. STUDENT
LOAN COMPANIES OFTEN PROVIDE
RECENT GRADUATES WITH THE SIX
MONTH GRACE PERIOD BEFORE THEIR
LOAN PAYMENTS ARE REQUIRED TO
BEGIN. THIS GRACE PERIOD IS
GENERALLY AN INSUFFICIENT AMOUNT
OF TIME FOR MANY RECENT
GRADUATES WERE OFTEN FACED WITH
DIFFICULTIES ADJUSTING AND
ENTERING THE WORKFORCE. AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SEVEN WILL
EXTEND THE SIX MONTH GRACE
PERIOD FOR TOWARD TO A FEDERAL
STUDENT.
I FEDERAL INCOME DRIVEN
PREPAYMENT PLAN TO TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS.
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE RECENT
COLLEGE GRADUATES.
MORE SUFFICIENT TIME TO EXPLORE
THEIR OPTIONS BEFORE HAVING TO
TAKE ON THE DAUNTING TASK EVERY
PAINFUL OR A STUDENT LOANS
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER BODICE SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLUB LIBERAL
I'M.
IT IS OUT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE WHAT I FIFTY TWO
KNOWS TWENTY TWO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ASCERTAIN A FILE ITEM TO FORTY
TWO.
FOR FILE ITEM TO FORTY THREE.
AB.
ARMY.
FILE ITEM TO FORTY THREE IS AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY EIGHT FIVE
MISTER KANSEN CHU. COOPERATE
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN NINETY
EIGHT BY SOME A MEMBER KANSEN
CHU AND ACTUALLY THE SCHOOL
BUSES. RESEARCH YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY EIGHT SET A
DATE. FOR WHICH ALL SCHOOL BUSES
IN CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTING
STUDENTS MUST HAVE SEATBELT.
CURRENTLY NEARLY HALF OF THOSE
SCHOOL BUSES SING CALIFORNIA DO
NOT HAVE SEAT BELTS.
THIS BILL REQUIRED CALIFORNIA
CLOSE THIS GAP BY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE.
WE KNOW OUR SEATBELTS SAFE LIFE
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
EUROPE AYE VOTE.
THINGS CHIU SAY NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON VOTE.
WIZARD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUR TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLAND. I SEVENTY KNOW
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM TO FORTY FOURS AB EIGHTEEN
OH FOR CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN NO FOR BY
FAMILY MEMBER BERMAN AND OTHERS
IN ATLANTA BY MENTAL QUALITY.
MISTER BERMAN YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES.
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT
THERE'S A CATEGORICAL INFILL
EXEMPTION WHICH IS INTENDED TO
PROMOTE INFILL DEVELOPMENT IN
URBANIZED AREAS.
HOWEVER THE EXISTING CATEGORICAL
INFILL EXEMPTION IS LIMITED TO
ONLY CITIES DESPITE THE FACT
THAT THERE ARE URBANIZED AREAS
IN OUR COUNTIES.
AB EIGHT YOU KNOW FORWARD EXPAND
THE EXISTING CATEGORICAL INFILL
EXEMPTION TO PROMOTE INFILL
DEVELOPMENT IN UNINCORPORATED
AREAS OF A COUNTY UNDER THE SAME
NARROW CONDITIONS. FOR PROJECTS
IN CITIES AND WOULD APPLY ONLY
TO RESIDENTIAL OR MIXED USE
HOUSING PROJECTS
IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT ALL CATEGORICAL EXEMPTIONS
INCLUDING THIS INFILL EXEMPTION
ARE SUBJECT TO EXCEPTIONS. UNDER
THE SEQUEL GUIDELINES THAT WOULD
DISQUALIFY A PROJECT FROM
RECEIVING AN EXEMPTION.
AB EIGHT YOU KNOW FOR PROMOTE
RESIDENTIAL OR MIXED USE HOUSING
PROJECTS AN URBANIZED AREAS IN
OUR COUNTIES IN THE US HELP
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S. HOUSING
CRISIS WITHOUT ADVERSELY
IMPACTING THE ENVIRONMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THINK OF US BERMAN SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK LIBERAL I'M.
THESE ARE ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIME BUT I
SIXTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM TO FORTY
FIVE.
AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY SEVEN OPERATE
AT SOME LEGAL EIGHTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NAZARIAN AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE BUILDING STANDARDS.
MISTRESS AREA AND YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY SEVEN REQUIRES
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
STANDARDS COMMISSION TO ASSEMBLE
A WORKING GROUP CONSISTING OF.
VARIOUS BUILDING HOUSING.
AND ENGINEERING EXPERTS TO
DETERMINE NEW POST EARTHQUAKE
BUILDING STANDARDS WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF ESSENTIAL
FACILITIES LIKE HOSPITALS AND
SCHOOLS CURRENT BUILDING CODE IS
ONLY DESIGNED. TO PROTECT
AGAINST LOSS OF LIFE IF A MAJOR
EARTHQUAKE HITS.
THE CODE SAYS NOTHING ABOUT
WHETHER OR WHEN A BUILDING WILL
BE USABLE AFTER A LARGE SEISMIC
EVENT.
AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY SEVEN WILL
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE CAN ENTER
BUILDINGS AND RESUME NORMAL
ACTIVITIES SOON AFTER A LARGE
EARTHQUAKE INSTEAD OF HAVING
BUILDINGS CLOSED FOR MONTHS OR
YEARS AT A TIME WHICH WAS.
EVIDENCED IN NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR WITH THE NORTHRIDGE
EARTHQUAKE I'M COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS. AS AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN MOVES THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTRESS AREA.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK LOVE THE ROLL-ON.
IS ARE LOW MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IS THERE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS HURT HIS ARTICLE
MISTER NAZARIAN MOVES A CALL
WELL I'M TO.
FILE ITEM.
TWO FORTY SEVEN.
IS AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY THREE
OPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN SIXTY
THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
MISTER JONES SAWYER. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO RESENT
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY THREE WHICH
WOULD ALLOW CANNABIS BUSINESSES
FILING AS A SOLE PROPRIETOR A
PARTNERSHIP OR LIMITED LIABILITY
COMPANY DID TO DEDUCT ORDINARY
AND NECESSARY. BUSINESS EXPENSES
FROM THE PERSONAL INCOME TAX
STATE INCOME TAXES
ABILITY DEDUCT EXPENSES INCURRED
WHILE CONDUCTING BUSINESS IS
ENJOYED BY ALL LEGITIMATE
BUSINESSES WHEN FILING TAXES.
HOWEVER IRS CODE SECTION TWO
EIGHTY E. PROHIBITS NOT
CORPORATE ENTITIES THAT DERIVE
THEIR PROFITS FROM THE
TRAFFICKING OF A CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE FROM DEDUCTING THESE
EXPENSES AS A RESULT CANNABIS
BUSINESSES THAT ARE NOT
INCORPORATED. ARE TAXED AT
HIGHER RATES THAN ANY OTHER
LEGAL BUSINESS INTHE STATE. AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY THREE WERE
ALIGNED TO CORPORATE AND
PERSONAL TAX CODE TO ALLOW LEGAL
CANDIDATES BUSINESSES TO DEDUCT
LEGITIMATE OPERATIONAL EXPENSES.
THIS BILL ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT HAS NO KNOWN OPPOSITION
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
NAME IS JONES SAWYER.
QUIRK LIBERAL.
NUMBER SO.
IT IS OUT OF VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TIE THAT I FIFTY
THREE.
NO IS NINE THE MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM TO FORTY EIGHT. IS A.
B. EIGHTEEN SEVENTY CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
BY SELLING OVER REYES AND OTHERS
AN ACTUAL INTO EMPLOYMENT.
MS REYES YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TO THEIR PRESENT A. B.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY A WOMEN'S
CAUCUS PRIORITY BILL. WHICH
EXTENDS THE TIME FOR FILING
HARASSMENT AND DISCRIMINATION
CLAIMS AGAINST THE CALIFORNIA.
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING ACT FROM ONE
YEAR TO THREE YEARS.
THIS WILL ALLOW VICTIMS
ADDITIONAL TIME TO SEEK REDRESS
AND MAKE IT MORE CONSISTENT WITH
THE FILING TIME LIMITS FOR OTHER
ACTIONS.
THE LEGISLATURE LIKE MANY
INDUSTRIES HAS BEEN GRAPPLING
WITH CHANGES IN THE WAKE OF THE
MEAT TO MOVEMENT.
HOWEVER THESE ISSUES ARE NOT
LIMITED TO THE HALLS OF
GOVERNMENT.
THROUGH THE STORIES WE ARE
HAVING A LARGER SOCIETY WHY
DIALOGUE ABOUT SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AND THE EVIDENCE IS THERE. ONE
YEAR IS SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH TO
BRING HARASSMENT AND
DISCRIMINATION CLAIMS FORWARD.
WORKPLACE HARASSMENT CREATES AN
INTIMIDATING HOSTILE DEGRADING
HUMILIATING OFFENSIVE
ENVIRONMENT.
WE ALL DESERVE TO WORK IN A SAFE
WE ALL DESERVE TO KNOW THAT WE
ARE PROTECTED AND WE CERTAINLY
DESERVE TO HAVE THE TIME NEEDED
TO PRESENT OUR COMPLAINTS.
AGAINST THE PERPETRATORS.
WE MUST TAKE PROACTIVE STEPS TO
ENSURE THAT VICTIMS ARE
PROTECTED AND THAT THEY KNOW
THEY ARE NOT ALONE. THEY MUST
NEVER FEEL INTIMIDATED TO SHARE
THEIR STORY.
SPELL IS NOT A MAGIC SOLUTION.
IT IS THE FIRST STEP IN AN
EFFORT TO PROVIDE SOME BASIC
PROTECTIONS
AND LEGAL RECOURSE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THEY'VE IS RACINO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
OR CLUB THE ROLL-ON.
THESE ARE ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLES HOWEVER RIGHTS
FORTY FOUR.
KNOWS FOR THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM TO FORTY
NINE.
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY THREE BY MR
OBERNOLTE CLERK WILL READ.
AT SOME LEGAL EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER OBERNOLTE
AND OTHERS ACTUALLY THE DRIVER'S
LICENSES.
MR OBERNOLTE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
THREE WOULD ELIMINATE THE FEE
CHARGED TO VETERANS WHO APPLY
FOR A VETERANS DESIGNATION ON
THEIR DRIVER'S LICENSE OR THEIR
CALIFORNIA STATE ID CARD. THIS
IS JUST A SMALL WAY OF
ACKNOWLEDGING THE DEBT WE OWE
THESE MEN AND WOMEN FOR THEIR
SERVICE TO OUR STATE AND TO OUR
COUNTRY. IT'S SUPPORTED BY A
WIDE VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
VETERANS GROUPS AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THING WHICH OBERNOLTE MISTER
FRAZIER. MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY THREE.
I NEVER INTENDED FOR THERE TO BE
A FEE WHEN I OFFER THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION CREATIVE EFFORTS
DESIGNATION. ON THE CALIFORNIA
DRIVER'S LICENSE.
I WAS FORCED TO INCLUDE ONE IN
ORDER TO GET IT PASSED.
VETERANS DESIGNATION PROGRAM HAS
GOTTEN THOUSANDS OF VETERANS IN
FRONT OF THEIR LOCAL CVS SO
OFFICES WHICH TO RETURN HAVE
HELPED OUR VETERAN SECURE.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS WORTH OF
BENEFITS THE ROAD BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
LIMITING THE FEE WILL INCREASE
PARTICIPATION THE PROGRAM AND
HOPEFULLY GET EVEN MORE VETERANS
THE VETERANS.
VETERANS THE BENEFIT THEY ARE
OWED AND DESERVE. I WANT TO
THANK OTHER FOR WORKING WITH ME
ON THIS BILL TO ENSURE ALL
VETERANS ARE EXEMPTED FROM
PAYING THE FEE THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER.
YOU KNOW DIGITAL DISCUSSION
DEBATE. THE CLERK WILL OPEN
ROLL-ON.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE THAT I SIXTY
SEVEN.
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TO FIFTY IS AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FIVE OPERATE.
AT SOME LEGAL EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE BY SEVEN NUMBER BUT IN
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
INSURANCE.
DOCTOR WOULD. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS LATE ON THE
NIGHT OF OCTOBER EIGHTH LAST
YEAR WILDFIRES RAGED THROUGH NOT
NAPA CINNAMON MENDOCINO
COUNTIES.
THE FIRES DESTROYED OVER EIGHT
THOUSAND HOMES INCLUDING OVER
THREE THOUSAND IN THE CITY OF
SANTA ROSA LOAN.
THOUSANDS OF MY CONSTITUENTS
LOST THEIR HOMES AND EVERYTHING
THEY OWN IN ONE NIGHT AND MY
COMMUNITY WAS FOREVER CHANGED.
IN THE AFTERMATH OF THIS TRAGEDY
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES ARE
FINDING THEMSELVES UNINSURED
UNDER INSURED AND STRUGGLING TO
REBUILD THEIR HOMES.
THE MOST RECENT STUDY ESTIMATES
THAT MORE THAN SIXTY PERCENT OF
THE PEOPLE WHO LOST THEIR HOMES
WILL WIND UP UNDER INSURED.
THIS UNDER INSURANCE EPIDEMIC IN
DO IS DUE IN PART TO THE
SIGNIFICANT SURGE IN DEMAND FOR
BUILDING MATERIALS AND SKILLED
LABOR.
PROPERTY OWNERS AND CONTRACTORS
ALIKE REPORT THE COST PER SQUARE
FOOT TO BUILD A HOME IN SANTA
ROSA HAS MORE THAN DOUBLED SINCE
THE FIRES IN OCTOBER. THEIR
EXISTING INSURANCE PRODUCTS THAT
ARE DESIGNED TO HELP PROTECT
PROPERTY OWNERS WHEN REBUILDING
COSTS SEARCH.
THIS BILL LAST THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE TO DEVELOP A HOME
INSURANCE FINDER TOOL THAT WILL
ALLOW PROPERTY OWNERS TO EASILY
IDENTIFY THE OPTIONS AVAILABLE
TO THEM.
AND REQUIRES INSURANCE INSURERS
WHO DO NOT OFFER REFUSE TO OFFER
A FIFTY PERCENT EXTENDED
REPLACEMENT COST POLICY TO
PROVIDE THE PROPERTY OWNER WITH
INFORMATION ABOUT THIS TOOL.
THOSE RECEIVE UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN POLICY
COMMITTEE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THEY DON'T WOULD SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
GROW. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IS THAT ABOUT ALL NUMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRABLE.
THE CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIES BUT I SIXTY SIX
KNOWS ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TWO FIFTY ONE IS AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO QUACKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
TWO BY FAMILY MEMBERS CERVANTES
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY CRIMES.
MR MATIS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA HAD
OVER THIRTEEN HUNDRED INCIDENCES
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
AND ACCORDING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
THERE IS AN ALARMING TREND IN
WHICH HUMAN TRAFFICKERS ARE
USING THE INTERNET AND POPULAR
SOCIAL MEDIA SITES SUCH AS
FACEBOOK AND INSTAGRAM. TO LOWER
POTENTIAL VICTIMS TO THEM
CURRENT LAW PROHIBITS
COMMUNICATION WITH THE MINOR
OVER THE INTERNET WITH THE
INTENT TO COMMIT KIDNAPPER RAPE
HOWEVER HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS NOT
ONE OF THE INCLUDED OFFENSES. AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO WILL CLOSE
THE SCHOOL POLL BY MAKING IT A
FELONY TO CONTACT A MINOR WITH
THE INTENT TO ENGAGE IN HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FREE AYE VOTE
ON AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO.
SHE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLICK LIBERAL. I'M.
THESE ARE ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE
SIXTY THREE KNOWS ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TO FIFTY TWO IS AB
EIGHTEEN NINETY FIVE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN NINETY
FIVE BY SOME A MEMBER CALDERON
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION.
MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB EIGHTEEN NINETY FIVE
REQUIRES PARTICIPATING
UNIVERSITIES OF CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES
TO CREATE PROCEDURES FOR INCOME
BASED REPAYMENT PLANS. FOR DREAM
LOANS
BY BECAUSE BY CREATING AN INCOME
BASED REPAYMENT PLAN FOR DREAM
LOANS.
OUR PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES
COMMUNICATE THAT THE STUDENTS
HAVE THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES AS
THEIR PEERS.
FLEXIBLY REPAY THEIR LOANS UPON
GRADUATION.
THIS BILL HASN'T RECEIVED ANY NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THINGS CALDERON SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK LIBERAL. ON MEMBERS FOR.
WHO IS OUT ABOUT ALL OVER SODOR
DESIRABLE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK ROLE CLOSE ROLL TIDE VOTE.
I FOUR NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
THERE'S ONE TO PASS A RETAIN.
ON FILE ITEMS TO FIFTY THREE.
TO FIFTY FOUR AND.
YOU FIFTY FIVE.
I BELIEVE WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
FILE IN TWO FIFTY SIX
AB NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT FIVE MR
MCCARTY THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN TWENTY
EIGHT BY SOME REMEMBER MCCARTY
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
RESOURCES CONSERVATION.
MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS
THAT STREAMLINING BILL RELATE TO
OUR CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS WE ALL KNOW ABOUT OUR
STATE COURT WE ALSO KNOW WE HAVE
GREAT LOCAL CORES. UNFORTUNATELY
I DO NEGLECT THAT CALIFORNIA
STATE CONSERVATION CORPS CANNOT
DIRECTLY CONTRACT WITH LOCAL
COURTS CAN TO COMPLETE. NEEDED
PROJECTS SUCH AS DISASTER RELIEF
IF I AM ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATION
SO FOR.
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE TO CLARIFY
THIS ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLICK LOCAL ROLL-ON.
THIS OUT OF ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE AROUND TIGHT OF A AYE
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM TWO FIFTY
SEVEN.
IS AB NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE BY SOME THE
MEMBER IRWIN AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
MS IRWIN YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB IN NINETEEN
THIRTY FIVE AUTHORIZES FUNDING
FOR TUTORING OF DEGREE AFFABLE.
TRANSFER LEVEL COURSES STUDIES
CONDUCTED BY SAMBAR MEDINA
VALLEY COLLEGE.
COLLEGE OF THE CANYONS FOUND
THAT STUDENTS WHO PARTICIPATED
IN TUTORING HEADS HIGHER SUCCESS
RATES AND THE CAMPUS WIDE
AVERAGE.
CURRENTLY COLLEGES CAN ONLY
RECEIVE FUNDING FOR TUTORING AND
BASIC SKILLS COURSES AND OTHER
VARIOUS CLASSES BUT NOT FOR
CLASSES THAT STUDENTS NEED TO
GRADUATE. OR TRANSFER TO A
UNIVERSITY AB NINETEEN THIRTY
FIVE ALLOWS COLLEGES TO RECEIVE
FUNDING FOR TUTORING IN THESE
CLASSES. THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
RECEIVES ZERO NOW VOTES AND
ASSEMBLY HIGHER ED AND
APPROPRIATIONS AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR DRIVERS.
THANK YOU MS IRWIN.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CORPORAL. I'M.
RESERVE A LITTLE MEMBERS WHAT IS
THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE TIES I
SIXTY SEVEN.
NOS ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO PASS AND
RETAIN. ON FILE ITEMS.
TWO FIFTY EIGHT.
THROUGH.
TWO FIFTY EIGHT AND TWO FIFTY
NINE OR DISPENSED FILE AND TWO
SIXTY.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP. FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO SIXTY ONE. THAT
IS AB NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN FORTY
EIGHT BY SOME A MEMBER JONES
SAWYER AND ACTUALLY ANY CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE.
MISTER JONES SAWYER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB NINETEEN FORTY
EIGHT WILL WOULD ADD FAT NO TO
LIST OF CONTROL SUBMITTED FOR
WHICH A WIRETAP MAYBE AUTHORIZED
WILL OUT LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
OBTAIN A WIRETAP. FOR THE
ILLEGAL USE OF FENTANYL THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE ON DRUG ABUSE
TO FIND FAT NO AS A POWERFUL
SYNTHETIC POPEIL. THAT IS
SIMILAR TO MORPHINE BUT IS FIFTY
TO A HUNDRED TIMES MORE POTENT.
A COMPARISON HARRISON HEROIN IS
ROUGHLY TWICE AS POTENT AS
MORPHINE.
IN MARCH TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
THE DRUG ENFORCEMENT
ADMINISTRATION ISSUED A
NATIONWIDE ALERT ON FOOTBALL AS
A THREAT TO HEALTH AND PUBLIC
SAFETY.
LAW ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITIES ARE
SEEING AN INCREASE IN FEDERAL
DRUG TRAFFICKING BECAUSE OF IT
IT'S LOW RISK AND HIGH PROFIT AB
NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT WILL HELP
KEEP DRUG TRAFFICKERS WHO ARE
ILLEGALLY TRANSPORTING.
MANUFACTURING AND SELLING THIS
FATAL DRUG OUT OF OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS AB NINETEEN FORTY
EIGHT HAS GONE TO THE ASSEMBLY
WOULD NO NO VOTES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR GUY VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS JONES SAWYER
MISTER HARPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I WANT TO
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR BRING THIS
FORWARD RECOGNIZING THE. THE
PROBLEM OF GOTTEN ALL IT IS A
SCOURGE THAT'S COMING THROUGH
OUR COMMUNITIES AND I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE HIS EFFORTS IN
COMBATING THIS.
THIS DRUG PROBLEM AYE URGING
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS HARPER AND
WITHOUT.
QUIRK LIBERAL. MEMBERS.
IS OUT OF OF MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THOUGH.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROSE HIGH THAT I SIXTY
KNOWS ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM TO SIXTY
TWO. AB NINETEEN FIFTY TWO
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN FIFTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAYES AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO FOOD
ACCESS.
MISTER MAYES YOU MAY OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
AB NINETEEN FIFTY TO BRING
TOGETHER A SKILLED WORKGROUP TO
DEVELOP A BROAD BASED PLAN TO
HELP US ACHIEVE THE GOAL OF A
HUNGER FREE CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE GEOGRAPHY
DEMOGRAPHICS AND FORTUNATE
PROMOTE THE PREVALENCE OF FOOD
DESERT'S THAT LIMIT FOOD ACCESS
FOR HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS.
AND THE HIGH HEALTH RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH POOR NUTRITION.
THIS BILL ALSO PROVIDES ELEVEN A
HALF MILLION FOR GRANTS TO
IMPLEMENT SOLUTIONS THAT IMPROVE
FOOD ACCESS AND IT PRIORITIZES
REGIONAL PLANNING CONNECTION
STRATEGY MODELS BETWEEN RURAL
AND URBAN. AREAS DEMONSTRATING
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT JOB
BENEFITS AND EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TO ENSURE THEVIBRANT
SUSTAINABLE FOOD SYSTEMS
AVAILABLE ACROSS ALL COMMITTEE
STATEWIDE.
THEY CAN THIS MAN. SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CORD GLOBAL ROLL-ON NUMBERS FOR.
ZARA VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THEY DESERVE A VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ROLE AND
TALLY THOUGH NUYS FIFTY SEVEN NO
ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WERE
TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
TO SIXTY THREE.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM TO
SIXTY FOUR AB NINETEEN FIFTY
SEVEN BY MISTER BERMAN THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN FIFTY
SEVEN BY FAMILY MEMBER BERMAN
AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES. MISTER BERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT AB
NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN WHICH WOULD
MODERNIZE STATE LAWS GOVERNING
COMMUNICATION FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
NET PROGRAMS.
COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES
ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF NEW
TECHNOLOGIES
TO COMMUNICATE WITH CLIENTS
HOWEVER STATE LAWS HAVE NOT KEPT
PACE.
AB NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN WOULD
AUTHORIZE AND SET PARAMETERS FOR
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATION WITHIN
PUBLIC SAFETY NET PROGRAMS WILL
BRING OUR LAWS INTO THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY AND ENSURE THAT WE
PROTECT THE PRIVACY. AND DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS OF CALIFORNIANS
WHO RELY ON THESE PROGRAMS TO
GUARD AGAINST HUNGER AND POVERTY
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THINGS BERMAN.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
LOCAL OF THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
THERE IS OUR TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS THERE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ON I SIXTY TWO
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WELL I AM TO SIXTY FIVE IS AB
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN FIFTY
NINE BY SOME REMEMBER WHAT IN
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY A
TELECOMMUNICATIONS OCCURRING
THERE AND SEE THEIR UP TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
DOCTOR WILLIAM AILMENT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE EXTENDS TO
SUNSET FOR THE CALIFORNIA HIGH
COST MONDAY. AND BE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROGRAM FOR
FOUR YEARS THESE PROGRAMS HELP
SUPPORT CARRIERS OF LAST RESORT
PRIVATE FIGHTING AFFORDABLE
RELIABLE TELEPHONE SERVICE IN IN
RURAL HIGH COST AREAS OF THE
STATE. THIS IS A UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN HAS HAD THE UNITED
MISS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS THE
RESPECT WE ASK YOUR AYE BILL.
THEY DUCKED WOULD.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CLERK WILL OPEN ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THESE ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESERTED THOUGH
TAKES FIFTY FOUR.
ON THE URGENCY.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL. TELL YOU THAT I
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY.
I SWEAR EIGHT NO ZERO ON THE
BILL.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM.
TWO SIXTY SIX.
FILE ITEM TWO SIXTY SIX.
IS AB NINETEEN.
SIXTY EIGHT BY MR LOW.
COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT BY FAMILY MEMBER LOW AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
FIREARMS.
ASSURE LOW YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB NINETEEN SIXTY
RESTRICTS FIREARM POSSESSIONS
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN
PLACED ON TO PSYCHIATRIC HOLES.
ARE WITHIN ONE YEAR THIS IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
AND THE CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION IS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE MISTER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
YES WAS SPEAKING MEMBERS ARE
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
HOW AM I THINK IT PUTS THE RIGHT
FOCUS ON THAT WE. WILL BEGIN TO
LOOK AT YOU KNOW WHERE THAT
WHERE THE PROBLEMS WHERE THE RED
FLAGS FOR US.
IN SOCIETY WHERE WE CAN YOU
KNOW.
IDENTIFY INDIVIDUALS AND ENSURE
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS.
TWO WEAPONS IN AND PEOPLE HAVE
TO.
OF THESE FIFTY ONE FIFTIES AND
AND A YEAR. AND THAT'S A PRETTY
BIG RED FLAG.
IS SO I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD. AGAIN
WE STILL HAVE THE ISSUE OF
ENSURING THAT.
.
ENSURING THAT THE WEAPONS ARE
THAT THERE SOMEONE IS GOING TO
GO AND ACTUALLY DISARM THEM THE
APPS PROGRAM AND THE DOJ IS
STILL NOT GETTING. THE BACKLOG
DONE WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
THAT'S DONE WE NEED TO HOLD THE
DOJ ACCOUNTABLE.
FOR THE JOB OF ENSURING THAT
PROHIBITED PERSONS DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO WEAPONS AND THAT'S
STILL A VERY BIG QUESTION MARK
OF THAT I THINK WE NEED TO TAKE
A.
THANK YOU.
THANKS GALLAGHER MISS MELENDEZ
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MEMBERS.
FIFTY ONE FIFTY IS.
THAT TAPE HOLDERS WHEN YOU ARE
DANGER TO YOURSELF A DANGER TO
OTHERS.
OR YOU ARE.
NOT ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF
YOURSELF.
.
IT IT'S IT'S NOT JUST AN
INSTANCE WERE SOMEBODY IS
THREATENING TO HARM SOMEONE ELSE
WERE THEMSELVES AND ACTUALLY
COVERS A WIDE VARIETY OF THINGS.
RIGHT NOW YOU CAN BE.
PROHIBITED FROM OWNING FIREARMS
FOR FIVE YEARS.
GIVEN THE CIRCUMSTANCES WHICH
IS APPROPRIATE.
ON THIS BILL SEEKS TO MAKE IT A
LIFETIME BAN ON EVEN IF IT'S A
SITUATION WHERE YOU ARE NOT.
THREATENING TO HARM SOMEONE
ELSE OR YOURSELF THE ACLU HAS
GREAT CONCERN ABOUT THIS BILL
BECAUSE OF SOME OF THOSE
REASONS.
I'D.
PERSONALLY I I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND WHERE THE AUTHOR IS
GOING WITH THIS AND I THINK THAT
IF WE HAVE SOMEONE WHO IS ON A
ON A REGULAR BASIS IF YOU WELL.
OUT OF BEING DETAINED AND.
AND HELD BY MEDICAL FACILITY
FACILITY AND.
BEING RECOMMENDED FOR THAT BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT WE CERTAINLY.
I'M WANT TO INTERVENE.
BUT IT IS NOT ALWAYS A CASE
WHERE ONE SHOULD LOSE THEIR
RIGHTS FOR FOR LIFE.
AS YOU ALL KNOW THERE ARE
CERTAINLY. PEOPLE IN YOUR
COMMUNITY PERHAPS PEOPLE IN YOUR
OWN FAMILY MAYBE EVEN YOURSELF
WHO HAVE GONE THROUGH A PERIOD
OF TIME IN THEIR LIVES WHERE.
THINGS BEGIN TO FALL APART AND
PERHAPS.
THEY'RE TAKEN IN ON THIS TYPE OF
HOLD DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO HARM
SOMEONE OR THEMSELVES OF THAT
THEY WILL DO SO. TEN YEARS OR
TWENTY YEARS FROM NOW I THINK
THEY THEY AYE I THINK THEY HAVE
WE SHOULD HAVE THE ABILITY. TO.
TO HAVE THAT CAREFULLY
CONSIDERED RATHER THAN TO JUST
TAKE THERE'S RIGHT AWAY.
.
FOR IT YOU KNOW IN IN
PERPETUITY.
WITH THAT I'M I WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL THANK YOU.
DOCTOR EGGMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS.
IT'S NOT OFTEN I GET UPON ON
GUN BILLS BUT I JUST IT BEFORE
TALK ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
AND I JUST FEEL THE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO SAY. WE CANNOT I MEAN WE
HAVE TO ANY GUNS ON OUR STREETS
WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO HAVE A LOT OF
ISSUES THAT USE GUNS AT ALL
KINDS OF DIFFERENT WAYS. TO TRY
TO STIGMATIZE PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES UP FOR EVER I
THINK SOMETIMES CAN BE SOMETHING
THAT WE FEEL GOOD ABOUT IN THE
MOMENT. OF BUT IF WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO LOOK AT THE OVERALL
ISSUE OF OF GUNS AND PEOPLE
GETTING HURT WITH THEM I THINK
WE NEED TO LOOK A LITTLE BIT
DEEPER. A AND IF WE REALLY WANT
TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO GET HELP.
THEN I THINK WE NEED TO BE VERY
CAREFUL ABOUT LIFETIME
CONSEQUENCES FOR PEOPLE WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES WE WANT
PEOPLE TO GET HELP WE DON'T WANT
THEM TO BE SHYING AWAY FROM
GETTING HELP NOR DO WE WANT
THEIR FAMILIES NOT TO BE.
SEEKING HELP FOR THEM.
WHEN THEY ARE IN NEED OF HELP A
AND AGAIN WE KNOW MENTAL HEALTH
IS SOMETHING THAT CAN BE TREATED
BUT WE KNOW THAT WE NEED MORE
RESOURCES AND BEING ABLE TO HELP
FOLKS.
SO I WOULD OFFER JUST CAUTION
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT FIXES A FOR
THE PROBLEMS OF SHOOTING.
THEY DECORATE MY MISTER GIPSON
ERICA THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL IN NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT AND THANK THE AUTHOR FROM.
ON CAMPBELL FOR BRINGING THIS
GOOD MEASURE BEFORE US TODAY A
PEOPLE AT RISK OF HARMING
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS SHOULD NOT
HAVE ACCESS ON TO FIREARMS
ACCORDING TO THE BRADY CAMPAIGN
EVERY DAY. NINETY SIX PEOPLE DIE
FROM GUN VIOLENCE
OF THOSE NINETY SIX FIFTY NINE
DIE FROM SUICIDE. IN THE YEAR IN
IN IN THE YEAR THAT THERE IS
THAT THAT'S TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
PEOPLE WHO HAVE DIED FROM
SUICIDE BY.
USE OF A BAR OR THIS SIMPLY
WILL SAVE LIVES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GIPSON DOCTOR
QUIRK PARADOX YA SO I HAVE
ABSTAINED ON SOME GUN GUN BILLS
THAT HAVE LIFETIME.
.
PERIODS WHERE YOU CAN GET A GUN
HOWEVER IN THIS CASE YOU ARE
ALLOWED TO GO TO COURT
CHALLENGES.
SO I THINK IT DOES HAVE THE
PROPER BALANCE.
I'M A VERY MUCHAS CIVIL RIGHTS
PERSON INACIO YOU PERSON. AND.
AGAIN I HAVE NOT AGREED TO
LIFETIME PROHIBITIONS.
IT CANNOT BE CHALLENGED THIS ONE
CAN SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING.
THEY NETWORK.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM.
MR LOW YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH.
I THINK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
THINK THEY MEMBER FROM HE WOULD
FOR ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
EARLIER COMMENTS WITH RESPECT
TO.
MAKING SURE THAT THERE ARE
MECHANISMS IN PLACE TO PETITION.
EVERY FIVE YEARS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THEY WERE SLOW WITH THAT.
CORD BLOOD THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS HER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW THE VOTE
EYES FIFTY FOUR. KNOWS ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WHAT A PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM
TO SIXTY SEVEN?
THAT BRINGS US TO FOLLOW ON TO
SIXTY EIGHT.
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
PEOPLE'S.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR WOULD PREVENT
SCHOOL DISTRICT FROM TAKING
UNNECESSARY PUNITIVE ACTION
AGAINST A STUDENT FOR DEBT OWED
BY THE STUDENT'S PARENT OR
GUARDIAN.
DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN KNOWN TO
CARE TO DENY HONOR CERTIFICATES
TRANSCRIPTS AND DIPLOMAS
PARTICIPATION GRADUATION
CEREMONIES AND PARTICIPATION
FIELD TRIPS WHEN A PEOPLE'S
PARENT OR GUARDIAN OWES A DEBT
TO THE SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THESE ADVERSE ACTIONS ULTIMATELY
PUNISHES STUDENT ON AN ISSUE
THAT THEY HAVE LITTLE OR NO
CONTROL ABOUT SOMETIMES NO
KNOWLEDGE OF.
FURTHERMORE THIS BILL WOULD
PROHIBIT A DEBT COLLECTOR FROM
REPORTING DEBT OWED BY A PARENT
OR GUARDIAN TOOK CREDIT
REPORTING AGENCY WOULD ALSO
PROHIBIT SCHOOL DISTRICT FROM
SELLING THE DEBT TO A THIRD
PARTY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
VOTE.
THEY RESIDENTS ALSO PLEASURE
SEEM ARMY. MS QUIRK SILVA
PURITY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS A STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AYE
TO OFTEN SAW STUDENTS AS YOUNG
AS KINDERGARTEN BE DENIED
LUNCHES BECAUSE OF THE DEBT ON
THE BOOKS FOR A. LARGE IN
ADDITION WITH ALL THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY OUT THERE MANY MANY
STUDENTS UP PARENTS WOULD HAVE
TO SIGN OFF ON SOME TYPE OF
TECHNOLOGY NOT REALIZING THE
MOUNT IT WOULD COST. AND THE
DEBT THAT WOULD FOLLOW AND MANY
TIMES AS STUDENTS MOVED OR SOME
TYPE OF TECHNOLOGY WAS LOST THIS
TO WOULD FOLLOW AND MANY PARENTS
WOULD THEN HAVE CREDIT ISSUE. SO
I STAND IN SUPPORT OF A. B..
NINE EIGHTY NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR I DON'T HAVE MY GLASSES ON.
EIGHTEEN.
THANK YOU MS QUIRK SILVA SAY NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL GROW.
THESE ARE VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
PARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF AN ICE FORTY
FOUR NO SEVENTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM.
TWO SIXTY NINE IS AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE BY SOME A MEMBER KANSEN CHU
AND ACTUALLY THE SOLID WASTE.
RESEARCH YOU YOU MAY OPEN CHECK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE IS A DISTRICT BILL.
ADDRESSING SONG LOCAL OLDER
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN HAN THAT
THOSE PEOPLE WHO LIVE HERE WHO
WORKED HERE ARE A WHO GOES TO
SCHOOL HERE.
SPECIFICALLY IT WILL FORMALIZE
THE CURRENT HOUSE FORCE
TO BRING STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER
TO WORK ON A SOLUTION.
THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL PERMIT
REQUIREMENTS OR ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS
ATTACHED TO THIS BILL. I'M NOT
LOOKING TO THE SHOT ANYONE DOWN.
WIDER.
THE CURRENT HOUSE FOR STAFF
SABRI DID THAT THIS BILL WILL BE
FORMALIZED
WAS FORMED IN TWENTY FIFTEEN AND
IS STILL ON GOING.
I'M HOLE FOR DEAD. IT WILL SERVE
AS A PLACE FOR LOCAL ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES
CITIES OF SAN JOSE MILPITAS
SANTA CLARA AND FREMONT. AND THE
FACILITIES STAFF COULD BE
A SOURCE OF ORDERS TO WORK
TOGETHER AND WORK HOME REMEDIES
TO FIX IT ADDRESSING THIS
PROBLEM.
I APPRECIATE TASK FORCES AFTER
SO FAR. BUT WHICH ALL HAVE THREE
D..
DID TO STAKEHOLDERS IN THERE
ALTHOUGH STAKEHOLDERS IN HER
ROOM DO GROUP CAP ONLY DO. SO
MUCH
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE WILL
BRING ALL THE STILL THOSE.
STAKEHOLDERS IN PUBLIC TOGETHER.
PROMOTE CALL THE COOPERATION AND
FIND A SOLUTION TO SOLVE AN
ISSUE DEATH HOUSE BEING
IMPACTING PEOPLE WHO LIVE. OR
LIVING AND WORKING IN AND THAT.
A AREA NEARBY SO I URGE FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AMOS DOCTOR EGGMAN MIRACULOUS.
I THINK IT WAS SPEAKER MEMBERS
OF US RESPECTFULLY RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
YEAH YOU KNOW LESTER I WAS A
PART OF THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE THAT WE
DID TO TRY TO DIVERT AS MUCH FOR
THOSE WE COULD FROM LANDFILLS.
SO OUR OUR LANDFILL COMMUNITY
ARE DOING THE VERY BEST THEY CAN
TO BE ABLE TAKEN EVERYTHING
WE'RE SAYING DOESN'T NEED TO GO
IN AND HOW WE DEAL WITH ALL OF
THOSE THOSE ISSUES.
AND SOMETIMES WHEN WE HAVE LAND
USE ISSUES WHEN CITIES BUILD
RIGHT UP TO LANDFILLS IT BECOMES
THERE ARE SMELLS ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT. AT THIS PARTICULAR ONE IS
ALSO ON A BAY WHICH ALSO HAS OR
A LARGE AMOUNT OF SMELLS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT. OTHERS
ALREADY TASK FORCE IN PLACE THIS
AND AND THE.
THE PEOPLE WASTE MANAGEMENT
LANDFILL PEOPLE ARE INVOLVED
WITH THAT.
THIS PUT ANOTHER THAT ONEROUS.
TASK FORCE ON TOP OF THE WHAT
ALREADY EXISTING ONE AND I WOULD
JUST CAUTION ALL OF US AS WE'RE
ALL MOVING FORWARD.
LOOKING AT HOW WE DIVERT OUR
STATE THINGS TO THE LANDFILL HOW
DO WE TREAT OUR TRASH AND I
REALLY BELIEVE TRASH THE
UNDERBELLY OF AMERICAN SOCIETY
AND NOW CHINA IS SAYING THAT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO TAKE OUR
REFUSE ANYMORE.
SO WE WE HAVE ISSUES WE HAVE
PEOPLE LIVING AROUND THEM AND I
THINK WE NEED TO REALLY HELP THE
INDUSTRY HELP THEMSELVES AND NOT
CONTINUE TO PORT EXTRA BURDENS
ON IN TRYING TO DO THEIR JOBS.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. ON THE ITEM.
MISTER CHIU YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EITHER AGAIN
TO CSUS TRYING TO CODIFY. AND
EXISTING TASK FORCE AND
TOADSTOOL WILL WE BE ABLE TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE CITIES
AROUND THE.
AFFECTED AREA KILL ALL BE PART
OF THE DISCUSSION.
I ASK FOR YOUR ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU.
WITH THAT TOOK OVER THE ROLE
I'M.
IT IS OUR TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
MISTER CHIU.
MISTER CHIU MOVES CALL
.
MEMBERS AND FILE ORDER FILE ITEM
TO SEVENTIES AB TWENTY FIFTEEN.
OPERATE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIFTEEN BY
SELLING MEMBER REYES AND
ACTUALLY A PEOPLE INSTRUCTION.
ISRAEL'S YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU
AB TWENTY FIFTEEN WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS. TO OFFER PROPER
INSTRUCTION ON THE COMPLETION OF
THE FREE APPLICATION FOR FEDERAL
STUDENT AID OF THE FAB SO.
OR THE CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT
APPLICATION.
INSTRUCTION MUST BE GIVEN TO
STUDENTS AT LEAST ONCE BEFORE
THE STUDENT BEGINS GRADE TWELVE.
AND THROUGH THIS BILL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND CHARTER SCHOOLS
WILL BE GIVEN THE FLEXIBILITY TO
DETERMINE HOW TO DELIVER THIS
INFORMATION.
RECEIVING ASSISTANCE CAN MAKE
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHETHER
OR NOT A STUDENT ATTENDS A
COLLEGE.
SO WE MUST ENSURE THAT STUDENTS
ARE GIVEN EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO
PROPERLY PREPARE. AB TWENTY
FIFTEEN IS A STRAIGHTFORWARD
MEASURE THAT AIMS TO PROMOTE
COLLEGE READY READING THOSE AND
AWARENESS BY INSURING THAT OUR
STUDENTS KNOW ABOUT THE
RESOURCES. AVAILABLE THAT THEY
CAN HELP THAT CAN HELP PAY FOR
COLLEGE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THING IS REYES DOCTOR CHOI YOUR
REGULAR.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS.
I RISE TO AS A LIFELONG
EDUCATOR.
I AM A VIGOROUS A SUPPORTER. OF
ENSURING THAT THE.
CALIFORNIA SUCH CHILDREN HAVE
ACCESS OF TWO ONE
CLASSIFICATION.
HIGHER EDUCATION IS OUR AREA.
KEY STEP. IN THE LETTER OVER
SUCCESS ON AND ON A KEY ELEMENT
UP TO ACHIEVING THE AMERICAN
DREAM.
AS I'M IMMIGRANT THAT WITH THIS
COUNTRY ATTAINING A. A HIGHER.
COLLEGE EDUCATION HAS MADE ALL
THE DIFFERENCE
FOR ME AND THE FOR MY FAMILY AND
I RECOGNIZE. IS A CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE IMPORTERS
HOWEVER.
WELL INTENDED NOT.
ALTHOUGH.
THIS BILL IMPOSED HIS TOP ON ONE
NECESSARY MANDATE TO ON SCHOOL
ROUTE DISTRICTS ARE THAT ARE
GOVERNED BY LOCALLY ELECTED
BOARD SO OF ATROCITIES THAN ON
UPON CHARTER SCHOOL HOURS.
S. OF FORMER ELECTED OFF.
A MEMBER OF THE IRVINE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
A TRUSTEE.
I HAVE ALWAYS HAVE BEEN NOT
COMMITTED AWFUL PROMOTING A HIGH
YOUR EDUCATION ACCESS.
I BELIEVE. THAT THE END OF THE
MANDATE. FROM THE SACRAMENTO IS
ON UNNECESSARY INTRUSION ON
LOCAL CONTROL.
IT TOOK.
COMMUNICATES.
THE LACK OF CONFIDENCE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE PASSED A IN
LOCAL DISTRICTS
COUNSELORS TEACHERS SAW AND THE
PARENTS.
THIS LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO MOVE
AWAY FROM THE US SACRAMENTO
KNOWS BEST.
MODEL OF A POLICY. MAKING.
I RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SO.
THIS SAW.
ONE NECESSARY YEAH UNFUNDED
MANDATE I OR IT YOU KNOW FOR.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
MS REYES WHO MAKE CLOTHES IF YOU
WISH.
THANK YOU AT THAT. THE QUESTION
OF LOCAL CONTROL WAS BROUGHT UP
AND IN FACT THAT WAS ONE. ONE OF
THE AMENDMENTS ACCEPTED WAS THE
FLEXIBILITY ALLOWING THE SCHOOLS
TO DETERMINE JUST HOW THEY WOULD
DO THIS I THINK.
SCHOOLS WILL ARE WERE ALL IN
AGREEMENT THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT SHOULD BE DONE THEY WANTED
TO BE ABLE TO CONTROL HOW IT WAS
DONE.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY HIS REYES WITH BACKLOG
LIBERAL. ON MEMBERS.
THE START OF A LITTLE MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER OWN TYLER HIGHS FORTY
FIVE.
KNOWS ELEVEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TWO SEVENTY ONE.
IS AB TWENTY TWENTY NINE BY
MISTER EDUARDO GARCIA CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWENTY NINE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND ACTUALLY THE MEDI CAL.
MISTER ARCEO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES THIS BILL EXPANDS THE
DEFINITION OF CHANGE IN SERVICE
OF SCOPE. RELATING TO OPERATE
COSTS ATTRIBUTABLE TO CAPITAL
EXPENDITURES.
TO INCLUDE THE ADOPTION
IMPLEMENTATION OF UPGRADE OR
CERTIFIED ELECTRONIC HEALTH
SYSTEMS PERTAINING TO FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CARE. CENTERS
IN RURAL CLINICS IN CALIFORNIA
RESPECT YES FOR RIVAL.
THEY MUST GARCIA SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLERK LIBERAL. ON THE.
THAT IS ARE VOTE ON THE WRIST
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
FOUR.
NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TWO SEVENTY TWO.
IS AB TWENTY THIRTY ONE
CROCKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THIRTY ONE
BY FAMILY MEMBER O'DONNELL AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
CONTRACTS.
MISTER O'DONNELL. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
TWO ZERO THREE ONE REMOVES THE
SUNSET REQUIRING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
RECEIVING STATE SCHOOL BOND
FUNDS TO PRE QUALIFY CONTRACTORS
FOR ANY CONSTRUCTION PROJECT
OVER. ONE MILLION DOLLARS.
UNDER A PREQUEL OF OCCASION
PROCESS CONTRACTORS AND CERTAIN
SUBCONTRACTORS.
ARE REQUIRED TO COMPLETE A
QUESTIONNAIRE AND PROVIDE
FINANCIAL INFORMATION ABOUT THE
COMPANY.
PREVIEW ALL PRE QUALIFICATION
SAVES MONEY BY AWARDING
CONTRACTS TO MORE QUALIFIED
BIDDERS.
AND REDUCING THE RISK OF
SELECTING A CONTRACTOR BASED
SOLELY. ON A LOW BID.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES ARE EXPECT LAST NIGHT OF.
DAVIS O'DONNELL SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLICK LIBERAL. AND.
IT IS OUT OF OUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT
CLERK WILL. CLOSE A ROLL AND
TELL THEM.
EYES SIXTY FOUR KNOWS ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES
WE ARE MOVING.
I'LL ORDER TO ITEM TWO NINETEEN
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION ONCE HAD BY
SOME A MEMBER MULLIN. ABILITY TO
TARGET DYSKINESIA AWARENESS WEEK
THANK YOU SOME EVER MULLIN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
HR ONE TEN PROCLAIMS THE WEEK OF
MAY TWENTY FIRST TWENTY
EIGHTEEN.
PART I'VE DYSKINESIA AWARENESS
WEEK WHICH RECOGNIZES THE NEED
FOR INCREASED AWARENESS.
OF THIS OFTEN UNRECOGNIZED AND
MISDIAGNOSED CONDITION.
MANY PEOPLE SERIOUS CHRONIC
MENTAL ILLNESS REQUIRE TREATMENT
WITH MEDICATIONS THAT BLOCK
DOPAMINE RECEPTORS IN THE BRAIN
SUCH AS ANTI PSYCHOTICS.
WELL THESE MEDICATIONS CAN BE
VERY HELPFUL EVEN LIFESAVING.
FOR SOME PATIENTS THIS CAN CAUSE
T. D. ARE MOVEMENT DISORDER
CHARACTERIZED BY UNCONTROLLABLE.
ABNORMAL AND REPETITIVE
MOVEMENTS OF THE TRUNK
EXTREMITIES AND OR FACE.
RESEARCH SUGGESTS THE OVERALL
RISK OF DEVELOPING TD FOLLOWING
PROLONGED EXPOSURE TO ANTI
PSYCHOTICS IS BETWEEN THIRTY TO
FIFTY PERCENT.
TV IMPACTS APPROXIMATELY FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE ACROSS
THE COUNTRY ROUGHLY SIX.
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
LIKE CAN BE CHALLENGING ENOUGH
FOR INDIVIDUAL STRUGGLING WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS IT BECOMES EVEN
MORE DIFFICULT. WITH
EMBARRASSING SIDE EFFECTS
BROUGHT ON BY MEDICATION MEMBERS
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
RECOGNIZING. THE WEEK OF MAY
TWENTY FIRST AUG TWENTY.
.
EIGHTEEN.
S. TART I'VE DYSKINESIA
AWARENESS WEEK.
AND I. ACID FIRST ROLE BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU SING NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK ABOUT A QUICKLY IS OPEN
THE ROLE FOR COOPERS.
THIS ROLE IS FOR COAUTHORS
MEMBERS.
THIS RULES FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS RULES FOR CO AUTHORS.
ADEQUATE PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE.
THERE ARE FIFTY SIXTY FIVE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY SAYING
AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MOVING BACK IN FIVE ORDER TO
ITEM TWO SEVENTY FIVE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY.
SORRY I'M SORRY TO SEVENTY
THREE.
S. ILLEGAL TWENTY FORTY SIX BY
FAMILY MEMBER DALY ACKLINGTON
INSURANCE.
SOME MEMBER DALY ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS LAST YEAR THE STATE
AUDITOR CONDUCTED AN EXAMINATION
OF THE WORKERS COMPENSATION
FRAUD PROGRAM.
AT BOTH THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS.
THAT REPORT CONTAINED A NUMBER
OF RECOMMENDATIONS MOSTLY
SUGGESTIONS TO THOSE TWO
DEPARTMENTS.
TO IMPROVE THEIR OPERATIONS IN
THEIR COMMUNICATION.
THE AUDITOR ALSO SUGGESTED SOME
CHANGES IN THE STATUTES.
IN THIS AREA FOR INSTANCE THE
BILL WILL AUTHORIZE THE FRAUD
ASSESSMENT COMMISSION TO USE ON
EXPENDED FUNDS FROM ONE YEAR TO
AUGMENT THE FUNDING IN A
SUBSEQUENT YEAR.
THE BILL ALSO MANDATES RATHER
THAN ALLOWS CERTAIN DATA SHARING
BETWEEN THOSE TWO DEPARTMENTS.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SING THEIR REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TELLING THE VOTES EYES
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVIE NIGHT OUT NOW TO ITEM TWO
SEVENTY FOUR MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FORTY NINE
BY SOMETHING MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AND ACT LIKE A
SCHOOLING COMMITTEE COLLEGE
EMPLOYEES THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THINKING THAT
SPEAKER AB TWENTY FORTY NINE IS
A SIMPLE BILL THAT MAKES THE
PROCESSING OF CAMINO COLLEGE IN
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
UNION MEMBERSHIP DUES. UNIFORM
AT THE CURRENT PROCEDURE THAT
FITS FOR PROCESSING TEACHERS USE
THIS BILL HAS NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION IN IRAQ RESPECTFULLY
ASPIRIN I'VE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE METAPHOR QUIZ OPEN THE
ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
MEDICARE PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
TALLY THE VOTES EYES FORTY SIX
KNOWS TWENTY ONE THE MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEMS TO SEVENTY SIX PASS AND
RETAIN MOVING OUT ITEM TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVENTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY
AND ACTUALLY THE SEX OFFENSES.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS
BILL CLOSES A LOOPHOLE THAT
ALLOWS SOME PROFESSIONAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO ESCAPE APPROPRIATE
PUNISHMENT.
COMMITTING SERIOUS CRIMES
THESE PERPETRATORS ARE TYPICALLY
IN POSITIONS OF TRUST.
SUCH AS CHIROPRACTORS MASSAGE
THERAPISTS OR PHYSICAL
THERAPISTS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW A FELONY SEX
OFFENSE OCCURS WHEN A MASSEUSE
ENGAGES IN A SEXUAL ACT BY FORCE
AGAINST A CUSTOMER. OR WHEN THE
MASSEUSE UNLAWFULLY RESTRAINS A
CUSTOMER.
BUT IF A MASSEUSE IS PROVIDING A
MASSAGE TO A CUSTOMER AND
SUDDENLY GROPES THE CUSTOMER'S
INTIMATE PARTS WITHOUT FORCE.
UNLAWFUL RESTRAINT OR FRAUD A
PROSECUTOR MAY BE LIMITED TO
PURSUING MISDEMEANOR CHARGES
UNDER CURRENT LAW. THIS BILL
ALLOWS PROSECUTORS TO PURSUE
EITHER MISDEMEANOR OR FELONY
CHARGES DEPENDING ON THE
SEVERITY THE CRIMES THE BILL
SIMPLY CLOSES A LOOPHOLE THAT
NEEDS TO BE CLOSED. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN OUR REQUEST TO
SPEAK METAPHORICALLY IS OPEN THE
ROLE.
I'M SORRY I DIDN'T HAVE THAT BIG
YOUR PARDON AS A MEMBER
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I RISE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO ZERO SEVEN
EIGHT.
THERE ARE A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
YEARS ON THE BOOKS A VERY FIRM
LEGISLATION IN THE AREA OF
IMPLIED AND EXPRESSED CONSENT.
THE EXISTING STATUTES
EXTENSIVELY COVER THIS AREA.
IT MAY SEEM APPEALING TO
REINFORCE WHAT IS ALREADY THERE
BUT THE FACT IS WE SIMPLY. DON'T
NEED IT AND UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES ARE POSSIBLE.
I URGE CAUTION IN RESPECTFULLY
URGE OR NO VOTE ON AB TWO ZERO
SEVEN EIGHT.
THANK YOU WITH SOME EVER DALY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS.
THIS BILL WAS SO IS THERE ARE
SPECIFIC CASES THAT THE LOCAL
DA'S HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO
PROSECUTE I FEEL PRETTY STRONGLY
THAT.
.
THE DA SHOULD HAVE THAT
DISCRETION TO PROSECUTE THESE
TYPES OF CRIMES THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE. OF MEMBERS WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK MAKE CLOSE THE
RULING TALLY THE VOTES HIGH
SIXTY FOUR NO ONE. THE ITEM
PASSES MOVING BACK TO ITEM TWO
SEVENTY FIVE AB TWENTY FIFTY
FOUR MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIFTY FOUR
BY SOME A MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
TO AGRICULTURAL PESTS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER THIS MAY BE MY
WITH LEAST CONTROVERSIAL BILL
EVER IN THE HISTORY OF BEING IN
THE ASSEMBLY. AB TWENTY FIFTY
FOUR SIMPLY PROTECTS CALIFORNIA
TREES BY SET UP A FRAMEWORK OF
COOPERATION BETWEEN STAPLE STATE
LOCAL. AGENCIES AND STAKEHOLDERS
TO COMBAT THE SPREAD OF THE SHOT
HOLE BOARD FEEL I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE RIGHT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM TWO SEVENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY TWENTY SEVENTY NINE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVENTY
NINE BY SIMPLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AND OTHERS AND EXPLAIN
TO EMPLOYMENT.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
JANITORIAL WORKERS ARE MONTHS
THE MOST VULNERABLE WORKERS IN
OUR SOCIETY THIS INCREASING LEAD
FEMALE WORKFORCE OFTEN WORKS
ALONE AND AT NIGHT. WORKERS
OFTEN DO NOT KNOW WHERE TO
REPORT ABUSE IS WHEN THEY DO
HAPPEN AND MANY SUPERVISORS NOT
TRAINED PROPERLY ON HOW TO
RESPOND LEAVING THESE WORKERS
KNOW WHERE TO TURN. THIS
ISOLATION HAS ALLOWED PERMITTED
TERRIBLE ABUSES ACROSS THE
INDUSTRY.
AB TWENTY SEVEN NINE WORKS TO
CHANGE THE CULTURE OF HARASSMENT
FEAR IN THE JANITORIAL INDUSTRY
WHICH FOR TOO LONG HAS TURNED A
BLIND EYE TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AND ASSAULT. THIS LEGISLATION
EMPOWER JANITORIAL SERVICE
WORKERS BY UTILIZING EXISTING
PEER COUNSELORS OR PERMIT TAUGHT
US TO PROVIDE CULTURALLY
COMPETENT TRAINING TO FELLOW
JANITORIAL WORKERS ON HOW TO
PREVENT SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
ASSAULT IN THE WORKPLACE.
PEER TO PEER COUNSELING HAS
SHOWN TO BE EFFECTIVE TEACHING
TOOL ALLOWING WORKERS MORE
CLOSELY RELATE TO THEIR PEER
COUNSELOR AS OPPOSED TO AN
OUTSIDE SOURCE OR AGENCY WHILE
ALSO CHIPPING AWAY AT THE
ISOLATION THAT HAS ALLOW THESE
PERPETUAL ABUSES IN THE
WORKPLACE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SEEING THEIR REQUEST TO SPEAK
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE OF TALLY THE VOTES.
A AYES FORTY THREES AND NO
EIGHTEEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM TO SEVENTY
NINE AB TWENTY NINETY FOUR
METAPHOR PLEASE READ. SOME
LITTLE TWENTY NINETY FOUR PRICE
ONLY MEMBER KALRA AND ACTUALLY
THE HAZARDOUS WASTE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COLOR YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPTIMISM AB
TWENTY NINETY FOUR DAY.
AB TWENTY NINETY FOUR AS A
WREATH INTRODUCTION TO LAST
YEAR'S AB ELEVEN SEVENTY NINE.
WHICH RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
IT WAS VETOED BY GOVERNOR BROWN
BUT CONTINUES TO SERVE AS PART
OF A LARGER DISCUSSION ON THE
NEED FOR D. T. S. C.. STRUCTURAL
REFORM.
A BETWEEN NINETY FOUR REQUIRES
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL DISSIDENT MANAGE RAMEN
ROOM TO ENSURE THE DEPARTMENTS
EFFECTIVELY MONITORING AND
ENFORCING COMPLIANCE.
DISABILITIES IN ITS CHARGE.
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
EXPRESSED CONCERNS REGARDING THE
REGULATION OF HAZARDOUS WASTE
FACILITIES
ONE OF THE MOST EGREGIOUS
EXAMPLES WAS THE BATTERY
RECYCLING PLANT OPERATED BY
EXIDE TECHNOLOGIES. IN THE CITY
OF VERNON SOUTHEAST LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WHICH IT ALLOWED TO GO
UNCHECKED OVER THIRTY THREE
YEARS. DUE TO LACK PERMITTING
AND ENFORCEMENT.
THE RESPONSE OF THIS AND OTHER
EVENTS LEGISLATOR INCLUDED THE
LEGISLATURE INCLUDED IN THE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN PUBLIC
RESOURCES BUDGET TRAILER BILL. A
REQUIREMENT THE DTS SEE
ESTABLISH INDEPENDENT REVIEW
PANEL TO REVIEW AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING
IMPROVEMENTS TO DTS SEES
PROVIDING. ENFORCEMENT PUBLIC
OUTREACH AND FISCAL MANAGEMENT.
THE I RP RECOMMENDED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE INCLUDE INSPECTION
FREQUENCIES IN STATUE BASED ON
FACILITY COMPLIANCE HISTORY
QUALITY OF WASTE. TOXICITY RISK
AND PROXIMUS PROXIMITY TO
SENSITIVE HABITATS AND
POPULATIONS AT RISK INCLUDING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
REGULAR AND WARREN FREQUENT
INSPECTIONS CAN HELP AVOID
EXPOSING THE PUBLIC AND THE
ENVIRONMENT TO HARMFUL TOXINS.
AB TWENTY NINETY FOUR WILL HELP
ENSURE THE VIOLATIONS OF
DISCOVERED QUICKLY AND
FACILITIES ARE BROUGHT BACK INTO
COMPLIANCE THEREBY MINIMIZING
HARM TO NEARBY COMMUNITIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM FOR PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
NOW MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MISTER KALRA.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE THE CALL ON
THAT.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM TWO EIGHTY AB
TWENTY NINETY EIGHT.
NOT A QUICKLY THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINETY
EIGHT BY SOME REMEMBER MCCARTY
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
SOMEWHERE MCCARTY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER THIS MEASURE WOULD
ESTABLISH TO CALIFORNIA AFTER
SCHOOL KIDS CODE PILOT PROGRAM
TO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS MONNING STEM
EDUCATION.
AND FOCUS ON COMPUTER CODING WE
KNOW THAT OUR CALIFORNIA ECONOMY
IS DYNAMIC AND NEED IT
WORKERS WITH THE SCHOOL SKILLS
NECESSARY TO COMPETE IN THE
GLOBAL ECONOMY.
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE NOT KEEPING
PACE
AB THE DEMANDS OF OUR GROWING
TECHNOLOGY SECTOR WE ALSO KNOW
THAT HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
GREAT AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
AND MARRYING THESE TWO THINGS WE
THINK WE HAVE A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON
DIVERSIFYING OUR TECHNOLOGY
SECTOR INCREASING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR. A UNDERSERVED STUDENTS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
S. MEASURES RESEARCHER RECEIVED
FINANCE UNANIMOUS SUPPORT TO
DATE AND I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ONCE AGAIN.
THANK YOU SOME MEMBER THURMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ARE RISE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY NINETY EIGHT I'D LIKE
TO THANK MY JOINT AUTHOR. FROM
SACRAMENTO A FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
IN THIS EFFORT AS YOU HEARD.
THIS WOULD CREATE AN AFTER
SCHOOL CODING TRAINING PROGRAM
FOR OUR STUDENTS AND HELP
PREPARE OUR STUDENTS FOR THE
JOBS OF TOMORROW.
THEIR ESTIMATES THAT THEY'LL BE
A MILLION AND A HALF JOBS IN
TECHNOLOGY IN ONLY HALF. THE
APPLICANTS IN CALIFORNIA FOR
THOSE JOBS AND LET'S MAKE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN OUR
STUDENTS NOW. I'M THE AFTER
SCHOOL TIMES ONE OF THE BEST
TIMES TO WORK WITH OUR STUDENTS
ON CODING AND STEM THE
TECHNOLOGY IN THIS IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE. UP
CALIFORNIA FORWARD ON BEHALF OF
OUR STUDENTS ARE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER REQUEST
TO SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS ROOMS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK WITH CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW THE VOTES.
I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM TWO EIGHTY
ONE A. B. TWENTY ONE ELEVEN
MADAM QUICKLY THREE. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE ELEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK AND ACTION
AND PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER QUIRK YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
IF%
IT COUNTY DETERMINES A SPONSORED
NON CITIZEN WOULD GO HUNGRY AND
HOMELESS WITHOUT A.
AB TWENTY ONE ELEVEN.
WILL REQUIRE COUNTIES TO RENEW
CAL WORKS BENEFITS.
TO AN ELIGIBLE SPONSORED
INDIGENT NON CITIZEN.
THIS CHANGE WILL ALIGN CAO WORKS
EXCEPTION PROVISIONS CHEVROLET
WITH THOSE USED FOR CAL FRESH TO
THE EXTENT PERMITTED BY FEDERAL
LAW.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON.
I MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM TO EIGHTY TWO AB
TWENTY ONE ELEVEN. MATTER
QUICKLY THREE. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY AND
ACTUALLY THE MEDI CAL DECLARING
THE URGENCY THERE UP TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY THINK YOU'RE
SOME EVER COOLEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
CALL A SIMPLICITY TO RICE RESENT
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN.
S. RELATES TO MEDI CAL
REIMBURSEMENT AND EMERGENCY
MEDICAL TRANSPORT.
LAST YEAR ON.
A PROGRAM MORE CALLOUS PRIVATE
MEDICAL SUPPLIERS.
CREATED A QUALITY ASSURANCE FEE
WHICH WILL KICK IN ON JULY
FIRST.
OF THIS YEAR. ARE TIED TO EACH
EMERGENCY MEDICAL TRANSPORT.
IN CALIFORNIA.
AS D. H. S. WORKED ON MODEL IN
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS THEY
CONCLUDED THAT THAT FEE.
ADDED TO.
PUBLIC SECTOR AMBULANCES WILL
ACTUALLY.
REDUCE THE AVAILABLE FUNDS OF
THE PUBLIC SECTOR FOR MEDICAL
SERVICES OF THIS TYPE. SO THIS
BILL SIMPLY EXEMPTS THE PUBLIC
SECTOR PROVIDER. FOR THIS
UNEXPECTED OUTCOME AND THEREBY
SUPPORTS ACCESS TO CARE.
JURAI VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE METALCORE PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TELLING THE VOTES I
SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
AB.
I AM SORRY SIXTY FIVE. YES AND
NO ZERO IN THE URGENCY SIXTY
FIVE YES NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING OUT IT'S TO EIGHTY THREE
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY FOUR MATTER
QUICKLY THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE TWENTY
FOUR BY SEVEN NUMBER REEFS RUBIO
AND OTHERS ACTUALLY AND CRIMES.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO.
THE MEDICS THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE TWENTY FOUR WILL
PROTECT. PROTECT SURVIVORS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING BY ULTIMATELY
PROVIDING DISTRICT ATTORNEY
OFFICES WITH ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO EMPLOY VERTICAL PROSECUTORS
IN HUMAN TRAFFICKING CASES.
APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN THOUSAND
TO SEVENTEEN THOUSAND VICTIMS
ARE TRAFFIC IT TRAFFIC IT. INTO
THE UNITED STATES ANNUALLY
BETWEEN TWENTY TEN AND TWENTY
TWELVE CALIFORNIA'S NINE
REGIONAL HUMAN TRAFFICKING TASK
FORCES IDENTIFIED.
ONE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED SEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN VICTIMS INITIATED
TWO THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY TWO INVESTIGATIONS
ARRESTED ONE THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED AND NINETY EIGHT
INDIVIDUALS. AND PROVIDED
CRITICAL TRAINING TO MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL
PROSECUTORS VICTIM SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND FIRST RESPONDERS.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS A FORM OF
MODERN DAY SLAVERY INVOLVING
INVOLVING USE OF FORCE FRAUD OR
COERCION TO RECRUIT HARBOR
TRANSPORT PROVIDE OR OBTAIN THE
PERSON. FOR THE PURPOSES OF
LABOR OR SEXUAL EXPLOITATION.
IN ADDITION CAL O. YES WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE A REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE. OUTLINING THE
NUMBER OF PROSECUTIONS FOR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CASES THE NUMBER OF
CONVICTIONS AND SENTENCES
IMPOSED.
I THINK YOU ANNOUNCED FOR YOUR
BY A VOTE.
THANK YOU OF SOME OF OUR BAKER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I THINK
ARE GOOD CALLING FROM BALDWIN
PARK IT'S GOOD TO BE. A TEAM
MEMBER WITH YOU ON THIS AND.
WORKING AS CO AUTHORS JOINT
AUTHORS AND MEMBERS WE HAVE
PASSED ON THIS FLOOR EACH YEAR
FOR THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
INCLUDING THIS YEAR MEASURES.
RESOLUTIONS CALLING ON THE NEED
TO BETTER FIGHT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND REDUCE ITS
PREVALENCE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE FBI HAS A LIST OF TEN WORST
HUMAN TRAFFICKING LOCATIONS IN
THE UNITED STATES CALIFORNIA HAS
THREE OF THEM. AND IN MY FIRST
TWO YEARS IN THE ASSEMBLY THREE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING RINGS ARE
BROKEN UP IN NEIGHBORHOODS IN MY
DISTRICT IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
WAYS TO ACTUALLY HELP FIGHT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. THIS BILL IS
ONE OF THE MOST CONCRETE
EFFECTIVE WAYS TO DO IT
PARTICULARLY IN A WAY THAT IS
VICTIM CENTRIC BY FUNDING
VERTICAL PROSECUTION AND
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OFFICES. A
ELEVEN IN THEM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE NOT ONLY
HELPING PROSECUTORS BETTER FIGHT
THIS CRIME AND FULLY BRING TO
JUSTICE THOSE WHO TRAFFIC.
VICTIMS BUT WERE ALSO DOING IT
IN A WAY THAT IS MUCH BETTER FOR
THE VICTIMS MANY TIMES THESE
VICTIMS ARE SIMILAR TO.
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
SPOUSAL ABUSE THEY HAVE A VERY
DIFFICULT TIME COOPERATING WITH
THOSE WHO TRY TO HELP THEM THEY
MOST IDENTIFY WITH THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN HURTING THEM. AND THIS
TYPE OF PROSECUTION ALLOWS THE
VICTIM TO HAVE ONE PROSECUTOR
ALL THROUGHOUT THIS THE PROCESS
SO THE PROSECUTOR GETS REALLY
GOOD AT THESE CASES AND THE
VICTIM IS BETTER SERVED. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THIS IS A LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS PRIORITY BELT THINK YOU.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM TWO EIGHTY
FOUR AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX
METAPHOR PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX BY
SOMETHING NUMBER EIGHT MEN AND
ACTUALLY NO RESOURCES
CONSERVATION. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EGGMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MS SPEAKER REMEMBERS.
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX
ADDICTS CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS MAKES A NEW TRACK IN IT
WORKING WITH PEOPLE TO BY YOUNG
PEOPLE TO WORK IN THE FOREST. AS
WE LOOK AT THE FOREST FIRES IN
THE PROBLEMS WE HAVE WE KNOW
THAT WE MUST TRAIN INVESTING
AREN'T FUTURE GENERATION OF
FORCED WORKERS. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAME QUIRK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MEDICAL PLEASE CLOSE A ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES BY SEVENTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM TWO EIGHTY FIVE
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY SEVEN MEDI
METAPHOR PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE TWENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM AND
ACTUALLY DIALECTIC VEHICLES
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY SEVEN REQUIRES
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION.
BARRY STATEWIDE ASSESSMENT OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE GOVERNOR HAS STATED THE GOAL
OF. TRYING TO GET FIVE MILLION
ELECTRIC IN ZERO EMISSION CARS
ON THE ROAD BY TWENTY THIRTY. IN
ORDER MEET THOSE GOALS WE RE
READING ASSESSMENT THAT PROVIDES
A ROADMAP. FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
BUILD OUT SO WE CAN MEET DEMAND
FOR VEHICLE CHARGING AS MORE
MORE ELECTRIC VEHICLES ARE IN
OUR DAILY USE. THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES AYE
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING NOW ITEM TWO EIGHTY SIX
AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY THREE
METAPHOR PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE THIRTY THREE BY
SOME A MEMBER WEBER AND ACTUALLY
THE STATE SOME RECALL HISTORY
RECORDS THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
YES MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT TO. YOU AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY THREE A BILL
THE SIMPLY PROVIDES CRIMINAL
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS CLEAR ACCESS
TO DOJ'S SUMMARY OF CRIMINAL
HISTORY DATABASE. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HIS
HEAD NO NO VOTES OF THIS SIMPLY
A LEVELS THE PLAYING FIELD FOR
OF CRIMINAL ATTORNEYS AND A
PROSECUTOR IS TO HAVE THE SAME
INFORMATION. WHAT'S NECESSARY TO
PUT.
TO HANDLE THE TRIAL THIS IS
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
AND SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION OF
ACLU. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE BOTH AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY THREE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES. I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM TWO EIGHTY SEVEN PASS AND
RETAIN ITEM TO EIGHTY EIGHT AB
TWENTY ONE.
SIXTY MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY ONE SIXTY
BY SOME A MEMBER THERE MEANT
ACTUALLY THE CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MA'AM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ARE RISE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY OF THIS BILL
WOULD PROVIDE CLASSIFIED SERVICE
TO PART TIME PLAYGROUND WORKERS.
WHO SERVE CHILDREN AT MERIT
BASED SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IF THE CLEAN
UP BILL THAT* AB SIX SEVENTY
FROM LAST YEAR SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR? THAT EXTENDED THE SAME
CLASSIFIED.
SERVICE TO PART TIME PLAYGROUND
WORKERS BUT INADVERTENTLY LEFT
OUT WORKERS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN MERE BASS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AYE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. ON AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY.
THANK YOU SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MATTER QUICKLY IS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I WAS FORTY FOUR KNOWS TWENTY
FOUR THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM TWO EIGHTY
NINE AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT
MADAM QUICKLY THREE. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT BY
SOMETHING MEMBER THURMOND AND
ACTUALLY THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
MAKING A PREPARATION THEREFORE
THANK YOU SO MEMBER THURMAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES ONCE AGAIN PRESENTING
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT A BILL
THAT WOULD HELP TO STRENGTHEN
OUR PROGRAMS AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION. MANY SPECIAL
EDUCATORS WILL TELL YOU HOW THE
EXPERIENCE BURNOUT FROM VERY
DIFFICULT WORK CONDITIONS OF
THIS BILL CREATES A MENTORING
PROGRAM.
SUPPORT SPECIAL EDUCATORS TO BE
SUPPORTED ABOUT MORE EXPERIENCE
AS SPECIAL EDUCATORS AND IT USES
CARRY OVER FUNDS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT WOULD BE
ALLOCATED TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. TO SET
UP THIS MENTORING PROGRAM ON
BEHALF OF ALL OF OUR STUDENTS
AND THOSE WHO ARE SERVED WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
EIGHT.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM TWO NINETY AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY FIVE MATTER QUICKLY
THREE ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND EXPLAINED THE
VESSELS. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY UP MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
FIVE WILL CREATE CONSISTENCY
BETWEEN THE HARBORS THE
NAVIGATION CODE AND THE VEHICLE
CODE BY GIVING PEACE OFFICERS
AND HARBOR PATROL OFFICERS. THE
SAME REMOVAL AUTHORITY FOR
VEHICLES AND VESSELS.
UNDER EXISTING LAW PEACE
OFFICERS CAN REMOVE VEHICLES
FROM PUBLIC PROPERTY IF THEY
HAVE PROBABLE CAUSE TO BELIEVE
THAT THE VEHICLE WAS INVOLVED IN
A CRIME. OR THAT IT WAS EVIDENCE
THING TO A CRIME.
THIS REMOVAL AUTHORITY DOES NOT
EXIST FOR HARBOR PATROL OFFICERS
TO REMOVE VESSELS. THIS FOR THIS
BILL HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SING NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS WHO WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
BENEFIT PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM TO NINETY ONE
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FOUR
METAPHOR PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FOUR BY
SOMETHING MEMBER DAVID CHIU AND
OTHERS NATURALLY AND BUSINESS
LICENSES. ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
FOUR WILL ALLOW MORE MORE
CALIFORNIANS PARTICULARLY FOR
MARK IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES TO
START BUSINESSES BY CLARIFYING
THAT A FEDERAL TAX ID NUMBER. A
CALIFORNIA DRIVER'S LICENSE OR
ANOTHER FORM OF STATE OR LOCAL
ID COULD BE USED TO APPLY FOR A
BUSINESS LICENSE.
WE ALL KNOW THAT THE ECONOMIC
SUCCESS OF OUR STATE HAS BEEN
BUILT BY THE TREMENDOUS WORK OF
IMMIGRANTS WHO CONTRIBUTE THIRTY
TWO PERCENT OF OUR STATE SHE P..
AND ARE ONE IN THREE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS
UNFORTUNATE ABOUT HALF OF OUR
STATE CITIES REQUIRED APPLICANT
FOR A BUSINESS LICENSE TO
PROVIDE A SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
ONLY. WHICH AS BEEN A BARRIER TO
CALIFORNIANS SEEKING ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY THROUGH OWNERSHIP.
THIS BILL BUILDS ON PREVIOUS
STATE LAWS THAT HAVE ALLOWED
APPLICANTS FOR PROFESSIONAL
LICENSES TO PROVIDE A FEDERAL ID
NUMBER AS WELL AS FEDERAL LAW
THAT AUTHORIZES STATES TO MAKE
LICENSES AVAILABLE TO IMMIGRANTS
REGARDLESS OF STATUS.
WE NEED TO WELCOME ALL BUSINESS
FOUNDERS IN OUR ECONOMY IN
CALIFORNIA SHOULD CONTINUE TO
LEAD THE NATION BY DANCING
POLICIES THAT RECOGNIZE THE
INCREDIBLE CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR
IMMIGRANT WORKERS AND BSINESS
FOUNDERS. AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MEDICARE PLEASE CLOSE THE RULING
TALLY THE VOTES.
EYES FORTY FOUR KNOWS NINE THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM TWO NINETY TWO THROUGH TO
NINETY FOUR PASS AND RETAIN.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM TO NINETY
FIVE AB TWENTY ONE NINETY FIVE
METAPHOR PLEASE READ SOME LEGAL
TWENTY ONE NINETY FIVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO AND ACTUALLY
THE GREENHOUSE GASES.
SOME MEMBER CHAO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY FIVE WOULD REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
TO QUANTIFY THE AMOUNT OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE LEAKAGE OF
GAS TO THE ATMOSPHERE DURING THE
PRODUCTION PROCESSING AND ALSO
TRANSPORT OF NATURAL GAS THAT IS
IMPORTED. INTO THE STATE FROM
OUT OF STATE SOURCES.
CALIFORNIA IMPORTS APPROXIMATELY
NINETY PERCENT OF THE NATURAL
GAS IT IS USED IN THE STATE.
METHANE A PRIMARY COMPONENT OF
NATURAL GAS IS EIGHTY FOUR TIMES
MORE POTENT DAN CARBON DIOXIDE
AT TRAPPING HEAT OVER THE COURSE
OF ITS FIRST TWENTY YEARS IN THE
ATMOSPHERE. LEADING TO SERIOUS
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF A LARGE
AMOUNT OF GAS IS LOST INTO THE
ATMOSPHERE.
CORD CURRENTLY ONLY CALCULATES
IN STATE NATURAL GAS.
A COMBUSTION AND LEAKAGE EVEN
THOUGH IN STATE USES RESPONSIBLE
FOR SIGNIFICANT POLLUTION
OUTSIDE THE STATE.
ACCORDINGLY MILLIONS OF TONS OF
TNT POLLUTION GO UNCOUNTED EVERY
SINGLE YEAR. AS A RESULT THE
TRUE ENVIRONMENTAL FOOTPRINT OF
CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS USE
IS HIDDEN FROM THE STATE'S
INVENTORY.
SERVERS AND OUR POLICY MAKERS
AS BILL TWENTY ONE NINETY FIVE
WILL HELP THE STATE TO
ACCURATELY. ARE CALCULATES YOUR
KEY EMISSIONS SO THAT PUBLIC THE
PUBLIC AND THE PUBLIC. AND
POLICYMAKERS CAN'T UNDERSTAND.
SCHOOL OF THE LEAKAGE IT RELATED
TO THIS OUR USE OF NATURAL GAS
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION TO THE TO
THE BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU SEEN A REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO
BUT A PURPOSE CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW THE VOTES. EYES FORTY TWO
KNOWS TWENTY THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
I AM TO NINETY SIX PASS AND
RETAIN.
I AM TO NINETY SEVEN PASS
TEMPORARILY ITEM TO NINETY EIGHT
PASS AND RETAIN MOVING OUT ITEM
TO NINETY NINE. A. B. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY ONE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO
TWENTY ONE VICE ONLY MEMBER
BLOOM NATURALLY THE HEALING
ARTS.
THANK YOU A SUMMER PROBLEM YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. I AM
PRESENTING AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
ONE WHICH UPDATES THE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY PRACTICE
ACT THIS IS A. PRACTICE ACT THAT
WAS FIRST WRITTEN EIGHTEEN YEARS
AGO THIS BILL SIMPLY UPDATES AND
CLARIFIES THE ACT TO ENSURE
THAT.
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPISTS
LIKE MY WIFE.
CAN PRACTICE TO THE FULL EXTENT
OF THEIR EDUCATION TRAINING
THEREFORE I RESPECTFULLY. AND ON
BEHALF OF.
DOMESTIC GOTTA.
TRANQUILITY AT HOME AS FEAR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
BUT A QUIRK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE ANTI THE VOTES I SIXTY FOUR
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM THREE HUNDRED PASSED
RETAIN.
ITEM THREE OH ONE PASS
TEMPORARILY ITEM THREE OH TO
PASS AND RETAIN ITEM THREE A
THREE PASS TEMPORARILY LIVING
OUT ITEM THREE OH FOR AB TWENTY
TWO SIXTY NINE.
MATTER QUICKLY THREE ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY TWO SIXTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES THANK YOU AS A MEMBER
LACKEY YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
THIS PROPOSAL WILL HELP YOU
THROUGH A RECEIVING CAL WORKS
BENEFITS BY EXTENDING THESE
BENEFITS TO CHILDREN. RECEIVING
AID.
UNTIL HERE SHE REACHED REACHES
THE AGE OF TWENTY OF THEIR
ATTENDING THE LAST YEAR OF HIGH
SCHOOL OR ITS EQUIVALENT.
CURRENTLY CAL WORKS PROGRAM
BENEFITS TERMINATE PER PERSON
WHO REACHES THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN
YEAR OLD EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD.
UNLESS THERE'S EVIDENCE HERE SHE
WILL COMPLETE THE SCHOOL
REQUIREMENTS BEFORE TURNING
NINETEEN.
THE NEXT YEAR TO ACQUIRE
EDUCATION CAN MAKE ALL THE
DIFFERENCE TO SOMEONE STRUGGLING
TO COMPLETE THESE REQUIREMENTS
IT'S HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR ITS
EQUIVALENT. HAS PROVEN TO LEAD
TO A HIGHER EARNING POTENTIAL
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN AND NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK METACARPALS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK. PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES ITEM THREE OH
FIVE PASS AND RETAIN BUT A CLERK
I AM PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL
ON ITEM.
ONE NINETY NINE AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTEEN MCCORKLE POST.
I.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES ICE
FIFTY SEVEN KNOWS FIVE THAT
MEASURE PASSED.
MADAM CLERK I'M PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL IN ITEM ONE NINETY
NINE.
I'M SORRY IN ITEM ONE NINETY
EIGHT. AB TWENTY TWENTY.
THE CLERK WILL HOST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TELLING THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY SEVEN NO A LEVIN.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM A THREE OH
SIX AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY TWO
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO SEVENTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAYES AND
ACTUALLY THE HIGHWAYS.
THE SOME MEMBER MAYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER.
AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY TWO WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE CDC
TO RELINQUISH PORTIONS OF STATE
ROUTE OF ONE ELEVEN THE CITY OF
PALM SPRINGS
CITY LIMITS.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MEDI PURPOSE OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
NOT APART PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW THE VOTES I SEVENTY TWO
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM THREE OH SEVEN AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY NINE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
NINE BY SOME REMEMBER WEBER AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO PEOPLE
RIGHTS.
THANK YOU A SOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YES
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
TO YOU AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY NINE
THE YOUNG PARENTS RIGHT TO
EDUCATION ACT. THIS IS A
PRIORITY BILL FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
THIS WOULD CREATE A STATEWIDE
FAMILIES AND SECONDLY POLICY FOR
YOUNG PARENTS AND LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES THAT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO OPT IN IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT THEIR ACADEMIC SUCCESS.
AND REBOUND WITH A INTO BOND
WITHIN AND CARE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
NINE HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES IN
THIS RESPONSIBLE ACT OF WOMEN.
AND GIRLS THE BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE. LETTING US FOR A
GROUP OF FOR REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE ACCESS WOMEN'S HEALTH
CARE JUSTICE AND IS ONE OF THE
ADVOCACY GROUPS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS ALONG WITH SIXTY OTHER
ADVOCACY GROUPS. ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER I VOCAL
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY NINE YOUNG
PARENTS RIGHT TO EDUCATION.
THANK YOU SEEING HIM NO REQUEST
TO SPEAK METACARPALS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MEDICARE PLEASE CLOSE THE ROWING
TALLY THE VOTES I SEVENTY ONE
KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING BACK TO ITEM TO NINETY
SEVEN. AB TWENTY TWO ELEVEN.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL PLANES YOU ELEVEN
BY SELLING OUR LIMON EXPLAINED
CLIMATE CHANGE THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMO YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY TWO ELEVEN WILL FORMALLY
MOVE THE CALIFORNIA GREEN
BUSINESS PROGRAM AWAY FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXICITY TOXIC
SUBSTANCE CONTROL TO THOUGH
WHITER UMBRELLA OF CAL EPA. THIS
SHIP WILL ENSURE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA GREEN BUSINESS
NETWORK WILL CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
THE OVERSIGHT AND SUPPORT NEEDED
TO EXPAND CALIFORNIA'S GREEN
ECONOMY AND THE AMBITIOUS STATE
GOALS. OF SUSTAINABILITY AND
REDUCTION IN GREECE GREENHOUSE
GASES.
THE CALIFORNIA GREEN BUSINESS
NETWORK IS A GREEN BUSINESS
CERTIFYING ORGANIZATION THAT IS
DRIVING FORCE BEHIND SUSTAINABLE
BUSINESS PRACTICES IN CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTING THE REGULATIONS PUT
IN PLACE BY THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL AGENCIES THE GREEN
BUSINESS NETWORK. IS A COST
EFFECTIVE VEHICLE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENTAL
AGENCIES TO MEET THEIR AIR
QUALITY RESOURCE MANAGEMENT AND
WASTE REDUCTION GOALS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DEBATE MADAM
COURT PLEASE OPEN THE RUN. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
PAUL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE
SIXTEEN NINE NOSE ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM THREE OH ONE
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY TWO METAPHOR
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIFTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LIMON AND ACTUALLY THE STATE
GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LIMON YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
NONPROFITS FRANK IS THE FOURTH
LARGEST INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYEE NEARLY ONE MILLION
PEOPLE AND PRODUCING MORE JOBS
THAN THE CONSTRUCTION OF FINANCE
OR REAL ESTATE INDUSTRIES.
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY DOES NOT
HAVE A CENTRALIZED DATABASE THAT
NON PROFITS CAN ACCESS TO
IDENTIFY SEEK GRANTS THEY MAY BE
ELIGIBLE FOR. MAKING IT
DIFFICULT FOR MANY NON PROFITS
TO FIND THE INFORMATION THEY
NEED ABOUT STATE FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES.
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY TWO WILL
CREATE A CENTRALIZED SEARCHABLE
DATABASE OF ALL STATE GRANT
OPPORTUNITIES BY MAKING
CALIFORNIA GRANTS ACCESSIBLE AND
TRANSPARENT WE CAN ENSURE THAT
ALL INTERESTED ENTITIES HAVE A
FAIR SHOT. AT STATE FUNDING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN A REQUEST TO
SPEAK METAPHOR PLEASE OPEN THE
RUN. ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE A TALLY THE VOTES I SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE.
MOVING TO ITEM THREE OH EIGHT AB
TWENTY TWO NINETY TWO MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE CHILD
CARE SERVICES THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY TWO NINETY TWO EXPANDS
OUR STATE'S CAPACITY FOR
IMPOTENT TALLER TODDLER CHILD
CARE. BY INCREASING THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES.
CREATING A GRANT PROGRAM TO PAY
FOR NEW AND RENOVATED CHILDCARE
FACILITIES. AND ESTABLISHING A
FUND TO RECRUIT A NEW GENERATION
OF PROVIDERS.
BY INCREASING THE STATE'S
CAPACITY TO SERVE OUR YOUNGEST
CHILDREN THIS BILL WILL ENSURE
SURE THAT A CHILD'S PATH TO
SUCCESS.
STARTS THE SECOND HE OR SHE IS
BORN.
THIS BILL ENJOYS SUPPORT FROM
OUR SEVENTY ORGANIZATIONS IS A
WOMAN'S CAUCUS PRIORITY AND
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE METAPHOR PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
HOME MEMBERS WHO WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE RETIRED TO
VOTE.
MEDICARE PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK TO
ITEM TWO SIXTY THREE.
METAPHORICALLY THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN FIFTY SIX
BY FAMILY MEMBER LIMON AND
ACTUALLY THE FIRE PREVENTION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AT THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA
WHILE SEASON WAS WILDFIRE SEASON
WAS ONE OF THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE
AND COSTLY ON RECORD. I'VE SEEN
THE DEVASTATION FIRST HAND IN
THE DISTRICT AS WE REBUILD WE
MUST LOOK TO HOW TO PREVENT
THESE FIRES FROM HAPPENING.
AB NINETEEN FIFTY SIX DIRECTS
CALIFORNIA TO INCREASE THE SCALE
AND PACE OF FIRE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES TO ENSURE THOSE
ACTIVITIES HAPPEN YEAR ROUND.
THE BILL REESTABLISHES A FIRE
PREVENTION WORKING GROUP AND
CREATES A ROBUST YEAR ROUND
PREVENTION LOCAL ASSISTANCE
GRANT PROGRAM I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MEDICAL PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
BUT APART PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SEVENTY
ONE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM THREE OH NINE
BACK IN FILE ORDER AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY FOUR MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO
NINETY FOUR BY FAMILY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE AND ACTUALLY THE CHILD
CUSTODY. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OBERNOLTE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY TWO NINETY FOUR WOULD
REQUIRE A JUDGE WHO ENCOUNTERS
AN ALLEGATION OF CHILD ABUSE.
DURING A CHILD CUSTODY HEARING
TO REFER THAT ALLEGATION TO THE
LOCAL CHILD WELFARE AGENCY FOR
INVESTIGATION THIS WILL HELP
KEEP CHILDREN SAFE ESPECIALLY IN
CASES WHERE THE COURT IS UNABLE
TO ISSUE A PROTECTIVE ORDER FOR
THAT CHILD.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION
MATTER FOR PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE NO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE A TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES
ITEM THREE TEN TO PASS AND
RETAIN. ITEM THREE ELEVEN AB
TWENTY THREE OH FOUR
METAPHORICALLY THREE ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY THREE OH FOR BY SOME
REMEMBER HOLDEN AND OTHERS
ACTUALLY DETRACT.
THANK YOU OF SOME MEMBER HOLDEN
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER. AB TWENTY THREE
OH FOR TASK THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE OF
TRANSPORTATION STUDIES. TO STUDY
EXISTING TRANSIT PASS PROGRAMS
FOR STUDENTS.
THESE PROGRAMS TYPICALLY CONSIST
OF PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN A
TRANSIT AGENCY AND A SCHOOL
DISTRICT OR STUDENT BODY TO
PROVIDE BOTH TRANSIT PASSESTO
STUDENTS FOR FREE. OR AT A MORE
AFFORDABLE COST.
PROVIDING VIABLE TRANSIT TO
STUDENTS GET THEM OUT OF THEIR
CARS AND ON TO PUBLIC TRANSIT
EIGHTY NOT JUST EDUCATION BUT
OUR ENVIRONMENT AS WELL. AB
TWENTY THREE OR FOUR WILL
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMUNITY WITH A
CLEAR PICTURE OF THE STATUS OF
STUDENT TRANSIT PASS PROGRAM
STATEWIDE. THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR.
THANK YOU SEEING THEIR REQUEST
TO SPEAK META PARKWAYS OPEN THE
RUN. MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM THREE TWELVE AB TWENTY
THREE OH FIVE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE OH
FIVE BY SOME IN MY RODRIGUEZ
NECKTIE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ
YOU RECOGNIZE
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY
THREE OH FIVE QUALIFYING
EXISTING. PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RELATION BOARD CASE WHICH GIVES
PROBE JURISDICTION. OVER PEACE
OFFICER EMPLOYER ORGANIZATION
DISPUTES
THIS BILL GIVES SMALL POLICE
OFFICER OF MUSICIANS THE ABILITY
TO DEFEND THEMSELVES AGAINST
UNFAIR. LABOR PRACTICES CONTRACT
DISPUTES AND BAD FAITH
BARGAINING.
ARE STRICTLY ESCRIBO.
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MATTER PARK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE.
MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS WHOSE ARTICLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
BUT A PART PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY NINE NO FOR THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEMS THREE THIRTEEN THREE
FOURTEEN PASS AND RETAIN MOVING
TO ITEM THREE FIFTEEN AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY THREE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
THIRTY THREE BY SOME THE MEMBER
WOULD AND ACTUALLY THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
THANK YOU SOME EVER WOULD YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ARE RICE
RESENT AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY
THREE WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WITHIN THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES.
RESPONSE TO THE TUBS FIRE AND
OTHER NORTH BAY COMPLEX FIRES
CALLAWAY ES IS DONE AN
INCREDIBLE JOB ORGANIZING RELIEF
CLEAN UP AND RECOVERY EFFORTS.
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT HAS BECOME A
VERY FAMILIAR NARRATIVE IN THE
HEALTHCARE ARENA THERE'S BEEN
SIGNIFICANT SHORTAGE OF MENTAL
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
RESPONDERS.
TO HELP COMMUNITIES EXPERIENCING
TRAUMA. BOTH INDIVIDUALS WITH
PRE WITH THE PRE EXISTING MENTOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DISORDER. A
SURVIVOR'S.
AND MEMBERS OF A NEWLY
TRAUMATIZED COMMUNITY DID NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO THE NECESSARY
MENTAL HEALTH CARE NEEDS TO
ADDRESS THEIR NEEDS.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT IN
THE EVENT OF AN EMERGENCY
INDIVIDUALS HAVE ACCESS TO
NECESSARY MENTAL AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES DURING A
DISASTER. IN THE DAYS OF
RECOVERY AFTERWARDS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
NO YOU DON'T WOOD SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
COR CLUB GIRL. I AM.
REYES ARE VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WILL. CLOSE A ROPE. TIED
BUT I SIXTY FIVE.
KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS THREE SIXTEEN THREE
SEVENTEEN PASS RETAIN.
GRACIOUS FOLLOWED NUMBER THREE
EIGHTEEN.
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY EIGHT FIVE
MINUTES AGUIAR-CURRY CLERK
MARIE.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY THREE FORTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND ACTUALLY
WILDLIFE. IS AGUIAR-CURRY MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY EIGHT WILL HELP OFFSET THE
COST FOR RICE FARMERS. TO WINTER
FLOOD THEIR FIELDS THIS
AGRICULTURAL PRACTICE HAS MANY
BENEFITS.
FLOODING THE FIELD HELPS TO
DECOMPOSE RICE STRAW BETWEEN
GROWING SEASON. AND ALSO
PROVIDES CRITICAL WETLAND
HABITAT FOR ROUGHLY SIX MILLION
BIRDS IN CALIFORNIA.
HELPING FARMERS PAY TO MAINTAIN
HIS WEST LA REST BUT LANDS IS A
COST EFFECTIVE WAY TO ENSURE
MIGRATORY BOARD BIRDS CONTINUE
TO HAVE A HOME IN THE PACIFIC
FLYWAY. THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
SENIOR DISCLOSURE BAIT ON THE
ITEM. CLERK LIBERAL.
THIS OUT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE TIED ABOUT AYE SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM THREE NINETEEN IS AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTY CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE FIFTY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE AND
ACTUALLY THE UNCLAIMED PROPERTY
MAKING A PREPARATION THEREFORE.
MISTER OBERNOLTE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB TWENTY THREE
FIFTY WOULD CHANGE PROCEDURES
GOVERNING SEVERAL OF THE
ACCOUNTS OVERSEEN BY THE STATE
CONTROLLER TO MAKE THEM MORE
EFFICIENT. THIS BILL SPONSORED
BY THE STATE COMPTROLLER IT HAS
NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK OF NARAL I AM.
IT IS OUR TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A
AYE SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FOLLOWING THREE
TWENTY IS AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY
TWO CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE FIFTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW AND
ACTUALLY TO ELECTIONS MR LOW YOU
MAY OPEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS OF
THIS BILL CAME OUT OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEES.
RECOMMENDATIONS WITH RESPECT TO
COUNTY REGISTRAR OF VOTERS AND
REPORTABLE HEIRESS RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE.
THE MISS LOVE SCENE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
PEROT.
NOT A MODEL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT
OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARAGO.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY TWO.
KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM THREE TWENTY ONE.
IS AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY FOUR
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE FIFTY FOUR BY SOME A
MEMBER RUBIO AND ACTUALLY THE
FAMILY LAW. MS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE FIFTY FOUR WILL HELP
ENSURE EQUITY IN COURT
PROCEEDINGS BY MANDATING THAT WE
HAVE COURT REPORTERS PRESENT IN
CHILD CUSTODY AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PROCEEDINGS.
ACCESS TO A VERBATIM TRANSCRIPT
IS CRITICAL IN THE CRITICAL
COMPONENT DURING COURT HEARINGS
WHERE PARTY'S OVERWHELMINGLY
REPRESENT THEMSELVES.
WITHOUT A RECORD OF THESE
HEARINGS LITIGANTS ARE UNABLE TO
APPEAL DECISIONS THAT ARE
CONTRARY TO VICTIMS SAFETY.
IT CAN BE EXTREMELY DIFFICULT IF
NOT IMPOSSIBLE TO RECALL
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENED DURING
CHILD CUSTODY AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HEARINGS. WHERE MANY
TIMES OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE IN A
VULNERABLE FRAME OF MIND?
PROVIDING COURT REPORTERS IN THE
FAMILY LOCK IN FAMILY LAW CASES
IS AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF
JUDICIAL HEARINGS AND PROTECTS
THE BASIC LEGAL RIGHTS OF ALL
PARTIES INVOLVED.
I THINK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THING IS RUBIO.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CORP
LOW OF THE ROPE. ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF OF ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
SENATE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE IN THE. ALLIES
FORTY FIVE KNOWS TWENTY ONE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEM THREE TWENTY TWO.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM THREE TWENTY
THREE. AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY
EIGHT FIVE MISS CARILLO CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE FIFTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
EMPLOYMENT. RISK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO PERCENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY THREE FIFTY EIGHT A
BILL THAT WOULD STRAIN OUR
EFFORTS TO STAMP OUT
DISCRIMINATION. AND HARASSMENT
AND ALL STATE CONSTRUCTION TRADE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS. THE
CONSTRUCTION FIELD OFFERS GOOD
PAY A RETIREMENT PLAN AND HEALTH
CARE BENEFITS HOWEVER THIS FIELD
AND THESE BENEFITS ARE
PREDOMINANTLY. OF FOUR MEN
CURRENTLY IN CALIFORNIA WOMEN
MAKE UP ONLY TWO POINT FOUR
PERCENT A BUILDING TRADES
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
THIS BILL WILL HELP CREATE A
RETAIN MORE WOMEN IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY AND
BROUGHT IN THE AUTHORITY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS TO OVERSEE.
NONDISCRIMINATION EFFORTS AND
ENSURE GREATER PROTECTIONS FOR
WOMEN AGAINST HARASSMENT AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTY EIGHT ALSO
ALLOWS APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
TO INTERVENE TO STOP HARASSMENT
OR EVEN DISCONTINUE ELATION
SHIPS WITH EMPLOYERS WHO DO NOT
COMPLY. WITH THESE POLICIES
OVERALL THIS BILL WOULD
ENCOURAGE MORE WOMEN TO PURSUE A
CAREER IN CONSTRUCTION BY
HELPING THEM FEEL SAFE AND
PROTECTED. WHILE DOING THEIR
JOBS THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND ZERO NO
VOTES AND THANK YOU COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
SENIOR DISCLOSURE MADE ON THE
ITEM.
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
ZARA VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY VOTE.
I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE I'VE THREE TWENTY
FOUR. CB TWENTY THREE SIXTY.
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE SIXTY BY SUMMING MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AND ACTUALLY THE
PEOPLE NUTRITION.
MISS RODRIGUEZ.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY.
IN CALIFORNIA TWENTY PERCENT OF
CHILDREN HAVE ON RELIABLE ACCESS
TO HEALTHY MEALS. AND FOR MANY
STUDENTS THE ONLY NUTRITIONAL
MEAL IS THE DAY THE COME FROM
SCHOOL.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION. TO ESTABLISH BEST
PRACTICES FOR PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN SCHOOLS AND FOOD BANKS
THESE GUIDELINES WERE INCLUDE
INFORMATION ON FOOD HANDLING
REGULATIONS RECOMMENDATIONS ON
FOOD. AND COST CONTROL AND AN
EXAMPLE OF WRITTEN PARTNERSHIP
AGREEMENT. BY PROVIDING GUIDANCE
AND INFORMATION AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY WILL FACILITATE MORE
PARTNERSHIPS.
BETWEEN SCHOOLS AND FOOD BANKS
TO COMBAT BOOTS STOOD IN
SECURITY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
OUR VOTE.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
BILL.
HARPER LOOKED THE ROLL-ON.
WHO'S OUT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DECIDED VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALTERNATIVE AND I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WHAT A PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM
THREE TWENTY FIVE WE DISPENSE
WITH FILE ITEM THREE TWENTY SIX?
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM THREE TWENTY
SEVEN AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT CORPORATION.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT BY SELLING NUMBER
SALAS AND ACTUALLY GREENHOUSE
GASES. MISTER SALAS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
WOULD REQUIRE THEIR BEAT
QUANTIFY THE PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS FROM GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION PROGRAMS RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU MICHELLE SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK LIBERAL.
IT IS NOT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO GO.
CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE VOTE
I SIXTY FIVE.
THERE WAS ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM
THREE TWENTY EIGHT.
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY BY SOME A MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND ACTUALLY TO
FIRE PROTECTION. MS
AGUIAR-CURRY.
MAD.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY REQUIRES THE
OFFICE EMERGENCY SERVICES AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND
FIRE PROTECTION. TO DEVELOP
REGULATIONS GOVERNING
COORDINATION OF PRIVATE FIRE
CONTRACTORS DURING ACTIVE FIRES.
THIS BILL IS THE DIRECT RESULT
OF COMMUNICATION I HAD WITH OH
YES
I CAL FIRE FOLLOWING THE
WILDFIRES IN MANY OF OUR
DISTRICTS LAST FALL.
REPORTS INDICATED THAT THE
PRIVATELY CONTRACTED RESOURCES
AND EQUIPMENT WERE
UNDISTINGUISHED MOBILE FROM THE
STATE AND LOCAL PUBLIC
FIREFIGHTING AGENCIES.
THIS PART CONFUSION FOR MANY
CONSTITUENTS.
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY WILL
STRENGTHEN OVERALL EMERGENCY
RESPONSE STANDARDS TO BENEFIT
ALL FIRED RESOURCES I ASK FOR
YOUR I WROTE.
THANK YOU MS SAGER OCCURRED
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CORD LOVE THEIR ALL. ON MEMBERS
FOR.
BUT IS THERE TO VOTE ALL THE
RESOURCES OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER TOWN AND I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
THREE TWENTY NINE IS AB TWENTY
THREE NINETY FIVE CORPORATE.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY THREE
NINETY FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON AND ACTUALLY INSURANCE.
MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
BILL IS ABOUT PREVENTION AND
PREPAREDNESS AND LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE MARKET.
THIS BILL REQUIRE LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE TO SUBMIT MORE
DETAILED FINANCIAL INFORMATION
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
AND REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE GUARANTY
ASSOCIATION. TO ASSESS OVER AND
REPORT ANNUALLY TO THIS BODY THE
LEGISLATURE ON ITS CAPACITY TO
HANDLE PERSPECTIVE LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE OFTEN SEES.
BY PUTTING THESE GUARDRAILS INTO
STATUTE AB TWENTY THREE NINETY
FIVE SIX TO PREVENT INSOLVENCY
IS IN THE INDUSTRY AND MAKE SURE
THAT POLICY HOLDERS ARE LEFT
WITHOUT COVERAGE IF ONE OF THESE
COMPANIES CAN NO LONGER SUSTAIN
ITSELF. THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
NOT A SINGLE NO VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I HOPE.
THINGS CALDERON SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
QUICKLAW PAROLE.
WIZARD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM THREE THIRTY IS AB
TWENTY FOUR A FOUR BY MISTER
O'DONNELL CLERK WILL READ.
SOME REAL TWENTY FOUR OH FOUR BY
SALLY MEMBER O'DONNELL AND
ACTUALLY AN OIL REVENUE MAKING A
PREPARATION THERE FOR.
MISTER O'DONNELL THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I RISE TO RESENT AB TWENTY FOUR
FOUR WHICH WILL ELIMINATE THE
CAP ON OIL TRUST FUND AND HELP
ENSURE THE CLEAN UP. OF A VAN
OIL WELLS IN MY DISTRICT.
THE LONG BEACH ISLANDS ARE HOME
TO THE WILMINGTON OILFIELD ONE
OF THE LARGEST OIL AND NATURAL
GAS FIELDS. IN THE UNITED
STATES.
BECAUSE THESE OPERATIONS ARE
LOCATED ON STATE LANDS THE STATE
RECEIVES A SHARE OF THE NET
PROFITS FROM THESE OPERATIONS
WILL BE PARTIALLY RESPONSIBLE.
OR CLEANING UP THE SITE WHEN
OPERATIONS SEES.
TO ENSURE THE STATE HAS THE
FUNDS NECESSARY TO DECOMMISSION
THE WELLS AND MITIGATE POTENTIAL
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS.
A PORTION OF THE STATE'S PROFITS
ARE DEPOSITED IN THE OIL TRUST
FUND.
HOWEVER THIS FUND HAS A CAP OF
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THAT FALLS FAR SHORT OF THE OVER
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
ESTIMATED COST OF CLEANING UP
THE WELLS.
AB TWENTY FOUR OH FOR ELIMINATES
THE THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
CAP ON THE FUN WHICH ALLOW THE
FUN TO GROW AND COVER THE
EVENTUAL COST OF OIL CLEAN UP.
IN MY DISTRICT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
PAYMENTS O'DONNELL SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
COR GLOBAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
THESE ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO SARAJEVO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
SIX
KNOWS ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WERE
FILE ITEM THREE THIRTY ONE AB
TWENTY FOUR OF SEVEN CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY FOUR OF
SEVEN BY SOME THE MEMBER TING
AND EXPLAIN TO RECYCLING.
MISTER TECH.
THANK IMAGE SPEAKER AB TWENTY
FOUR OH SEVEN TASK THE SECRETARY
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION.
TO CONVENE THE LITHIUM ION CAR
BATTERY RECYCLING ADVISORY
GROUP.
AS WE HAVE MORE LECTURED
VEHICLES ON THE ROAD WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO WITH ALL
THE LITHIUM ION BATTERIES. AS
THEY GET USED BY THESE VEHICLES
ARE THE BILL CURRENTLY HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECT FOR YA
THROUGHOUT.
THEY EMERGED BANG SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
OUR GLOBAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
WIZARD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTED
TO SARAJEVO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE IN TELL A VOTE AYE
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FOLLOWING THREE THIRTY
TWOS AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTEEN
COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
FIFTEEN BY SOME A MEMBER
CALDERON AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT. MISTER
CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT ALLOW
CALPERS TO SET THE COMPENSATION
FOR ITS CHIEF HEALTH DIRECTOR OR
DEPUTY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OFFICER POSITIONS.
HAVING COMPENSATION FOR ITS C.
H. D. AND D. E. L. POSITION SET
BELOW THAT OF SIMILAR PUBLIC
AGENCIES.
AND THE PRIVATE SECTOR MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR THE CALPERS BOARD
TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN TALENT IN
THESE POSITIONS A NEAR CONSTANT
HIRING PROCESS FOR THESE
POSITIONS UNDERMINES CALPERS
ABILITY. TO PLAN FOR THE
SECESSION.
OF ITS EXECUTIVE LEADERSHIP TEAM
AND MEET ITS FIDUCIARY DUTIES
THIS BILL WILL GIVE THE CALPERS
BOARD THE AUTHORITY TO APPOINT
AND FIX THE COMPENSATION OF ITS
C. HD IN THE E. L. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON.
SEE NO DISCUSSION BAKER COOPER
THE ROLE. ON MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLLING TIDE OF AN AYE
SIXTY THREE. KNOWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM THREE
THIRTY THREE IS AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE CLERK WILL READ. AT
SOME LEVEL TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
ONE TO BUY SOMETHING MEMBER MARK
STONE AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE POLLINATORS. MISTER STONE
EMAIL OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
CYCLE A BIT ABOUT MONARCH
BUTTERFLIES.
YES THIS WOULD PROTECT MONARCH
BUTTERFLIES BOTH THEIR HABITAT
AND THE RESTING AREAS BUT IT'S
ACTUALLY ABOUT POLLINATORS
WHICH ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
TO AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY ACROSS
THE STATE. AS IT TURNS OUT THE
HABITATS TO SUPPORT MONARCH
BUTTERFLIES ALSO SUPPORT OTHER
POLLINATORS.
NOW YOU MIGHT ASK APPROPRIATELY
R. MONARCHS ACTUALLY GOOD
POLLINATORS NO THEY'RE NOT.
BUT THE OTHER SPECIES THAT HAVE
WITH APOTEX OR THE POLLINATORS
THAT WE RELY ON ACROSS THE STATE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTES.
THEY MISSED DOWN SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK GLOBAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IS THERE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
COUNTY THAT I SHOULD BE SEVEN
KNOWS THREE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM THREE THIRTY FOUR IS
AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
BY FAMILY MEMBER ARAMBULA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE MEDI
CAL.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY AIMS TO
RAISE THE INCOME LEVEL OF THE
AGED AND DISABLED MEDICAL
PROGRAM.
BETTER KNOWN AS THE A IN THE
PROGRAM TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
EIGHT PERCENT OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL.
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT MOST ADULTS
CAN NOW QUALIFY FOR MEDI CAL. IF
THEY HAVE INCOMES BELOW ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT PERCENT
OF FPL.
THE ACA HOWEVER DID NOT CHANGE
THE INCOME LEVEL FOR THE MEDI
CAL AGED AND DISABLED PROGRAM
WHICH IS EQUIVALENT TO A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY THREE PERCENT. OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
THIS ALSO MEANS THAT A SIXTY
FOUR YEAR OLDS RIGHT NOW WITH
FREE MEDICO CAN LOSE IT THE DAY
THAT THEY TURN SIXTY FIVE YEARS
OLD.
A SENIOR WITH AN INCOME OF JUST
ONE DOLLAR OVER THE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE PERCENT OF FPL. IS
ONLY ELIGIBLE FOR MEDI CAL WITH
AN EXPENSIVE SHARE OF COST.
THIS CREATES A SIGNIFICANT
BARRIER TO HEALTH CARE FOR
SENIORS TO ACCESS AFFORDABLE
HEALTH CARE BECAUSE THEY ARE
FORCED TO CHOOSE BETWEEN PAYING.
FOR RENT AND FOOD OR THE MEDI
CAL SHARE OF COST.
RAISING THE AMD INCOME LIMIT TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT PERCENT
OF THE FEDERAL PARTY LIMIT. IS
THE SIMPLE MOST OF COST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO ENSURE THAT LOW
INCOME SENIORS HAVE EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE HEALTHCARE.
AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY WILL
ENSURE THAT THIS VULNERABLE
POPULATION OF LOW INCOME SENIORS
ARE TREATED FAIRLY AND CAN HAVE
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE MEDICAL
CARE.
I HUMBLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR RAY MILLAND
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK LIBERAL. ON MEMBERS.
RESIDE A VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS BUT IT IS THERE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TALLY THE VOTE.
UP.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE A VOTE. AYE
SIXTY THREE KNOWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM
THREE THIRTY FIVE AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY THREE.
GREGORY.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
THREE BY SOME THE MEMBER SALAS
AND ACTUALLY THE TRANSPORTATION.
MISTER SALAS.
VIGOROUS SPEAKER MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
THREE WOULD ESTABLISH A SOME
ACCOUNT OF THE STATE HIGHWAY
ACCOUNT.
THE COMEDY DEPOSITS AND
EXPENDITURES OF MONEY IS
RELATIVE TO MONSTER INSPECTION
TESTING SERVICES.
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
SEEING THEIR DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CARP WILL OPEN ROLL-ON.
HIS ARE ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE HER OWN TIME
AND I SIXTY EIGHT. NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM THREE
THIRTY SIX IS AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY FOUR CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOR THIRTY
FOR BY FAMILY MEMBER BLOOM AND
ACTUALLY TO HEALTH AND ALL
POLICIES. MISTER BELOW. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOR THIRTY
FOUR AND SHRINES THE HEALTH IN
ALL POLICIES TASK FORCE INTO A
PERMANENT PROGRAM. AND WILL
ALLOW US TO USE ITS GREAT
ACRONYM PERMANENTLY AS WELL
HIGHER.
THIS TASK FORCE IS THE FIRST OF
ITS KIND IN THE NATION.
AND BRINGS TOGETHER COUNT THEM
EIGHTEEN STATE AGENCIES
DEPARTMENTS AND OFFICES TO
IDENTIFY PRIORITY PROGRAMS
POLICIES AND STRATEGIES.
PROMOTE HEALTH CONSIDERATIONS IN
DECISION MAKING.
WITHIN THE AGENCIES AND TO
IMPROVE THE HEALTH OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
BECAUSE OF THEIR WORK HIGH APP
HAS CREATED PROGRAMS THAT
INCREASE HEALTH THESE TREES IN
SCHOOLS. AND PROVIDES NATURAL
CANOPY AND HE REALLY CAN SCHOOLS
AND DEVELOPS HEALTH AND EQUITY
TOOLS IN STRAIGHT IN STATE.
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING THE HIGH
UP TASK FORCE HAS PROVEN HAS A
PROVEN TRACK RECORD FOR
PROMOTING. A HEALTHIER
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE THEIR
GOOD WORK AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
THAT WILL GET USE THAT GREAT
ACRONYM.
HIGH UP.
ON A PERMANENT BASIS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CLUB SCENE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLICK LIBERAL. AND VOTE.
IS THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
THIS OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY
VOTE I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
THREE THIRTY SEVEN IS AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY ONE COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR FORTY
ONE BY SOME THE MEMBER FRAZIER
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THAT
SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN DELTA.
MISTER FRAZIER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FOUR FORTY ONE. WILL DIS
WILL SECURE DESPERATELY NEEDED
FUNDING TO REMOVE ABANDONED
COMMERCIAL VESSELS THROUGHOUT
THE DELTA.
BENDING VESSELS ARE A MASSIVE
PROBLEMS SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN
DELTA.
AND THERE ARE ROUGHLY TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY ABANDONED VESSELS
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO COMPLETELY
ERADICATE.
THESE VESSELS POSE A DIRECT
THREAT TO THE DELTA ENVIRONMENT.
THE NAVIGATION OF THE DELTA AND
THOUGH ENTIRE STATE'S WATER
QUALITY.
THE LEECH ASBESTOS LEAD
PETROLEUM AND MANY OTHER
DANGEROUS TOXINS INTO OUR WATER
SUPPLY.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT AERIAL
SURVEY ABOUT FIFTY FOUR
ABANDONED COMMERCIAL VESSELS IN
THE DELTA REGION AND THE COST OF
AN AVERAGE OF FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO REMOVE.
UNLIKE RECREATIONAL VEHICLES
COMMERCIAL VESSEL VESSELS DO NOT
HAVE ANY AVAILABLE FUNDING FOR
REMOVAL.
THIS BILL RE DIRECT STATE
PROPERTY LEASE REVENUE WITHIN
THAT FIVE DELTA COUNTIES OF
CONTRA COSTA SACRAMENTO SAN
JOAQUIN SOLANO IN YELLOW. INTO A
NEW ACCOUNT FOR THE REMOVAL OF
BAND AND.
COMMERCIAL VESSELS.
THIS NEW ACCOUNT WOULD BE
MANAGED BY THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION AS THEY WILL WORK
LOCAL AGENCIES TO REMOVE THE
ABANDONED VESSELS.
THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THINK THIS FRAZIER.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CORP LOVE THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS.
WHO IS OUR TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE.
I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WERE FILE
ITEM THREE FORTY ONE AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY FIVE.
GREGORY. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY FIVE BY SOME REMEMBER
GALLAGHER AND ACTUALLY THE
FISHING.
MISTER GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I AM PROUD T PRESENT AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE THIS BILL
REQUIRES DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE TO CONVENE A SPORT
FISHING ADVISORY GROUP BY
FEBRUARY FIRST TWENTY NINETEEN.
TO IDENTIFY BARRIERS TO SPORT
FISHING AND PROPOSE SOLUTIONS
THAT ADDRESS DECLINES IN SPORTS
FISHING LICENSES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
NAMES GALLAGHER SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTE.
IS ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTE
THIS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL CLOSE REAL TIME BUT
AYE AYES. SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
FOLLOW THREE FOUR TWO'S AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY TWO
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY TWO BY SELLING MEMBER
WHAT AND OTHERS ARE GOING TO
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE.
FRIEDMAN.
DOCTOR WHAT. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AS YOU ALL
KNOW THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY SYSTEMS AND
UNIVERSAL COVERAGE CONDUCTED
FIVE INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS TO
IDENTIFY THE BEST AND QUICKEST
PATH UNIVERSAL COVERAGE. FOR
CALIFORNIA EXPLORE STRATEGIES
FOR IMPROVING OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. OR THE TOPICS THAT THAT
SELECT COMMITTEE DISCUSSES THE
BY ABILITY ESTABLISHING A PUBLIC
OPTION IN AN EFFORT TO INCREASE
PLAN COMPETITION IMPROVE THE
AFFORDABILITY OF HEALTH CARE.
MANY COWS AT KENNY'S IT COUNTIES
IN CALIFORNIA ONLY HAVE TWO OR
FEWER HEALTH PLAN CHOICES IN
THIS LIMITED OPTION IS IMPACTING
NOT JUST THE PRICES OF HEALTH
CARE. ALSO THE QUALITY OF
HEALTHCARE THAT CONSUMERS
RECEIVE.
HOWEVER WE RECOGNIZE THE
COMPLICATIONS OF ESTABLISHING A
PUBLIC OPTION BECAUSE AMONG MANY
REASONS.
GO UP UP BECAUSE OF OTHER
REASONS AMONG OTHER REASONS
AMONG A LOT OF REASONS.
THE EXTENSION.
EXTENSIVE NETWORK OF LOCAL
HEALTH PLANS AND HEAVY
CONCENTRATION OF MANAGED CARE IN
THE EXISTING MEDICARE PROGRAM.
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY TWO WOULD
REQUIRE COVER CALIFORNIA TO
PREPARE A FEASIBILITY ANALYSIS
TO DETERMINE THE POSSIBILITY OF
A PUBLIC HEALTH INSURANCE OPTION
IN CALIFORNIA.
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY TWO
ESTABLISHED AS A POP APPROACH TO
THE PUBLIC OPTION ISSUE MIGHT
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
EXACTLY.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON.
WE STARTED VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL CLOSER ROLL TIDE BUT
I SIXTY TWO NO SEVEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
GONNA MOVE BACK IN THE FILE.
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE ZERO
THREE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM THREE OH
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY ONE BY MS
FRIEDMAN.
THE CAR CARILLO. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO SIXTY ONE BY FAMILY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND ACTUALLY TO
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES.
MS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU MISS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE
FOLLOWING YEARS OF SOCIAL UNREST
ARE LEGISLATIVE PREDECESSORS
ESTABLISHED THE POSITION OF
COMMUNITY REPRESENTATIVES TO
ENHANCE THE ABILITY OF SCHOOLS
TO INTERACT WITH BOTH OUR
STUDENTS AND THE COMMUNITIES
THAT THEY SERVE.
OVER THE PAST FORTY SEVEN YEARS
COMMUNITY REPRESENTATIVES HAVE
PROVEN TO BE ADAPTED SERVING
THEIR SCHOOLS. AND WHAT WAS ONCE
CONSIDERED TO BE A SHORT TERM
SOLUTION HAS BECOME AN INTEGRAL
COMPONENT FOR SCHOOL DISTRICT
WANTING TO BETTER CONNECT WITH
THE STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
FOR SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE THEY'RE THE
LINK TO THE NEIGHBORHOOD AND FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES OR
THOSE WITH A HIGHER NUMBER OF
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LURKERS WORK
ARE LEARNERS. THEY'VE WORKED TO
IDENTIFY PROBLEMS AND BARRIERS
AND TO IDENTIFY SOLUTIONS.
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY ONE UPDATES
ARE EDUCATION CODE TO REFLECT
COMMUNITY REPRESENTATIVES AS
PERMANENT CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES.
THE BILL ALSO PROVIDES A
FLEXIBILITY THAT DISTRICTS NEED
TO STAFF THE POSITIONS AS THEY
SEE FIT BY LIFTING THE PRE
PRESCRIBED CAP ON THE NUMBER OF
HOURS I REPRESENTATIVE CAN WORK.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
HE WAS FRIEDMAN SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CORPORAL. I'M.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ADDED THOUGH.
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A FORTY
EIGHT.
I FORTY EIGHT KNOWS TWENTY FOUR
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS BACK IN FILE ORDER.
BOTTOM THREE FORTY THREE IS AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY THREE BY
MISTER BONTA THAT CARP OR READ.
SOME LEGAL TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY
THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER BONTA AND
ACTUALLY THE STATE HIGHWAYS.
MISTER BONTA YOU MAY OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY THREE IS A DISTRICT BILL
THAT WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION TO RELINQUISH THE
CITY OF SAN LEANDRO THE PORTION
OF STATE ROUTE ONE EIGHTY FIVE.
THAT RUNS THROUGH THE CITY OF
SAN LEANDRO THIS QUARTER HAS
BECOME A SIGNIFICANT COMMUNITY
CONCERN GIVEN ITS CENTRAL
LOCATION AND POOR RECORD OF
MAINTENANCE THIS TRANSFER IS
CONTINGENT UPON THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION'S
APPROVAL. AND THE CITY OF SAN
LEANDRO CALTRANS
A MUTUAL AGREEMENT TO A FUNDING
PLAN AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY
THREE. TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY THREE
IS NECESSARY TO ENSURE THE
REGULAR UP KEEP AN IMPROVEMENT
OF A VITAL THOROUGHFARE IN SAN
LEANDRO AND IN ALAMEDA COUNTY.
THIS BILL WAS ON CONSENT IN
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE RECEIVING ZERO NO
VOTES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU CALLING.
THANK YOU MISS BONTA
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
OUR CLUB THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
WE THE ART ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS NARRATIVE OF.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE IN THAILAND I SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEMS.
THREE FORTY FOUR THREE FORTY
FIVE AND THREE FORTY SIX PASS
AND RETAIN.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM THREE FORTY
SEVEN AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
EIGHT COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
O'DONNELL AND ACTUALLY TO SCHOOL
FACILITIES. MISTER O'DONNELL.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT
ESTABLISHES A PILOT PROJECT FOR
THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. CUES TASK ORDER
CONTRACTING.
UNDER THIS BILL. LAUSD WILL BE
ALLOWED TO GO OUT TO BID ON
CONTRACTS FOR SERVICES AND
REPAIRS BEFORE THEY ARE NEEDED.
POOR EXAMPLE. DURING THE HOT
SEASON.
EIGHT TRACKS.
EIGHT TRACK SYSTEMS WILL BREAK
DOWN GOING OUT TO BID AFTER
QUITMAN MALFUNCTION THIS TAKES
TIME AND WILL BE COSTLY.
IT'S SIMPLE SUPPLY AND DEMAND.
DELAY REPAIRS MAY ALSO AN IMPACT
INSTRUCTION AND STE ANY STUDENTS
ABILITY TO LEARN.
BY HAVING CONTRACTS IN PLACE
EARLIER THIS BILL WILL ENABLE LA
U. S. DO YOU TO RESPOND TO
REQUESTS REPAIRS WHEN. THEY ARE
NEEDED AND WILL SAVE THE
DISTRICT MONEY BECAUSE THE
PRICES ARE PRE DETERMINED. AYE
ASPIRIN I'VE.
THANK YOU MISTER OF O'DONNELL.
SAMEER DISCUSSION DEBATE OR
GLOBE ROLL-ON VOTE.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUT OF VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL TALLY VOTE I SIXTY
SIX NEWS ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEMS
THREE FORTY EIGHT AND THREE
FORTY NINE.
WE DISPENSE WITH FILE ITEM THREE
FIFTY.
WE'RE AT THREE FIFTY ONE THIS IS
AB TWENTY FIVE.
ONE BY MISTER KANSEN CHU THE
CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE OH ONE
BY SELLING MEMBER KANSEN CHU AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE DRINKING
WATER. MISTER CHIU.
CHECK YOUR MISTER SPEAKER SAM
MEMBERS AB TWENTY FIVE FULL ONE
WOULD INCREASE ACCESS TO CLEAN
DRINKING WATER. BY EXPANDING THE
STATE WATER BOARDS AUTHORITY TO
REQUIRE CONSOLIDATION OF SMALL
WATER SYSTEM WAS LAST DAM
FIFTEEN ONE FIVE OF CONNECTIONS.
BUT THE DATA ARE CONSISTENTLY
EXPERIENCING POOR WATER QUALITY.
CURRENT LAW ALREADY ALLOWED THE
WATER BOARD TO REQUIRE A
CONSOLIDATION AND EXPANSION OLD
SERVICES TO WATER SYSTEMS. THEY
ARE STRUGGLE TO PROVIDE CLEAN
DRINKING WATER. THIS BILL FOCUS
ON REALLY SMALL WATER SYSTEMS.
THAT ARE OFTEN OVERLOOKED BUT
ARE THE MOST VULNERABLE. A LOT
OF TOOLS WATER SYSTEMS ARE NEXT
DOOR TO LARGER O. WATER SYSTEM
THAT CAN EASILY IS PHONE BILLS
FEW OF CUSTOMERS.
MY BILL WILL ALLOW THOSE WHO ARE
THAT IS TO HAPPEN WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING. THAT THOSE STATE
DO OVER WOULD HAVE ADEQUATE
FUNDING PRIOR TO REQUIRING SUCH
A CONSOLIDATION.
I UNDERSTAND THAT.
THAT DISSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES HAS CONCERN
BLISTERS COST OF CONSOLIDATION
AND I'M WORKING.
WORK IT WOULD COME WAS FROM TO
FURTHER CLARIFY DE EXISTING LAW.
I URGE FOR EUROPE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU.
ST NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON DESIRE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY VOTES EYES
FORTY SEVEN KNOWS TWENTY ONE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WERE
FILE ITEM THREE FIFTY TWO. AB
TWENTY FIVE OUT TO CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE A TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WHAT IN OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE HEALTH CARE.
DOCTOR WOULD THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB TWENTY
FIVE OH TWO WOULD REQUIRE THE
SECRETARY OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY. TO
ESTABLISH IMPLEMENT AND
ADMINISTER THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
CARE PAYMENTS DATABASE TO
COLLECT INFORMATION ON THE
ACTUAL COSTS OF HEALTHCARE.
THE BILL AS A FIRST STEP IN A
DATA DRIVEN TO COST CONTAINMENT
EFFORTS WILL SERVE AS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL IN MONITORING
TRENDS IN HEALTHCARE SPENDING IN
PRICING.
THE COST OF HEALTH CARE IS
RISING TREMENDOUSLY AND RAPIDLY
THIS IS PUTTING A HEAVY BURDEN
ON CONSUMERS AND EMPLOYERS.
COLLECTING THE DATA ONE FIRM
INFORM POLICYMAKERS ON HOW TO
ESTABLISH COST CONTAINMENT
MEASURES. THAT IS THAT ARE
SUSTAINABLE FOR EVERYONE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU THAT WOULD.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CARCLUB
ROLL-ON.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUR VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLLING TIED
ABOUT AYE SIXTY THREE. DOES ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS I
WANNA GO BACK IN THE FILE.
TO PICK UP AN ITEM FOR WHICH WE
PASS TEMPORARILY THIS IS FILE
ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY NINE AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY TO BY MISTER SANTIAGO.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX THIRTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO
AND ACTUALLY A PACKAGING AND
LABELING. MISTER SANTIAGO.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY TO AT THE CALIFORNIA
SLACK BILL LAWS TO. HAVE
ADDITIONAL EXEMPTIONS TO PROVIDE
MANUFACTURERS AND RETAILERS
WRIGLEY GREATER CLARITY AND
CERTAINTY REGARDING THE VARIOUS
REQUIREMENTS FOR PRODUCTS IN
FOOD PACKAGING.
I MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS SANTIAGO SEEING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLERK LIBERAL. MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS THERE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE A ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
OKAY MEMBERS BACK AND FILE
ORDER.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM THREE FIFTY
THREE THAT'S A. B..
TWENTY FIVE A THREE BY MISS
IRWIN THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE A
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN
AND ACT GOING TO BUSINESS.
MISSOURI.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWENTY FIVE A THREE WOULD ALLOW
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. TO
ADMINISTRATIVELY DISSOLVED
DOMESTIC CORPORATIONS ANALYSES
OF CEASE DOING BUSINESS FOR AT
LEAST FIVE YEARS AND OF PAID ALL
TAXES AND FILLED OUT ALL RETURNS
DO UP TO THAT DATE THEY STOP
DOING BUSINESS.
CURRENTLY THE FTP LACKS THE
AUTHORITY TO DISSOLVE AN ENTITY
TO STOP THE ACCRUAL OF MINIMUM
OUR ANNUAL TAX.
THE TAX SETS OF THE ENTITIES
HAVE BEEN THAT OF CEASE DOING
BUSINESS OPERATIONS CONTINUE TO
BE ON THE DEPARTMENT'S
ACCOUNTING SYSTEM FOR UP TO
TWENTY YEARS. AND EVEN AFTER
TWENTY YEARS HAVE PASSED AND THE
TAX DEBTS ARE WIPED AWAY THE
ENTITIES WILL FOREVER REMAIN IN
THE STATE'S ACCOUNTING SYSTEM.
AB TWENTY FIVE A THREE WILL
CORRECT THIS AND GRANT THE FTP
THIS ORDER TO CLEAR THESE
ENTITIES FROM THEIR BOOKS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE FOR THIS GOOD GOVERNMENT
BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER WHEN.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUICK THE RUN ON MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSER ROLL TIDE OF
AYE SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE
.
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM THREE
FIFTY FOUR.
THAT IS AB TWENTY FIVE FOURTEEN
BY MR THURMAN THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE PORT.
ABSOLUTELY BY FOURTEEN BY SUMMER
THURMOND AND OTHERS IN ATLANTA
PEOPLE INSTRUCTION.
THIS SHOULD THURMOND YOU MAY
OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES ARE RICE RESENT AB
TWENTY FIVE FOURTEEN. AT THIS
BILL WILL PROVIDE RESOURCES TO
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS THE PROMOTE
MULTILINGUAL IN BILINGUAL
EDUCATION
IT RECOGNIZES THAT THERE
BENEFITS THAT WE ALL GAIN WHEN
YOU CAN LEARN A SECOND LANGUAGE.
AND IT RECOGNIZES THAT OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS NEED MORE
RESOURCES.
A POOR ENGLISH LEARNERS OUT THE
BILL WOULD PROVIDE GRANTS TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE DUAL
LANGUAGE IMMERSION PROGRAMS FOR
ENGLISH LEARNERS AND FOR NATIVE
ENGLISH SPEAKERS. AS WELL AS
EARLY LEARNING TOOL LANGUAGE
PROGRAMS FOR OUR ENGLISH
LEARNERS ARE ALLOW US TO
CONTINUE TO BUILD ON THE
INCREDIBLE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE.
IN CREATING A MULTI LINGUAL AND
BI LINGUAL SOCIETY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE FOR AB TWENTY FIVE
FOURTEEN.
THANK YOU MRS THURMAN. SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
COR CLUB THE ROLE I'M.
THESE ARE ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THE CLERK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES
FIFTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT.
THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WERE
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE. FIFTY
FIVE.
AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTEEN BY
DOCTOR WOULD THAT CORPORAL READ.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTEEN BY SOME REMEMBER WHAT
AND OTHERS IN ATLANTA HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE DOCTOR WOULD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
SOME HAVE GREAT HEALTH CARE SOME
HAVE INSURANCE BUT IT'S
EXPENSIVE SOME BUYING COVERAGE
ON AFFORDABLE SOME HAVE MEDI CAL
BUT STRUGGLE TO FIND CARE AND
SOME HAVE NOTHING.
WE ALL KNOW HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS
QUANTITATIVE AND THERE IS NO
QUICK FIX.
THIS BILL AUTHORIZED CREATES THE
ADVISORY PANEL. ON HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS AND UNIVERSAL
COVERAGE WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
AN INDEPENDENT PANEL THAT WILL
DEVELOP A PLAN INCLUDES A
TIMELINE OF. OF THE BENCHMARKS
AND STEPS NECESSARY TO REACH THE
GOAL OF UNIVERSAL COVERAGE.
DURING OUR SELECT COMMITTEE
HEARINGS WE DUG DEEP INTO THIS
COMPLEX POLICY ISSUE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT BEAT TO BE
SUCCESSFUL WE MUST DEFINE A
PATHWAY THAT ADDRESSES A NUMBER
OF ISSUES INCLUDING CHALLENGES
TO RELATED TO STATE AND FEDERAL
LAW. THIS BILL PROVIDES THE MAP
AND THE PATH WE NEED TO SUPPORT
AND I'M ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
IT'S RESPONSIBLE PROPER WAY TO
ADDRESS A MULTI MULTI FACETED
SYSTEM AS MANY MOVING PARTS
SUCCESS IN THE END WILL BE THE
CREATION OF SUSTAINABLE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. PROVIDES
QUALITY AND AFFORDABLE
HEALTHCARE TO EVERYONE IN
CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I BO.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CORD CORPORAL MEMBERS.
HIS OUR TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE
ICE. FORTY FIVE KNOWS TWENTY
THREE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM THREE
FIFTY SIX AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
THREE BY MR STONE THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY THREE BY SOME A MEMBER
MARK STONE AND ACTUALLY THE
INMATES. MISTER SHELDON YOU MAY
OPEN THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS WHEN AN INMATE IS
CONSIDERED INDIGENT UNDER RULES
THAT CDC ARE ACTUALLY UNDER THE
STATUTE THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE.
PERSONAL HYGIENE PRODUCTS AND
ACCESS TO THE COURTS.
BUT IF THEY'RE NOT INDIGENT THEN
THEY HAVE TO FIND A LOT OF THIS
THEMSELVES RIGHT NOW THE CDC OUR
STATUTE OR THE STATUE THE
GOVERNESSES SAYS THAT IF AN
INMATE HAS LESS THAN A DOLLAR.
IN THERE AND MADE ACCOUNT THAT
THEY ARE INDIGENT ALL THIS BILL
DOES IS RAISE THAT TO TWENTY
FIVE DOLLARS. SO THAT THAT
SOMEONE WHO IS ACTUALLY A DIGIT
IS NOT HAVING TO GO BURDEN THEIR
FAMILIES. BURDEN OTHERS AND
STILL HAVE ACCESS TO HYGIENE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE ACCESS TO
THE COURTS WORKING CLOSELY WITH
CDC ARE TO ENSURE THAT THIS IS A
CORRECT NUMBER. FOR OUR INMATES
IF WE WANT TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM.
TREAT PEOPLE WITH DIGNITY WHILE
THEY'RE IN PRISON THIS IS AN
APPROPRIATE MOVE TO MAKE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EITHER.
THANK YOU MISTER STONE SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
IT IS OUT OF OUT ALL THE
RESEARCHERS ARE THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE SARAJEVO.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLAND TALLY THE VOTE AYE
AYES FORTY SIX KNOWS FIFTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS I AM
GOING TO LIFT THE CALL.
ON FILE ITEM TO SIXTY NINE.
THAT IS AB NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
BY KANSEN CHU THE CLERK WILL
POST.
HOMEOWNERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE. TALLY THE VOTE
EYES TWENTY SEVEN A FIVE THE
MEASURE FAILS.
AND MR CHIU.
MISTER CHIU NOTICES
RECONSIDERATION.
MEMBERS BACKING FILE ORDER WE'RE
GOING TO PASS RETAIN A FILE
ITEMS THREE FIFTY SEVEN.
AND THREE FIFTY EIGHT WE
DISPENSE WITH FILE ITEM THREE
FIFTY NINE.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
THREE SIXTY.
AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN BY
MISTER GRAY.
CLERK READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY SEVEN BY SOME A MEMBER
GRAY AND ACTUALLY THE TAXATION
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX
LEVY.
MR GREAT THANK YOU THE SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY
SEVEN WILL CREATE. AN ABOVE THE
LINE DEDUCTION TO ENSURE THAT
ALL TAXPAYERS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR INCOME BRACKET WILL BE
ABLE TO RECEIVE THE BENEFIT. OF
DEDUCTING THE COST OF THE UNION
MEMBERSHIP DUES FROM THEIR
ANNUAL GROSS INCOME.
UNDER EXISTING STATE AND FEDERAL
LAW TAXPAYERS ARE PROVIDED THE
OPTION TO CLAIM THE STANDARD
DEDUCTION OR TO ITEMIZE THEIR
DEDUCTIONS.
UNDER EXISTING LAW ARE ONLY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ITEMIZE THEIR
DEDUCTIONS ARE ALLOWED THE
OPTION OF DEDUCTING THE UNION
DUES AND INITIATION FEES TO THE
EXTENT THAT THEIR ITEMIZED
DEDUCTIONS. EXCEED TWO PERCENT
OF THEIR ADJUSTED GROSS INCOME.
I ARRESTED ILLUSTRATES THE
TAXPAYERS WITH HIGHER INCOMES
ARE MORE LIKELY TO ITEMIZE
DEDUCTIONS WHILE THOSE WITH
LOWER INCOMES ARE MORE LIKELY TO
OPT FOR THE STANDARD DEDUCTION.
ALLOWING INDIVIDUALS TO DEDUCT
FROM HIS OR HER GROSS INCOME THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY PAID IN
MEMBERSHIP DUES TO LABOR
ORGANIZATION.
WE'LL BOTH REDUCE THE TAX BURDEN
FACED BY LOWER AND MIDDLE INCOME
TAXPAYERS WHO DO NOT ITEMIZE
THEIR RETURNS. AND ENSURE THAT
ALL TAXPAYERS RECEIVE EQUITABLE
BENEFITS FOR THE SAME ON
REIMBURSABLE EMPLOYMENT
ACTIVITIES.
AB TWENTY FIVE SEVEN SEVEN
SUPPORT BY MANY OF OUR LABOR
ALLIES INCLUDE INTERNATIONAL
LONGSHORE WAREHOUSE UNION PEACE
OFFICERS RESEARCH ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA. AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GRAY MISTER
HARPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS.
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN FEDERAL TAX
BILL MADE IT EASIER FOR
EVERYONE.
TO FILE THEIR TAXES BY DOUBLING
THE STANDARD ITEMIZED DEDUCTION
ELIMINATING MISCELLANEOUS
DEDUCTIONS.
THIS ALSO ENDED THE ABILITY FOR
EXPENSES OF MOST EMPLOYEES TO BE
DEDUCTED.
RARE THAN CREATE A TAX DEDUCTION
FOR ALL EMPLOYEES ARE EMPLOYEE
BUSINESS EXPENSES AB TWENTY
THREE AUG TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY
SEVEN ONLY CREATES A DEDUCTION
FOR UNION DUES.
UNION WORKERS SHOULD NOT BE THE
ONLY WORKERS BENEFITING FROM A
TAX CREDIT AND UNION ACTIVITY
SHOULD NOT BE SUBSIDIZED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I GET IT
THAT FOLKS WANT TO SUCK UP TO
THE UNIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT THIS IS REALLY
OVERBOARD I URGE A NO VOTE.
SEEING.
NO OTHER MEMBER I'M SORRY MISS
MELENDEZ.
YOU ARE WRECK THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER.
NOT SUCKING UP TO ANYBODY BUT I
DO HAVE CONSTITUENTS ARE UNION
MEMBERS NEVER REALLY LIKED THE
TAX BREAK SO THAT'S WHY I VOTED
FOR THIS BILL IN COMMITTEE.
SELF USUS JUDGMENT THINKS.
WE WE SHALL.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
MR GRAY YOU MAY CLOSE.
ALL THINK MY COLLEAGUES FOR A
LIVELY DEBATE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
CLARK LOVE THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLAND TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY ONE KNOWS TEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WERE
GOING TO MOVE BACK IN THE FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE ARE GOING
TO BE TAKING UP.
FILE ITEM THREE FORTY NINE THIS
IS FILE ITEM THREE FORTY NINE.
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY NINE BY DR
ARAMBULA.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY FOUR NINETY
NINE BY SOME A MEMBER ARAMBULA
AND ACTUALLY THE HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. DOCTOR ARAMBULA THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY NINE
PRESERVES HOW OUR STATE'S
MEDICAL LOSS RATIOS ARE
CALCULATED.
RISING HEALTHCARE COSTS
ESPECIALLY HEALTH INSURANCE
PREMIUMS CONTINUED TO BE A
CONCERN FOR CONSUMERS.
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY NINE IS
ANOTHER WAY THAT OUR STATE CAN
PRESERVE IMPORTANT ACA
PROTECTIONS FOR CONSUMERS.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD PRESERVE HOW
THE I'M ALL ARTS ARE CALCULATED
SO THAT MORE OF OUR PREMIUM
MONEY IS SPENT ON ACTUAL CARE.
AND LESS ON INSURANCE COMPANY
PROFITS IN OVERHEAD.
I AM COMMITTING TODAY.
TO TAKING AMENDMENTS THAT WILL
CODIFY OBAMA ERA REGULATIONS
THAT WILL MAINTAIN POWER I'M ALL
OURS ARE CALCULATED. AND WILL
KEEP THE EXISTING M. ALL OURS
THE SAME.
AS A PHYSICIAN AND LEGISLATOR
I'M COMMITTED TO ENSURING. THAT
MOST OF OUR PREMIUM DOLLARS GO
TOWARDS MEDICAL CARE AND NOT
TOWARDS ADMINISTRATIVE OVERHEAD
OR INSURANCE COMPANY PROFITS.
AND I ASK THAT WE AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY ENSURE THIS AS
WELL.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA SEEN
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK LOGAN ROLL-ON.
ROSARIO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THE MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY
NINE BE TO ALLOW AUTHORS TO TAKE
UP LATE AMENDMENTS ON
THE FOLLOWING BILLS ITEM TWENTY
NINE AB TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
CAMBIADO ITEM ONE FIFTY THREE AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY THREE DAVID
CHIU ITEM ONE SEVENTY SIX AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY SIX CHAO. ITEM
ONE NINETY AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY
FIVE BONTA ITEM TO AWAIT AB
TWENTY THIRTY ONE NINETY FOUR
DAILY IN ITEM FOUR FORTY THREE.
ITEM THEY SQUEEZE ME A. B.
THIRTY TO THIRTY TWO FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CALDERON MISS WALDRON FOR
PURPOSE OF WE OPPOSE THE MOTION
ON LATE AMENDMENTS.
MISS WALDRON IS WITHHOLDING
MISTER CALDERON MOVES.
THE RULE SUSPENSION SECONDED BY
MISTER GIBSON MEMBERS THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE.
ON THE RULES SUSPENSION CLERK
WILL. OPEN THE ROLL-ON STRIP
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
AND MISS WALDRON IS ASKING FOR A
NO.
S. CAULDRONS ASKING FOR AN I..
AND MISS WALDRON A NO.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL EYES FORTY NINE KNOWS
TWENTY THREE.
THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE AGAIN RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
ADOPT THE FLOOR AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE PENDING AT THE DESK. ON THE
FOLLOWING BILLS I'M TWENTY NINE
AB TWENTY TWENTY THREE COVER YOU
KNOW. I DON'T WANT TO DO THREE
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY THREE
DAVID CHIU I'VE ONCE EVERY SIX
AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY SIX SHALL
ITEM ONE NINETY AB. TWENTY NINE
TWENTY FIVE BONTA I'M TO AWAIT
AB THIRTY ONE NINETY FOUR DALY
AND ITEM FOR FORTY THREE AB
THIRTY TO THIRTY TWO FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CALDERON WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MEAN TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
I OPPOSE SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED BILLS ARE
OUTSPRINTED BACK ON FILE
.
MEMBERS WE ARE CONSENT
HELLINGER.
WE STILL HAVE THREE BILLS ON
CALLED OVER GOING TO TAKE A
CONSENT AS ANY MEMBER WISH TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FIFTY
NINE BY FAMILY MEMBER MCCARTY
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC TRUST LANDS MAKING
PREPARATIONS THERE FOR IT KIND
URGENCY THERE UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
MCCORKLE OVER THE ROLE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
THIS IS CONSENT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THIS IS CONSENT CALENDAR
MEMBERS.
WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE.
I TELL A VOTE I SEVENTY SIX NO
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED AND THE CLERK WILL READ
THE REMAINING ITEMS ON
SEN CALENDAR.
ASSIMILATING FORTY THREE WITH
URGENCY.
EYES SEVENTY SIX.
I SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO SUM ABLE
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE.
I SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO A SUMMIT
ON NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE BY
SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO CYNICAL
TWENTY EIGHTY SEVEN I SEVENTY
SIX NO ZERO SUM OF TWENTY ONE
FORTY FIVE I SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO
SINGLETON ONE FIFTY FIVE BY
SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO SIMPLE
TWENTY FIFTY FIVE. I SEVENTY SIX
NO ZERO A SINGLE TWENTY FORTY
SIX I SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO SUM OF
NINETY EIGHTY EIGHT I SEVENTY
SIX NO ZERO SYMBOL TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY ONE I SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO
SEVENTY FIVE TWENTY FOUR. BY
SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO CYCLE TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY TWO I SEVENTY SIX NO
ZERO ASSEMBLE TWENTY SIX SIXTY
SEVEN BY SEVENTY SIX NOCERA
ASSEMBLE TWENTY EIGHTY NINE I
SEVENTY SIX NOCERA SINGLE TWENTY
NINE OH FOUR. BY SEVENTY SIX
THOSE ZERO SUBTLETY AND FOURTEEN
I SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO SYMBOL
TIENEN SIXTY SEVEN I SEVENTY SIX
NO ZERO SIMPLE THIRTY ANY A. I
SEVENTY SIX NOCERA SIMILAR
THIRTY ONE FORTY NINE BY SEVENTY
SIX NO SIR AND ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TO FIFTY SIX BY SEVENTY
SIX.
NO ZERO.
MEMBERS HAVE PREPARED TO LIVE
THE CALL ON FILE ITEM THREE
FORTY NINE THIS IS AB TWENTY
FOUR NINETY NINE BY DOCTOR
RAYMOND OF THE CLERK WILL POST.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE. THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE EYES FORTY EIGHT KNOWS
TWENTY THREE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE AND TO FORTY FIVE
THAT IS AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
BY MISTER THIS AREA AND THE
CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF NO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT.
CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ON TIED ABOUT ICE FORTY
TWO KNOWS TWENTY FIVE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THERE WAS WE HAVE ONE REMAINING
ITEM ON CALL.
THIS IS AB TWO SEVEN NINE.
ARMY FILE ITEM TWO SEVEN NINE I
BELIEVE IT'S AB TWENTY NINETY
FOUR BY MISTER KALRA THE CLERK.
WILL POST. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE.
AYE AYES FORTY THREE KNOWS
TWENTY FIVE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
WEDNESDAY MAY THIRTIETH FLOOR
SESSION FROM TEN AM TO SIX PM
ALL OF OUR ITEMS REMAINING WITH
HOUSE RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MISTER
GIBSON SECONDS.
AT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL WEDNESDAY MAY THIRTIETH AT
TEN AM IN THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED.
AND MEMBERS BUDGET COMMITTEE IS
MEETING UPON ADJOURNMENT AND
ROOM FORTY TO VOTE TO. BUDGET
COMMITTEE IS MEETING IMMEDIATELY
AND ROOM FORTY TWO OH TWO